thanks to the defenses that we've built
so much of this year's this year has
been a year of recovery
we've we've enjoyed greater freedom than
at any time during the pandemic so far
thanks to the rapid progress of our
vaccination program our investment in
treatments and our decision to open up
during the warmer summer months we're in
a strong far stronger position than we
were last winter
but even as I stood but even as I stood
at this dispatch box in back in July
when I stood here to announce the major
Milestone of taking step four in our
roadmap I said and I quote Madam Deputy
speaker we know that the greatest risk
to the progress that we've made is the
possibility of another new variant
especially one that can escape immunity
and puncture the protective wall of our
vaccination program
we've always known that variants have
had the potential to knock us off our
course
and we've built the capacity to identify
and to respond to those that pose a
threat
the vast majority of new variants
present no risk whatsoever
since the summer there have been
hundreds of new variants but only one of
them
Omicron has been designated a variant of
concern
for example just last month I updated
the house from this dispatch box on ay
4.2
a new form of the Delta variant which
preliminary analysis showed at that time
might be more infectious I said then
that we would keep it under review and
that's what we decided and that's what
we did and we took no action
but Madam Deputy speaker Omicron is a
grave threat
we acted early to slow its spread
strengthening our testing regime and
placing 11 countries on the Travel Red
List
but despite those Swift steps the data
over the past few days has shown more
cause for concern
and I'd like to reinforce with the house
today to all honorable members why
Omicron represents such a risk to the
progress that we've all made so far
together
I will yes I'm grateful I'm listening
very carefully to the Secretary of
State's comments and the fact that he's
brought these measures to the house I
asked him yesterday uh whether if the
government had to bring further measures
in other than those being proposed today
during the recess whether he would give
a commitment at the dispatch box to
recall the house so that we could be
involved on behalf of our constituents
in making that decision he very kindly
agreed to take that matter away to
discuss it with the prime minister is he
able now at dispatch boards to commit
that if the government were to take
further measures to deal with Omicron
during the recess that the government
would recall the House of Commons so
that we're able to have all of the
evidence and be participate in taking
those decisions on behalf of the
constituents we represent
I of course understand the importance of
the question for my right or friend and
as he said himself he asked it yesterday
and he's understandably asked it again
today uh I hope he understands I am not
able to give that commitment alone it
wouldn't be a decision for me and my
department alone but it is something
that I know the government would
consider together seriously now Madam
Deputy speaker I I I want to I I I I I I
will yeah I'm very grateful to the
Secretary of State for giving away I
wonder whether he might consider going a
little bit further because since the
data is changing all the time almost by
the minute it's inconceivable that in a
week's time and a week after that we'll
be in the same place that we are today
this house needs to consider the
information available to it in near real
time and therefore will he go away and
consider whether it would be appropriate
now to ensure that the house is able to
consider these matters for sure next
week and the week after that yeah
imaginative speaker I will consider that
but it is uh important of course this is
my honorable friend is right to point
out this is a fast-moving situation and
it is right for the government continues
to monitor that and respond to that when
necessary but I hope that my honorable
friend will agree with me that right
here and now the matter that's being
debated the regulations in front of the
house this is the best possible response
that can be given by this Parliament
today now Madam Deputy speaker I I I
will then I need to make some progress I
will I'm very grateful to the Secretary
of State for giving away giving work if
he is going to consider these Masters
will he also include consideration of uh
the issue that obviously the virus
spreads if people are not able to
isolate so will he think about
addressing the the issue of statutory
lifting spreading the scope of SSP and
lifting it to a proper rate so people
can isolate not spread the virus and not
end up in our hospitals yeah I
understand Madam Deputy speaker and uh
The Honorable General will know already
currently in play there are some
measures in place such as uh the the
ability to get sick pay from day one
there are hardship funds but I
understand well The Honorable gentleman
has said he's asked us to to to to look
at that further and and and we will all
these matters are under review now
imagine if this week I do want to turn
to uh some of the information that no I
will have to I'll take an intervention
later for the honor gentleman but what
some of the things that we have learned
about this uh new varied and the first
thing is and these are things that we
know certainly is is it is a fast moving
situation in the last week we have been
able to determine these things with a
high degree of confidence first that it
is more transmissible Omicron is more
transmissible than the Delta variant we
can see that the growth in Omicron cases
here in the UK is now mirroring the
rapid increase that we are seeing in
South Africa and the current observed
doubling time is around every two days
although yesterday we reported there
were 4 713 confirmed cases of Omicron in
the UK the UK HSA estimate that for the
number of daily infections was 42 times
higher at two hundred thousand
scientists have never seen never seen a
covid-19 variant that's capable of
spreading so rapidly so we have to look
at what we can do to slow omicron's
advance so I
I I will to honor will lead that and I
will
if I'm a chrome but does he accept that
the government's mixed messaging has
been incredibly unhelpful telling people
that a tsunami of Omicron is on the way
but at the same time we can go on
partying absolutely undermines that
message will he have the moral courage
to say that we actually do need to
reduce our social contacts and will he
make it possible for people to do that
both with the sick pay we've already
talked about and with ensuring that
businesses get the financial support
they need if fewer people are going into
those business premises
I think what we need to do is are the
measures that are in front of the house
today and I hope that the the house will
support those I think those are the most
important measures that we can take
right now I will give both questions for
your stake for giving away but has heard
the uh statement or seen the statement
from Angelique catasi the head of the
South African Medical Board today who
says that the government's measures on
lockdown may be counterproductive that
Omicron is a mild form of covid-19 it
will have huge benefits for herd
immunity and protection and energy and
delaying its spread may give time for a
more virulent and pathogenic uh variant
to take hold and cause more deaths in
the UK
first of all I think my honor friend if
I heard him correctly talked about the
government's measures on lockdown I'm
not sure where he's seen these measures
on lockdowns they're certainly not here
today being presented by this government
on the issue of um whether this is
milder or not I will come to that very
shortly I will give way to my old friend
actually building on the point from my
honorable friend from Northwest
leicestershire and here in the right my
friends only just about to expand but
the question is this
when would we know whether Omicron gives
severe or mild disease and therefore if
it is mild how quickly would the
decision to be made that this would be
of an advantage to get rid of Delta and
get a herd immunity which doesn't create
strong disease
imagine this week if my animal friend
will allow me I'm about to come
precisely to the point that he raises so
the the second thing uh that about her
Omicron that I want to share is that
although we don't yet have a complete
picture of Omicron severity
even if even if severity is
significantly lower
then the much higher transmissibility of
Omicron means it still has the potential
to overwhelm the NHS
take take the current observed doubling
time of two years and let's say just for
argument's sake so so take that
let's take the current doubling time of
two days right and let's say just for
argument's sake if I say to all members
for argument's sake that Omicron was
only half as severe as Delta half a
severe after the lag between cases and
hospitalizations has taken effect then
this would mean it would only buy you
two days it would buy you two days
before Omicron hospitalizations reached
the same level as Delta
in English I I will later I will later
in England 10 people are confirmed to
have been hospitalized with the Omicron
variant now I know that some honorable
members they have said that because
confirmed hospitalizations from Omicron
are low then we don't need to act
but it's the fact that Omicron
hospitalizations are low that means it
is now the best time to act and we've
seen during previous waves we've already
seen this the lag between infections and
hospitalizations it's about two weeks
when infections are rising so quickly
we're likely to see a substantial rise
in hospitalizations before any measure
is starting to have an impact so there
really is no time to lose I will give
way
I think my friend's giving away and I
understand the Nuance Point that he's
making but just on forecasts will he
accept that many academics have doubted
the previous forecast describing them as
hysterical substantially inflated
consistently of confident lurid and
severely flawed we have had a problem
with inaccurate forecasts would he
accept that point
yes yes I absolutely accept that point
and with previous uh variants of covid
we have seen you know fourth casts and
estimates whether it's from academics or
think tanks and others that have been
completely off the market I completely
off the mic but all I would just say
gently to my honorable friend and other
honorable members just because forecasts
in the past ever have been wrong it
doesn't mean to say every estimate or
forecast is always wrong and I hope my
honorable friend will will note that I
will give away to my right honorable
friend I'm grateful to my right from a
friend for giving way he talks about
hospitalizations and the danger that
they may cause to the NHS but will he
reflect on the fact that it's not just
hospitalizations but it's the length of
stay in hospitals that determines how
many beds are occupied and evidence from
South Africa suggests not only are there
fewer hospitalizations but people are in
hospital for a much shorter time does
that is that reflected in his
calculations
uh yes sir I can confirm that to her on
my right on the phone first of all he's
absolutely right to make that point of
course it's not just about entering
hospital but it's about how many days
that individual is likely to say in in
hospital and currently with the Delta
variant it's I believe it's about
roughly about nine days an individual on
average stays in hospital and if that
was cut for example to five or six days
of course that would help with uh with
capacity now first of all we can't
assume that because what we are seeing
in terms of the hospitalization the
impact in South Africa or the
hospitalizations there are rising
rapidly there are hundreds of people on
ICU and ventilators that it's hard to
read across given that the average age
of the South African population I
believe is about 27 years for example so
it's hard to just completely read that
across but I hope he would agree with me
uh similar to the point I just made on
severity that even if the hospital stay
is half of what it is at the moment at
the rate that this thing is growing if
it continues to grow at that rate that
could be canceled out that benefit could
be canceled out in two days I'll give
weight to The Honorable gentleman yeah
I'm very grateful to what the Secretary
of State for giving way he's facing a
lot of criticism from behind him but he
should be assured that on these benches
we absolutely recognize the dangers of
the variants in front of him but does he
accept that having come into uh his post
saying that the end of restrictions was
irreversible but he has created an
expectation that he's going to
constantly uh ignore the scientific
advice which is why he's facing so much
disappointment behind him now
now I think the Old Gentleman may have
heard earlier when I started my remarks
uh I talk about what I said at this
dispatch box enjoy specifically about
the risk of a vaccine Escape variant now
I do want to talk about the vaccines and
this varied Madam Deputy speaker I I I
will I will give away one more time for
now to my honorable friend and then I
will come back to other honor friends
I'm very grateful and I think my views
on this are pretty well understood just
given the case that he's setting out I
think one thing I'm puzzled by is why
he's only going as far as he is can he
just explain to us
why in his estimation the measures he's
taking are equal to the situation which
he's describing
it's a bad industry it's a very fair
question as always for my honorable
friend the the measures that we are
setting out we are taking into account
the very best advice that we are being
given including uh making sure that
we're not just uh listening uh to every
piece of advice or every forecast that
we're seeing my honorable friend will
remember back in the summer if we had
listened to some of the advice we were
receiving we wouldn't have opened up in
the way that we did so we are taking
account of the advice deciding on
whether it should influence our decision
making and then coming to a balanced and
proportionate response which are the
measures uh that I I've talked of I will
talk about here today but also for
example increasing the booster program
which I will turn to in a moment too now
I must make some progress I must make
some progress about Deputy speaker but I
will come back to honorable uh onward
members in a moment to take further
interventions I do want to talk about
the importance of what we learned about
Omicron and the vaccines vaccines have
proven to be highly effective against
previous variants for example sample the
alpha and Delta variance this has
weakened the link between cases and
hospitalizations and debts and it has
allowed us to reopen our country once
more but recent analysis from the ukhsha
has shown that two doses of a vaccine
provide much lower levels of protection
against symptomatic infection from
Omicron when compared to the Delta
variant but more encouragingly
Effectiveness Effectiveness Rose
considerably in the early period after a
booster dose providing around 70 to 75
protection against symptomatic infection
this data starkly shows the importance
of booster Doses and why we're working
so hard to get many more boosters into
arms and I will say more about that in
just a moment now our strategy is to
take proportioned action now to come
down hard on this virus and strengthen
our defenses rather than waiting until
it's too late I
the whole point is that we cannot be
complacent about assuming that this
likely huge increase in infections is
all going to have very mild symptoms and
therefore what the government is doing
is taking modest steps to ensure that if
that doesn't happen we will be prepared
and will he promise that actually if
that doesn't materialize then he will be
able to relax again
the Mad industry we all want to relax
and I I wish I was more relaxed right
now than I already am but my honorable
friend is absolutely right and I agree
with you I give way to The Honorable
lady I'm really grateful I appreciate
that this is an escalating situation
which needs urgent attention but the
reality is if we are enabling social
mixing that is the very place where we
are going to see transmission as we did
with Delta last December so will he
review these measures because it seems
that these Saturday instruments before
us today are already out of date
it is important of course that we we
keep measures under review but I do
believe for the reasons I've said
earlier and I will continue to set out
these set of measures before the house
there are the right balanced and
proportional response yes I will I Thank
The Honorable amount of time for giving
way he may be interested to learn that
Dr curtsy gave evidence to the Science
and Technology committee this morning
and rather Contra to her piece in the
mail she actually endorsed what the
government is doing she said that the
boosters were definitely the absolute
priority but she said face masks and
avoiding mixing and she was asked
specifically about the cover past
proposals she said they sounded like a
proportionate response to the required
requirements of the situation what can I
can I thank my honorable friend for for
sharing that uh with the house and uh
and I think it's important uh that uh to
hear that support uh from uh South
African experts too I will give my phone
for giving away uh we are of course all
concerned I think to hear that plan C
measures have been discussed already be
grateful you could lay that to rest but
could I take him to the question of
hospitalizations there's a difference
between people who've been hospitalized
with uh Omicron and uh and from Omicron
so could he tell us what he knows about
those cases how many came into hospital
for other reasons and how many of her
actually around in hospital because they
are seriously ill with Omicron
well what I can tell my right honorable
friend is that there are approximately
in English hospitals about 6 000 people
in with coving with Kobe as a you know
their positive covert cases oh of those
of those around as I've shared this
information with the house before
because I was determined to get this
information when I first became Health
Secretary of of those approximately 80
percent are there because of the
symptoms they have from covid and around
the rest about one-fifth are there
because for for other reasons and they
also of course have been tested for
covid and they happen to have coven I
hope that is helpful by my right
honorable friend uh I I will give way
one more time for now and then I will
I thank the Secretary of State for
giving way I really must press in on
this issue on behalf of workers in my
constituency across the country
particularly low paid workers why isn't
the government bringing a vote today on
whether to increase sick pay to real
living wage levels we can't have a
situation where the government is making
the case that this matter is so serious
which is yet forcing low-paid workers to
choose between putting food on the table
and self-isolating and protecting the
rest of the community
where I agree with the honorable
gentleman is about the importance of
support for people in in with with
measures and there is support already in
place I can see from the way he's raised
this question that he thinks there
should be more support The Honorable
gentleman thinks that I I understand
that we have a difference of view on
that but it is something that we keep
under review now when I when I set out
when I set out our autumn and winter
plan to this house in September I
outlined how we'd hold measures in
reserve in case the NHS was likely to
come under unsustainable pressure and
with this would then stop it being able
to provide treatment that we want all
our constituents to receive yesterday
the NHS England announced that it will
return to its highest level of emergency
preparedness level 4 National incident
and unfortunately there is now a very
real risk that the exponential rise of
Omicron crisis cases translates into a
spike in Hospital admissions and
threatens to overwhelm the NHS we've
done so much already to boost the
capacity of the NHS we've increased the
number of doctors by 5 000 over the past
year and the number of nurses by almost
10 000 and we've also expanded the
number of beds available but we've also
had to put in place measures for
infection control which have limited
this capacity and there's already over
six thousand covid-19 patients in
hospital beds in England despite the
progress that we've made the NHS will
never have unlimited numbers of beds and
no unlimited numbers of people to look
after anyone that is in those beds so if
we think that capacity risks being
breached then we simply have to step in
because we know that this what this
would mean in practice for both covid
and for non-covered care it would mean
one of your constituents perhaps
is in a car crash maybe it's a child in
a car crash they need emergency care and
the NHS having to make difficult
decisions about who deserves treatment
and who doesn't now I know that someone
all the members think that this is
merely hypothetical
but it's not
we've seen health services around the
world become overwhelmed by covid-19 and
we cannot allow that to happen here I'll
give way to you I'm a lady and then I
will yeah thank you for giving away an
extremely uh grateful for him mentioning
Frontline NHS staff the old party group
on coronavirus had a hearing this
morning where we heard that they are
suffering with moral injury because of
the exact decisions that they have to
make that he's just outlined but the
other thing we heard is that there is a
worrying suggestion that Omicron may be
worse for children than Delta what
assessment has he made of that risk and
what is his plan for children to protect
them against this deadly New Way well
first of all about it if you can I very
much agree with you honorable lady about
the the worker the everyone in the NHS
the phenomenal work they've been doing
at all times but especially over the
last two years during this pandemic they
could not have delivered more in terms
of her her question about uh children
learn me crime I'm afraid we don't have
any evidence of that yet that I have
seen but of course it's something uh the
impact of Omicron we take very very
seriously that I hope that she can see
and we will keep that under review now
Madam Deputy speaker where where I will
take some interventions in a moment but
I do want to just finish this section
Madam Deputy speaker we're also giving
the NHS more time to to put boosters in
arms and I can ensure the house that we
won't waste a single second in doing
that we've already given more booster
doses than anywhere else in Europe and
uh 44 of the people in this country over
the age of 18 have already been boosted
but the recent data showing the
importance of booster doses for our
fight against Omicron has highlighted
the need to go even faster yesterday I
set out to the house how we're bringing
the target we've set ourselves we're
bringing it forward so that everyone
who's eligible and aged 18 and over in
England will be offered the chance to
get their booster dose before the new
year this is a this is a new National
Mission a race between the virus and the
vaccine to get as many people protected
as soon as possible and just as we
embark on this huge logistical Endeavor
in the short term we're also looking at
the long term we've already signed
contracts to buy a total of 114 million
extra doses of future proof this these
are future proof vaccines that will help
our country's vaccination program over
the next two years and the deals that we
struck will give us the earliest access
to modified vaccines to combat Omicron
and future variants of concern should we
need them
I'm very grateful to the Secretary of
State for giving way and he is
absolutely right and I'm Overjoyed that
the boosters are the key to getting the
country out of this issue I raised for
the last couple of weeks and last week
in pmq's the issue of the 15-minute wait
post Pfizer I wonder if the mrha or jcvi
have come to a conclusion on this
because this will free up a huge amount
of capacity when it comes to delivering
the boosters yeah
my armor friend as he mentioned you he
did raise this yesterday and what I can
tell him that it is very urgently being
looked at and I am sure he will agree
with me that if it is done it should be
done in a safe way that our Regulators
are happy with and uh I I I I can
confidently say uh that I can expect a
update later today as soon as I leave
this chamber I'll just get ready let's
grab somebody on the frontal I actually
entirely agree with what he said about
the pressure on the HSN notes difficult
problems that will occur if there are
injuries taken up by I'm vaccinated
people blocking ICU beds but
as my own friends said very much come
along he's making the case that even if
it's only got mild symptoms you're going
to get an exponential growth in
hospitals so what is the ongoing plan
going forward there's a set of measures
today to deal with the situation now
fair enough but if this is going to keep
happening how do we avoid being sat here
in three months time five months time
six months time debating the same thing
what's the plan
and it's a very it's a very fair
question and I will say more about that
in a moment but one of the things I've
just mentioned I point to my uh on my
friend is is the vaccines the the the
the better and better vaccines in the
future we will have polyvalent maxines
and because of the orders that we have
already placed we are the front of the
queue for such vaccines but but but
I I will to The Honorable lady I will
come
I thank the Secretary of State for
giving way on that point does he um has
he noticed as I have uh the view that
Omicron and where it came from it may
have originated
um in in Africa with an immunosuppressed
uh sufferer from HIV where these viruses
can then um mutate much faster than they
would under other circumstances and does
he agree with me that the best way of
dealing with this is to get vaccines
into as many people in Africa as
possible and also ensure that HIV AIDS
suffers are given access to the proper
treatment
there is there's lots of speculation on
how we can may have originated I won't
add to that speculation now but I will
agree with the point that the the
general Point The Honorable lady has
made which I think is a very important
powerful one about the need to get more
vaccines to people in developing
countries whether that's in Africa Asia
or elsewhere we can be proud of what the
UK has already done over 20 million
vaccines delivered through Kovacs or or
directly almost another 10 million on
the way and completely committed uh to
meet our Target of 100 million vaccine
donations by June 2022.
or just before the Secretary of State
makes further progress it is it's
absolutely right that the Secretary of
State should be taking a lot of
interventions a lot of questions to be
asked people who've already made one
intervention shouldn't be making a
second intervention or a third
intervention and certainly not if they
also wish to be called to speak later in
the day I've got too many people who
wish to to speak there isn't going to be
enough time for everybody and be sure if
you keep intervening you don't get to
speak let's have a little consideration
for others Secretary of State
I will indulge my own friend for the
member for Northwest legislative but
it's going to be really short
the secretary of state knows I've been
short all my life
the Secretary of State said earlier in
his opening speech that the average age
in South Africa was 27 and a half I
think I fear he may have misspoken or be
badly advised in fact the median age in
South Africa is 27.5 and the comparative
median age in the UK is 40.5 not
radically different
well first of all I think if I'm pleased
I allowed that intervention I'm pleased
I allowed it because uh I don't want
people to think uh like my own friend
has just been uh suggested but I do have
to disagree that I think first of all
there's a big difference between those
two ages and last time I looked at the
median can be described as an average
um but I I'm pleased to shared that
because it highlights my point now I I
do need to power on now but I will take
some interventions a bit later so Madam
Deputy speaker for the reasons I've set
out I do believe the responsible
decision to take is this type is because
of all this is to move to plan B in
England drawing on the measures that
we've held in contingency to give more
time to get those boosters into arms
these are not steps that we would take
likely I firmly believe in individual
liberty and that their curves should be
placed on our freedoms only in the most
gravest of circumstances and not only
that I am of course mindful of the cost
that restrictions can bring to the
nation Health to our education to the
economy so it's vital that we act early
and we act in a proportionate way doing
whatever we can to build our defenses
and to preserve great greater freedom
for the long term I'm confident that
these measures are balanced and their
proportion measures and that they still
leave us with far fewer restrictions
that are in place in most countries in
Europe and I can assure the house that
we'll keep reviewing these measures that
we've put in place and we won't keep
them in debt in place for a day longer
than we have to the the I will give way
I thank the Secretary of State to give
away specifically on the regulations
then deregulation about refusal of Entry
given the small number of venues and the
large number of exemptions and we know
the lack of uh protection for doubly
vaccinated people why is there not the
necessity for everybody to show a flow
test rather than showing double
vaccinations if my if my older friend
allows me I will come to that point
shortly but man definitely speak I just
uh I I just said a moment earlier that
we won't keep measures in place for a
moment longer than we need to and for
example now that there is community
transmission of Omicron in the UK and
obiquan has spread so widely widely
across the the world the travel red list
is now less effective in slowing the
incursion of Omicron from abroad so I
can announce the day that whilst will
maintain our temporary testing measures
for international travel we will be
removing all 11 countries from the
travel Red List effective from 4 AM
tomorrow morning
now now now Madam Deputy speaker I'd
like to return to turn to the details of
some of these regulations before the
house regulation number 1400 proposes
extending the use of face coverings in
October ukhsa published an updated
review of the evidence on the
effectiveness of face coverings and
concluded that there's good evidence
good evidence that they they can help in
reduce the spread of covid-19 when worn
in the community this regulation
proposes extending the legal requirement
to most indoor settings including
theaters and Cinemas although they are
not required in places where it wouldn't
be practical so for example Hospitality
settings like cafes and restaurants and
pubs nightclubs or other dance venues or
in exercise facilities like gyms
next matter Deputy speaker regulation
1416. this would mean anyone over 18
would need to show a negative lateral
flow test to get into a limited number
of high-risk settings unless they were
double vaccinated
however as I as I announced to the house
yesterday in light of the new data on
how vaccines respond to Omicron Our
intention is that boosters will be
required instead of two doses as soon as
all adults have had a reasonable chance
to get their booster jab I I will
I I found the secretary state for being
so generous with these interventions um
would the Secretary of State agree that
if we are to go on the front foot in
tackle this pandemic we have to
acknowledge that this pandemic is like
our house being on fire and we're
dealing with just one room in that house
when the rest of the house on fire
surely the trips waiver giving those
other countries across the developing
world and Beyond the ability to produce
the vaccine themselves and increase
Supply at a cost effective rate and
stopping big Pharma from excessively
profiteering is the way that we get onto
our front foot in vaccinating the rest
of the world to enable that new variants
do not continue to flourish
as I said in response to a question from
another honorable member earlier we are
in terms of getting vaccines to
developing World donations through
Kovacs bilateral are really important
but I I have to I have to strongly
disagree with the suggestion of The
Honorable member that waving rights to
intellectual property and patent are
going to help they are not going to help
it is going to undermine the world's
ability to deal with this pandemic
because it will remove all the
incentives from the pharmaceutical
companies that actually develop these
valuable drugs in the first place I do
have to respectfully disagree with the
honorable uh gentleman now I do need to
make some progress now Madam Deputy
speaker
with this uh however I announced to the
house yesterday lighter this new data on
how vaccines respond to Omicron Our
intention is that boosters will be
required instead of two doses as soon as
all adults have had a reasonable chance
to get their booster jam now Madam
Deputy speaker I'd like to reinforce The
Honorable members that this this
proposal around getting a a
um a lateral flow test a negative result
from a lateral flow test or or not
having to do so if you're a double uh
vaccinated this is not a vaccine
passport it is it's really important to
me as a point of principle that people
have a range of different routes to show
how they're eligible and that is what it
is before the house today these options
include showing proof of a negative test
for the last 14 hours proof of
vaccination a medical examination or
evidence of participation in a clinical
trial these regulations cover a small
number of settings that present
particular risk I will give way to my
honorable friend I find The Honorable
friend giving way and he knows that I'm
completely against vaccine passports and
monetary vaccinations can he confirm
with me though that lateral flow tests
will always be used and they lay fears
that people having a Roth Valley and
myself that we are not going to create a
two-tier system we're not going to have
mandatory passports and lateral flow
tests will always be used so everyone
can have access to all parts of our
society
I I can give my old friend that
confirmation I'm very happy to to make
that really clear I think it is
absolutely vital there's always an
option for lateral flow tests and I
would not support a vaccine only option
I will give way to our my friend I thank
my much I'm a friend for giving way in
terms of providing proof of native
lateral flow test is that possible for
someone who doesn't have access to the
internet or phone what seat what's the
evidently requirement
the uh the lateral flow tests are
available for everyone the the vast vast
majority of people I think will have uh
access uh to to phones or in other ways
and we are looking at and many people we
have seen have um uh they can once they
have taken the lateral flow test and uh
registered that result perhaps with the
help of someone else in their family or
a friend they are able also to get
printed proof of that by using the 119
service and and we and if there are
other ways to improve that of course we
will but it is it is something that we
have found is act available to the vast
vast majority of people including to
those who might not be so familiar with
technology I will give way I'm grateful
to the sexual state for a giving me can
I say to him that a vaccine passport
with a lateral flow test alternative is
still a perfect vaccine passport we have
seen the use of vaccine passports in
other parts of the country in Scotland
and in Wales so can he tell the house
what difference it has made the
transmission of Omicron in these parts
of the country
well I I'm I'm coming uh to that more
specifically in a moment but again I
just have to this is not a vaccine
passport I mean the right honorable
gentleman should know that a vaccine if
he wants to see a vaccine passport you
know he will know that of that in
Scotland or he can go to France or some
other countries but this is a
requirement it is of course an attempt
to reduce uh the risks in a high risk
venue from high risk from covid and I
think it is a sensible proportionate way
that provides a number of options and a
number of flexibilities in doing so I do
have to make some progress and I will
take some interventions later these
regulations regulations 1416 they cover
a small number of settings that present
a particular risk venues like nightclubs
indoor events with over 500 or more
attendees likely to stand and move
around outdoor events with 4 000 or more
attendees likely to stand and move
around and all events with 10 000 or
more attendees these measures come into
Force tomorrow we've given a week's
notice of these changes so so I will so
we we've given notice of these changes
that so venues have time to put
Arrangements in place and I'm pleased to
see that many venues are already using
these measures we can't of course but
enough speaker we can't eliminate the
risk of covid-19 that's of course simply
not possible nor should that be tried
but we can reduce it and these proposals
offer a pragmatic way of doing this
under these proposals people can either
show they can either show a negative
lateral flow test result meaning that
they're less likely to be infectious
than otherwise
or they can be double jabbed which means
that they'll be less likely to become
severely and well if they are exposed to
kobit 19. I will give way to my own
orphan
my constituents have contacted me
concerned that these measures today are
the first step in further restrictions
against social Gatherings and businesses
will he assure them today that this is
not the case and that if we can rescind
these measures earlier than the 26th of
January we will I I'll just add that the
what I'm about to say next I think will
give my honorable friend uh that
insurance that the these plans would
would make high risk environments safer
than they would otherwise be but this
regulation this particular regulation in
fact all these regulations the the
measures on face coverings they will be
reviewed by the 5th of January and they
will all sunset on the 26th of January
that's the point I think I would have
emphasize uh in response to my own
friends question they would sunset on
the 26th of January and if if even if
the government wanted to do something
different and changes some way of course
it would have to come back to this house
and seek The house's approval I will
give away
he's quite right that these are not
vaccine passports Who's Back benches in
the liberal Democrats are completely
wrong about that but can I warmly
welcome what you said a moment or two
ago about abolishing the red list will
he now release all of those people who
are currently incarcerated in so-called
quarantine hotels in inhumane conditions
in this country now and we also get rid
of the other extra restrictions he
introduced only two weeks ago to try to
keep the omnicron varied out when it's
already here
it's an important point about the
managed uh quarantine those people are
already in managed quarantine yeah I'm
told that the practice in the in the
past on this has been requiring them to
complete their quarantine period however
I do understand I do understand the
importance of that and I have asked for
an urgent advice about what this means
and I hope to act very quickly on on on
just that I will give way to the Amazon
yeah
I thank the Secretary of State for
giving away and one of the things that
we do know about Omicron is the
significant genetic mutations and
changes that have happened to the spike
protein and this morning at the
Scientific Technology committee Kate
Bingham the government's own vaccine
Tsar said that the government's decision
to pull the plug on Val Neva contract
was mistaken will the Secretary of State
make a commitment today to revisit that
given the specific technologies that
exist there with the whole virus vaccine
that is described by uh Miss Bingham as
having the edge over other vaccines and
would help the distribution of vaccines
to the rest of the world
I I think the honorable General will
understand that when the government
makes decisions on vaccines it takes
expert advice most of that comes from
the jcvi and we're always listen
carefully to that advice that make a
final decision but though that advice is
is is is coming on a number of occasions
and is constantly kept under review now
I yes I will yeah yeah you thank you
very much my friend for giving away I'm
referring back to the honorable member
on the opposite side from exeter's point
um it surely is crazy that people who
have been in self-isolation are going to
have to remain there how the 11
countries haven't been removed from the
from the red list but surely not only
should they be released from their
incarceration but they also should be
reimbursed the astronomical amount of
fees they've had to pay
uh Madame deaf speaker I I very much uh
understand what my honorable friend has
said uh I I'm I'm very persuaded by what
he said I would love to stand here right
now and just say that is the case there
are uh there are some uh issues that
need to be resolved and they are
urgently looked at I hope we can say
something more on this as a government
even as early as say but I do understand
what he said for exactly the reasons
that he said including on his point
about reimbursement uh as well now miss
Madam Deputy speaker as well as the new
measures we're proposing we're also
restoring Freedom's true to drawing on
the defenses that we've already built at
the end of last month this house passed
regulations requiring all close contacts
of a suspected or confirmed Omicron case
to self-isolate for 10 days but given
the increasing dominance of Omicron this
approach no longer makes sense for
public health purposes and nor is it
sustainable for the economy so we're
drawing on the testing capacity that
we've built to create a new system of
daily testing for covered contacts which
has started today instead of close
contact of confirmed cases or suspected
cases having to self-isolate all
vaccinated contacts irrespective of
whether the contact was within Omicron
case or not will be asked to take
lateral flow tests every day for seven
days regulation regulation
1415 allows us to put this plan into
action by revoking the Omicron specific
Provisions for self-isolation yeah I
will you know I thank him he knows I
welcome that I think the isolation regs
that we passed two weeks ago which I
didn't support was Sinister and well
done for for getting rid of it the test
and release though he will know many of
our constituents many of mine have
contacted me to say they cannot for love
no money get hold of lateral flow tests
right now could he update the house on
whether this problem has been resolved
man you have to speak my own friend will
understand that uh that there has been a
huge surge in demand for lateral flow
tests perfectly of course uh
understandably and uh the the situation
uh present is that the warehouses the of
the UK HSA they have plenty of stock the
distribution channel has been limited
although they have added to that
significantly in recent days including
building on the channels they had with
Royal Mail with Amazon and other
suppliers and also opening up more
access points other than direct ordering
online so that people can pick up tests
for example from far more pharmacies
than they currently can do but it is
something that is is being worked on and
I think whatever the current situation
in is it will it will improved very very
quickly I hope that reassures Maya often
I will take one more until I need to
start closing
I thank the Secretary State and he's
making some vital points about testing
and self-isolation but I did although
the supply of lateral flow test is
important so is the testing the PCR
testing which is obviously more reliable
gold standard today there was a point
when it was reported on social media
that there were no PCR testing slots
available in any region of England
yesterday I asked the Secretary of State
if he would authorize each director of
Public Health across the country to have
a float stock of 500 PCR tests they can
use to disrupt cobit outbreaks and to
slow the transmission of on the ground I
think that's a really important Point
only nine of the directors of Public
Health have that float stock at the
moment will he take that vital step and
authorize it for all the other directors
of Public Health
we are magnific we are working uh very
closely as The Honorable lady would
imagine with directors of Public Health
throughout England and whether it's on
testing and elsewhere in terms of
testing PCR specific testing capacity
there's around I think capacity is
around roughly 600 000 a day it's been
expanded to it normally is at that level
it's been expanded already to around 800
000 a day it will be further expanded I
think it is important for uh for
honorable members to know that testing
is released during the different times
of the day and so if someone checks the
system and it's not available it might
be available in in their local area in
the in in the next couple of hours it's
not uh just a day by day process uh and
and also um as it is surged there will
become much more easily available but it
is important I think to to remind people
whenever uh one can that a PCR test
should only be used if someone has
symptoms uh otherwise uh lateral flow
tests uh are the tests that should be
deployed now finally Madam Deputy
speaker I'd like to turn to measures to
help keep the Health and Care System
safe for the long term by making
vaccination a condition of deployment
for more Health and Social care settings
across the UK the overwhelming majority
of us have made the positive Choice the
positive choice to accept the offer of a
vaccination against covid-19 and 91 of
NHS staff already have two doses but we
need this figure to to go even higher
uptake rates vary between different
Health and Care organizations and across
the country and despite the incredible
effort to boost uptake across the
country there are still approximately 94
000 NHS staff who are unvaccinated it's
critical to patient safety that Health
and Care staff get the job to protect
some of the most vulnerable people who
are in their care and also keep the NHS
Workforce strong in the wake of omicon
now we made vaccination against covid-19
a condition of deployment in care homes
from the 11th of November this year and
contrary to what some feared we're not
aware of any Care Home closures where
vaccination is a condition of deployment
has been the primary cause today we're
putting before the house regulations to
extend this requirement to health and
other social care settings I will give
away to your own General
thank the most for giving away
earlier on in a speech the minister
pointed out that the capacity of the
Health Service is important and should
not be breached
how does he expect if there's nine
percent of the staff
who have to this be it decided not to be
vaccinated
and who presumably will stick with that
decision how does he expect that that
will not reduce the capacity of the
Health Service in the future and is it
not a factor already there are many
people who are staying in hospital
because it can't be facilitated in Care
Homes due to the lack of staff
uh it's a fair question and I will be
answering precisely that question in
just a moment
with direct reference to what he's just
been talking about we know that the
vaccines are only what 33 effective at
reducing their infection of uh Omicron
we know that uh the reduction of
infectiousness reduces dramatically to
zero after 12 weeks in the case of
AstraZeneca so what does he view as
better in terms of protecting people
from infection daily lateral flow tests
or vaccination
I think uh I'd say to my horrible friend
I think that they both have a role to
play of course in the NHS and in Social
care there is a very frequent uh testing
both lateral flow testing in the case of
the NHS often uh PCR testing but I think
vaccination has a role uh to play at
this point in time many people uh still
have two doses that is rapidly changing
when they have three doses get their
booster doses that gives them an even
higher degree of protection I will give
way to my honorable friend
clear argument for the need to do
something he talks about how a very
small proportion of a much larger number
of cases could overwhelm the NHS in in
the way that a larger proportion of a
much smaller number of cases might not
but we do know that the NHS has a huge
backlog of people awaiting a diagnostic
and operative procedures
they'd like to ask him what evidence he
has that mundating
um vaccines for NHS staff will help and
given the fact that we know that
vaccination doesn't particularly reduce
transmission why he doesn't and what he
said before about the importance of
choice why he doesn't think it would be
reasonable to offer medical staff and
nursing staff the option of daily
testing instead of vaccination should
they make that choice yeah absolutely
right these in in coming to this
decision we held an extensive
consultation with thousands of responses
we also of course consulted and this
very importantly with the NHS itself as
I shall touch on a moment from now the
NHS itself has weighed up this decision
and and The Honorable lady is right if
she suggests that there may be some
people that choose to leave the NHS
rather than stay and and get be
vaccinated that is a choice for them to
make but there's also here a issue of
patient safety that is also the view of
the NHS and as I said in response to my
radical friend a moment ago a chesting
can be used as well alongside this but
vaccinations help as well and I want to
just I want to just talk about the the
the settings order
let's allow the Secretary of State to
finish his speech he has some important
information to put before the house I
now want to hear that sexual state
Madam Deputy speaker the the settings
that this would apply to include of
course NHS hospitals GP and dental
practices regardless of whether a
provider is publicly or privately funded
anyone working in those health or social
care activities regulated by the Care
Quality commission will need to be
vaccinated against covid-19 if their
role will involve direct contact with
patients this is apart from a few
limited exemptions for example for
medical reasons the definition of fully
vaccinated is currently two doses but
we're keeping this under review and of
course I'd urge everyone who works in
the NHS and social care to get their
boosters too I I hear that concerns have
been raised about the impact of the
measures on the workforce we've just
heard that Madame Deputy speaker
especially during these winter months
although even before the pandemic
workplace policies were in place
requiring the hepatitis B vaccine for
those who've had to perform certain
clinical procedures we're already
allowing a 12-week grace period to give
people the chance to make the positive
choice to get protected and we're aiming
to start enforcing the risk these
requirements from the 1st of April next
year subject of course to the will of
this house and today today the I will
give way if it's on this point I will
give way very grateful to the minister
for giving way if a member of the NHS
decides they do not want to be
vaccinated will they be given a
redundancy payment and if not why not
but if they are not as a policy how much
would it cost the NHS and would that be
a good use of taxpayers money I I
believe it wouldn't be classed as
redundancy because it's not redundancy
you know that that job has not became
redundant and if that individual if that
individual chooses not to to get
vaccinated and then that of course is a
decision for them to make but as I as I
stressed that the way that this will be
implemented by the NHS and the way that
it should be implemented by the NHS I
know that there will be is that getting
vaccinated should always be a positive
choice and the NHS has put in place a
number of uh methods and ways to try and
provide the information that that people
uh want to share and and also including
one-to-one uh consultations uh providing
more information especially uh for those
uh that have may have received
misinformation and the the outcome of
this uh with uh with the Care Homes when
this was uh the similar measure was
implemented earlier was that many of
them when they're provided with the
right positive information chose to
actually become vaccinated rather than
choose to leave the jobs now I must make
progress I'm sorry madam the secretary
of state is right he must make progress
other people need to speak now please
let us allow the Secretary of State to
conclude his speech so thank you madam
Mr Speaker and just on this issue to
finish on this particular regulation
today the the chief executive of NHS
England and has written to me
reinforcing the importance of getting a
jab in the interest of patient and staff
safety and I'll be placing a copy of
this letter in the library of both
houses today and I'm pleased to say that
despite the concerns that some people
have raised we've already seen a net
increase of over 55 000 NHS staff
vaccinated with a first dose since we
consulted on the policy in September now
Madam Deputy speaker although I firmly
believe that these measures are a
proportionate way of protecting those at
greatest risk I know that oral members
have questions about whether we would
extend these measures further and I'd
like to say very clearly to the house
today that
and say this once and fall that although
we've seen plans for Universal mandatory
vaccination in some countries in Europe
I will never support them in this
country
I I firmly believe that getting
vaccinated is something that should be a
positive decision and I can assure the
house that the government the government
has no intention of extending the
condition of deployment to any other
workforces or introducing monetary
vaccination more widely now now Madam
Deputy speaker the the regulations we're
debating today are not measures that any
of us would like to be putting in place
but they are measures that I think the
situation demands because when the facts
change our response must change too as
we look ahead to a winter with Omicron
in the midst the measures before the
house a day will fortify our national
defenses and guard the gains that we've
all made against this deadly virus I
commend these regulations to the house
yeah
thank you the question is As on the
order paper and before I call the shadow
Secretary of State it might be helpful
for the house to know that there will be
an immediate uh a time limit of five
minutes on that bench speeches that will
reduce later in the afternoon but
initially five minutes
Shadow secretary of state was streeting
thank you madam Deputy speaker and can I
begin by acknowledging that there are
sincere and deeply held views on both
sides of the debate that we're having
this afternoon indeed on both sides of
the house and I respect those taking a
different view to the one that I'll be
outlining on but half of the opposition
but can I also say that we owe it to our
country to give them a debate worthy of
the finest traditions of this house
and in light of comments made in recent
Days by at least one conservative MP
comparing these measures to the
situation in Germany in the 1930s I
would just say it should not be for me
as the shadow Secretary of State to
point out that we are not living in the
1930s and the Secretary of State and his
team are not Nazis
on their shoulders rest the health of
our nation and the responsibility to
protect our NHS indeed it's a
responsibility we all share they need
our support and they are owed better
than a better treatment than they have
received from some on their own side in
recent days and even this afternoon
but no matter how dysfunctional the
conservative party has become the
country can rely on labor we will act in
the national interests as we have done
throughout the pandemic putting Public
Health before Party politics by
supporting the Motions under
consideration this afternoon we do not
do so lightly throughout the pandemic we
have asked the British people to make
big sacrifices to support the national
effort against coronavirus sacrifices
which have impacted on lives livelihoods
and Liberties and whenever this house
considers such measures we owe it to the
British people to explain why they are
necessary
we believe these measures are necessary
a necessary response to the Omicron
threat necessary to protect ourselves
necessary to protect the ones we love
and necessary to protect our NHS we
can't yet be sure about the severity of
the Omicron variant but we can be
certain that is spreading and spreading
fast faster than any other variants and
even if a smaller proportion of Omicron
victims are hospitalized the rapid
advance of the virus through the
population could see large numbers of
people admitted to hospital during the
months in which the NHS is under
greatest pressure and there should be no
complacency about this the winter months
present the greatest pressures on the
NHS in any normal year and as we know
this is far from a normal year the NHS
is contending with winter pressures a
serious backlog the Delta variant and
now the Omicron variant
and when people invoke the story of the
boy who cried wolf the warnings that
came before but never materialized
people should remember that in the end
there was a wolf
many of these challenges facing the NHS
are understandable given the
unprecedented challenges of the covid-19
pandemic but we've got to be honest and
acknowledge that confronting these
challenges has been made much harder
because we went into the pandemic with
NHS waiting lists at a record four and a
half million a hundred thousand staff
vacancies and a shortage of 112 000
vacancies in Social care it wasn't just
that they didn't fix the roof while the
Sun was shining is that they dismantled
the roof and removed the floorboards and
now the NHS is locked in a Race Against
Time a race against the fastest variant
of covid-19 we have seen to date a race
to get as many people boosted as
possible before the end of this month
on this side of the house we support
them in that task and let me say on
behalf of all of us in the labor party
to every NHS worker every GP every
pharmacist every Public Health official
in local government every member of our
armed forces and every volunteer
stepping up to meet this enormous task
that we are with them 100 and if anyone
can do it they can
could you explain to me why the labor
party supported supported not a
mandatory vaccinations for care workers
but now changed their mind for NHS
workers
outline our position on that but the
honorable gentleman have to be patient
so I'll come on to that later in my
speech
but we need to buy them some time
the measures put forward for
consideration today and are attempt to
do just that by slowing the spread of
the virus whilst trying to protect
Christmas so that people can enjoy the
festive season safely by limiting our
interactions in the workplace by wearing
face coverings in settings where the
virus finds it easiest to spread by
testing before we attend large indoor
Gatherings and by getting behind the
booster rollout to ensure that everyone
is protected play I certainly will I'm
very grateful to my honorable friend for
giving way and he's absolutely right
that we're all very conscious of how
important this time of year is to the
hospitality sector but would he agree
with me the greatest threat to the
hospitality sector isn't the uh lot
isn't the kind of restriction that are
in front of us today but it's the sense
that this virus is out of control and
widespread cancellations from the sector
so these these restrictions of us today
enable the hospitality sector to survive
in this really difficult time but also
enable us to take proportionate steps to
make sure the spike doesn't get out of
control
I wholeheartedly agree with my honorable
friend indeed one of the primary reasons
for supporting measures for
consideration today is because we on
these benches support business and we
want support them through a particularly
difficult time where normally trading
would be at its busiest the goal in the
end must of course be to learn to live
with the virus that means effective
vaccination antiviral treatments and
public health measures that have minimal
impact on our lives our jobs and our
businesses so let me now take each of
these measures in turn and explain why
labor supports them and no doubt take
interventions as we come to each one
first of your mask wearing Madame Deputy
speaker no one enjoys wearing a mask I
certainly don't but it is nothing
compared with the cost that more
Draconian restrictions have on our lives
livelihoods and Liberties masks are
simply a price worth paying for our
freedom to go out and live our lives
during this pandemic they are proven to
be effective and not only that but in
times of rising infections when people
are feeling increasingly cautious it is
vital to our economy that people feel
safe boarding a busy bus or entering a
crowded theater and in our view the
government should never have got rid of
the requirement to wear masks in these
settings but we know why they did and
we've we've we've counted in recent
weeks honorable members opposite not
wearing masks I'm glad to see that
compliance has risen somewhat uh
considerably
uh we know the we know the prime
minister no longer has the authority to
lead his own party but I'm grateful that
members opposite have at least listened
to their health secretary
turning to the vaccine pass on to
testing to enter night clubs and large
events I welcome that the government has
listened to representations from labor
and responded the labor party has argued
consistently against vaccine passports
and insisted on people having the option
of showing a negative test further we
argue these passes should not be
required for access to essential
services on both counts the government
has listened amended the proposals and
we can support the measure in front of
us today it is not a vaccine passport it
is in effect a default requirement to
show a negative test to enter venues
where the virus is most likely to spread
with an opt-out available to those with
an NHS covid plus I certainly will give
way
is making a very good point on this is
the reality not that if we didn't
introduce these measures there would be
a danger that our nighttime economy pubs
venues and other events would have to
shut completely so these this past is
actually a pass for freedom to allow us
to continue to enjoy activities that
otherwise would be shut down and those
Libertarians opposites should be
welcoming it not bemoaning it
I wholeheartedly agree with my honorable
friend and and let me be clear we and
the labor party support this approach
because we support British business this
is about giving people the confidence to
go out and about despite the presence of
Omicron and certainly will give way
I I think the shadow Secretary of State
for giving ways and I I wonder if he
shares my concern that reports over the
past couple of days that there has been
an absence or a a lack of lateral flow
devices to be sent out for testing and
also uh what is uh also alarming is the
lack of support for the domestic
Diagnostics market and the manufacturer
of lateral flow devices in this country
that are much more accurate reliable and
superior to the current government
lateral flow devices and if these
devices are to make a difference then we
must have the best quality devices in
place very good
I do agree with the with the honorable
gentleman and of course in order for
this measure to work as effectively as
we would wish there has to be an
adequate supply of lateral flow tests
and I heard what the Secretary of State
said yesterday about the availability of
testing but it's no good if the tests
are in the warehouse they need to be
available to people where they need them
when they need them we've had supply
issues and these really do need to be
resolved not least in light of other
measures which I'll come on to shortly
as well I'll give away another time
we do not accept that rather than giving
confidence to people these measures and
the background against which they have
been introduced have actually reduced
confidence when you have predictions of
75 000 deaths when you are telling
people that they can't go to venues
unless they have certain tests the
experience in Northern Ireland already
has been that the hospitality industry
has lost millions of pounds of orders
coming up the Christmas period because
people are afraid to go out
um well I'll say to The Honorable
gentleman in dispatches from the shadow
Secretary of State for Northern Ireland
where of course Northern Ireland is
ahead of uh England on this uh he had a
perfectly nice time like out last night
is my understanding
um enjoying the best Hospitality that
that Northern Ireland the people of
Northern Ireland have to offer and I
think people are drawing Confidence from
this and let me also say
um drawing on the experience of other
countries look at Italy look at France
look at Denmark countries with strict
covert passport rules all have seen
their retail and Recreation sectors Fair
far far better than here in the UK
because there's been consistency and
confidence on this and with passes and
lateral flow tests venues can operate at
100 capacity punters can be confident
that they're safe to attend and enjoy
themselves at this time of year the show
goes on and everyone stays in a job
without these measures with just a
moment without these measures with
Rising infections with more
hospitalizations we would see we would
risk seeing the government forced to
impose more Draconian measures on these
sectors shutting down our cultural
sector collapsing the economy once again
and I think we should be confident about
about this and and let me also just
address this
tension and it's a reasonable question
about the the message to work from home
if you can but but go out I sort of make
no apology actually for trying to
safeguard social interactions at this
time of year to trying to safeguard
interactions between people their
families and their friends at Christmas
time but also make no apology whatsoever
for supporting our hospitality industry
which has been battered by the pandemic
and which enjoys our support our
confidence support our full-throated
support and our support at the table at
the bar in the coming days
can we take it from that momentum to
speak that he's in favor extending the
certification or vaccine passport to all
venues
Well for now we think the government has
struck the right balance this is limited
to nightclubs and to larger venues but
as the secretary of state knows we
listen to the chief medical officer we
listen to the chief Scientific Advisor
we listen to Sage we listen to the NHS
and we make decisions based on evidence
and if ever the government wants to come
forward with further proposals we will
consider them we will consider them in a
genuinely bipartisan way and we will act
in what we believe to be the national
interest and I don't think anyone would
expect less of us I'll certainly give
away
um I Thank The Honorable member for
giving away would he recognize that
actually with the covert passes given
that there's an option of a lateral flow
test or a double vaccination actually
the double vaccination that many people
will use gives a very false sense of
security because we know that you can be
vaccinated and still transmit most of
the people we know getting covered at
the moment have already been vaccinated
so it's not actually very effective and
will give a real false sense of security
I I I I also think the The Honorable
member should look at the evidence from
our friends on the continent which is
that not only not only do does this
approach work in terms of giving people
confidence to go out and enjoy
themselves it also does encourage people
to take up vaccination and on that basis
I think the liberal Democrats ought to
reconsider their position
I'll give away one more time and I've
got to make progress thank you so much
really appreciate that he's obviously
spoken to us into Knoxville and who's
really concerned about trans
tell the house the house the labor party
Juiced by two vaccinations
I'm grateful for the honorable members
intervention I director to the sage
advice on this which is there is some
some evidence I wouldn't put it any
stronger than that there is some
evidence on reduction of transmission
but as I say our primary reason for
supporting this measure is about giving
people confidence to continue accessing
hospitality and to give people an added
incentive to take up vaccination as well
and on both of those tests I think the
our friends on the on the continent have
shown us A Better Way Forward an
effective way forward and I would I
would dare members opposite to suggest
that France for example is not a country
that values Liberty very strongly when
you look at their history and their and
their and their culture anyway moving on
Madame dip speaks I must make progress
for these passes to work people must be
able to access tests easily and readily
we cannot continue in this situation
where tests are out of stock and
unavailable to the public who are
required to take them not if covert
passes are to work and not if people who
are close contact of a covered case to
be able to take the daily tests required
the government's website showed PCR
tests unavailable throughout England
this morning the only region where
lateral flow tests are available today
is in the Southeast those sorts of
technical issues and those practical
issues of test delivery need to be
resolved immediately and Madam Deputy
speaker the measure on daily testing is
the one measure that seems to have
United the house in agreement so the
Secretary of State really needs to get a
grip on this and ensures we have access
to the tests we need
moving on to the flexibility to work
from home Madame Deputy speaker we've
called for workers to be given the
flexibility to work from home for months
and we support the guidance to work from
home where possible I've addressed um
the the contradiction in people uh
working from home and going out to
Christmas parties and we want to protect
people's ability to enjoy Christmas
safely this year which I think is one of
the key Arguments for this measure and
by limiting the interactions people have
worked without disrupting their ability
to do their work we thereby lower
contact lower infections and we hope to
preserve their ability to go ahead with
the social interactions they cherish
most at this time of year
onto mandatory vaccination Madame Deputy
speaker since the Prime Minister rather
clumsily and unhelpfully tried to open a
quote National conversation on mandatory
vaccinations for the country at large
last week I want to make it crystal
clear that we do not support mandatory
vaccinations in general and I welcome
what the secretary of state has said
this afternoon not the first time he's
had to clean up the prime minister's
mess we believe the vaccine is safe and
effective and that everyone should
choose to have it and I can't give any
stronger endorsement than to say that
I've had my first two Jabs and I'll be
having my booster on Thursday and I
wouldn't take it myself or recommend it
to others unless I believed it was safe
on mandatory vaccinations for NHS staff
I recognize that this is a difficult
issue for colleagues across the house
and in our NHS but the NHS has asked us
for this patients want this and we are
persuaded that the threat of Omicron
makes it even more important for staff
to be vaccinated to protect themselves
and to protect the public they serve a
certainly giveaway
Thank The Honorable member for giving
away and draw The house's attention to
my Declaration of members interests as a
practicing NHS doctor and I'd like to
commend The Honorable member for the
consensual way that he's approaching the
debate today and for many of the points
that he's made of which I agree on the
point of mandatory vaccinations for NHS
staff before I could train in medicine I
had to have a BCG TB injection I had to
also have hepatitis injection or I
couldn't practice medicine because it
was about protecting my patients and I
believe it's the duty of all Healthcare
professionals to put their Paces first
and that's why it's absolutely right the
healthcare professionals should have
mandatory covered vaccinations would he
not agree with that point
I I strongly endorse what he has said
and look infection control is going to
be a real challenge this winter because
of the nature of the Omicron variant
ensuring that the NHS Workforce is fully
vaccinated protects pay patients and it
protects staff who put themselves In
Harm's Way enough already and as The
Honorable gentleman who speaks with real
knowledge and expertise this is not a
new precedent NHS staff are already
required to inoculate themselves against
other diseases it is indeed a
professional Duty and the NHS clearly
believes that the April deadline does
give sufficient time to persuade the
workforce to protect themselves their
patience and their loved ones without
seeing an exodus of Staff certainly give
way I'm very grateful to the shadow
Secretary of State for giving way and
indeed I um supported the requirement
for people working with vulnerable
people in Care Homes to be vaccinated or
if they wouldn't be vaccinated to be
removed from direct contact with
vulnerable people can he tell me if he's
aware because I didn't get a chance to
ask the Secretary of State this proposal
for those members of the NHS who have
not got vaccinated is it only affecting
Frontline staff who interact with the
vulnerable or is it people throughout
the NHS who might have no contact with
the vulnerable because that will affect
the way I cast my vote today well I hope
I can reassure him in that people it's
not just a case of if you don't take up
the jab that's it you're out there is
also the opportunity for redeployment to
other roles where vaccination would not
be mandatory so I hope that gives him
the reassurance that that that he needs
I certainly good boy
I thank my honorable friend giveaway and
I think he's handling this this speech
in just the right way there's a balance
of Rights here patients have a right to
be treated by staff who are fully
vaccinated to protect them I had a
constituent who was clinically extremely
vulnerable and contacting me she was not
willing to go to her needed Hospital
appointments once she realized that the
hospital staff were not fully vaccinated
we have to think of those pretty large
number of clinically extremely
vulnerable people in this country does
he agree
my honorable friend is is is absolutely
right and we've we've heard the
arguments in in outline which is it's
about protecting staff it's about
protecting patients this is not a new
precedent there's a professional
obligation which does make this slightly
different to the experience uh in care
in the care of social care Workforce of
our common to talk about what the
government needs to do there these are
the arguments uh broadly but I would
just ask members on all sides of the
house just let me make this point and
I'll certainly give way I would just ask
members on all sides of the house to
think about those NHS staff who go to
work every day feeling unsafe because
their colleagues are not vaccinated
and if that's not persuasive enough I
would ask them to think about how they
would feel if a loved one were treated
in a clinical setting or Care Home by an
unvaccinated member of Staff through
whom they contracted covid and with it
serious illness or worse if I lost a
loved one to serious illness in those
circumstances I'm not sure I would be
very forgiving about the decisions made
by members of this house
the point The Honorable gentleman is
making but that's not what the results
of the survey found when conducting it
with NHS staff a healthcare and social
care Workforce found that 55 of people
in the NHS were against this so how does
he respond to that
no doubt whatsoever and I don't dispute
the opinion in the workforce is divided
opinion in the workforce is divided and
it's partly divided because people
because people resent the mandate
but altar just a moment ultimately it
really does it really does come down to
this and not just in terms of the broad
arguments
um I made or indeed the specific cases
we might be confronted with without this
protection at what point
do we as a house think it's acceptable
for people working in Health and Social
care who have a duty of care to their
patients to say I am making a choice to
put them at greater risk I am working
against the very principles that
encourage me to sign up to my vocation
in the first place and that's why
ultimately I think on balance this is
the right measure but I will certainly
come back shortly to the way in which we
need to take the workforce with us and
what we need to do ahead of April
I'm I'm very grateful to my friend for
giving away and he really is setting out
with great care uh his is very very
careful response to all of these uh
proposals uh on this uh vexed issue of
mandatory vaccinations really except for
me that my own trust 97 of the staff
have been properly vaccinated of the
three percent there's a significant
proportion of those who are new stars is
making their Journey towards a proper
vaccination so it isn't that clear and
of course we do have responses from the
BMA uh Unison RCN United CSP GMB RCM and
Royal College of GPS who are actually
opposed to making this mandatory and
prefer persuasion to coercion does he
not think that we should be uh adopting
that approach
well that is a very helpful intervention
from my honorable friend and let me be
uh very clear I absolutely acknowledge
uh the views that have been put forward
by the Royal colleges and by staff trade
unions government ought to take them
seriously and ought to work heavily with
them in this next phase where there is
still a window of time for persuasion
and I also point the government to the
success that the Welsh government the
Welsh labor government has had in
persuading the workforce I think there's
much to learn there's time available and
we've got to work in a spirit of
partnership and I'll say more about that
in just a moment because the honorable
gentleman at the back has been very
patient
I'm very grateful to the shadow secret
stating can I endorse and welcome what
he said at the start of his speech with
regards to comments about the uh Nazis I
called that out yesterday and he was
right to do so at the dispatch box
but could I I was looking through my
inbox at this go back to the start of
the pandemic in lockjam and virtually
every single person working in the care
sector or the NHS in my constituency was
perfectly legitimately saying when the
vaccine is available we must be the
front of the queue because we are
dealing with the vulnerable it is our
duty to get vaccinated I don't think
that has changed and I think he's
absolutely right as is the Secretary of
State for those who are caring for those
who are most vulnerable in society to
try and reduce the risk that they face
they should be vaccinated
I agree with the I agree with the
honorable gentleman and look we've got a
big effort to boost the booster this
month I mean we've got to boost the
workforce as well and make sure that
people
um are are supported
I certainly will I've got this is a
difficult decision two members from the
same region but the honorable member
right in the corner has been very
patient and then I'll come to my right
of a friend I really appreciate my
honorable friend for giving away and
he's making uh an excellent speech but
the BMA have identified some serious
concerns in terms of mandatory vaccines
the fact that we have a chronically
understaffed NHS and do you believe or
does my honorable friend believe that
this is likely to have
um a significant impact and more harm
than good going forward
really I think that's such an important
point I'm grateful for my to my
honorable friend for making that
intervention I think there there are
there's a reassurance I'd like to offer
her and then there's a call to action I
would like to issue to the government
the reassurance is there were concerns
about what would happen to the social
care Workforce and that very much
influenced Labor's position on that
statutory instrument at the time but we
did not see a collapse in the social
care Workforce numbers that were warned
and there was lots of evidence that it
had a positive impact on take-up I'll
give let me just finish this let me let
me just finish this let me just finish
this point
but I do also want to say to the
Secretary of State and his team
asking the Health and Social care
Workforce to do their Duty as
professionals the government must show
greater respect to their professional
voice and experience on pay on
conditions on workload it is often said
that the NHS runs on Goodwill so I would
like to see the government showing
greater Goodwill in return and to engage
with the Royal colleges and staff trade
unions not just on the plan for vaccine
rollout to their members but on the
debate about the future of our Health
and Social Care Systems and the big
Workforce Challenge on vaccination there
is still precious time to do the work on
persuasion and having met with the trade
unions in recent days had a great
meeting with unison yesterday which I
should also declare maddened up speakers
I'm a member of Unison Unison has some
really helpful advice and practical
feedback about the kind of conversations
with Occupational Health that are making
a really big impact in giving staff the
confidence to choose to take the vaccine
well ahead from the deadline and of
course we would much rather persuasion
than compulsion I'll give way to mind up
a friend
thank you
giving away instant talents we have 99
of their Care Home staff vaccinated in
Western Hospital best hospital in the
country we have 91 first vaccine 39
second vaccine and 64 of the booster
this has all been done with persuasion
not with the threat of the sac these
people are in a vocation it isn't just a
job to them they believe in the patience
we must knock that to that stage where
we're threatening people it's been
curved the GPS have even been involved
in persuading the clap on staff everyone
has been involved for some considerable
time and that's the way to do it in
order order let me just make this clear
there are over 40 people who want to
speak this afternoon
and if people make interventions it's
simply not fair on those who are at the
end of the list who will be trying to
speak later on
um I'm Not The Honorable lady is only
one of many
um the shadow secretary of state is
being very fair as was the Secretary of
State in answering all the questions but
I must ask people to be reasonable
was treating thank you madam speaker it
may have been a speech rather than
intervention but I thought it was a very
good one and I welcome what my honorable
friend has said and I'll give way to my
right honorable friend
the uh my my honorable friend for giving
way
um will he acknowledge that there is
vicious and very effective psychological
propaganda that anti-vaxxers are using
to upset and worry people who may be
vaccine hesitant particularly about
issues with fertility and whether the
vaccine in halal and all of those things
does he agree with me the government
should do much more to counter this very
vicious and damaging propaganda I
wholeheartedly agree with my right or
befriend and this comes back to the
point I made about the government
engaging with staff trade unions and the
Royal colleges whatever their policy
position on having mandatory vaccination
he will find in them willing allies who
want to help the government to persuade
colleagues to engage with them and to
deal with some of these dangerous
conspiracy theories which which are
knocking public confidence and creating
real fear and anxiety entirely without
basis and so I really hope that on this
point when the government concludes
later on they will set out how they plan
to engage and will give an undertaking
to work with the staff trade unions and
with the Royal colleges because I think
that would do so much to achieve the
objectives we all share but also to
raise morale in the workforce who often
feel that they are slogging their guts
out for the government but don't get the
hearing that they deserve I'll give way
to this honorable gentleman I'll come
back tomorrow
thank you for giving away he's making a
very good speech and I apologize for
interrupting him but on a point of
science will he just accept that he's
got it a little bit wrong having the
vaccine doesn't stop you spreading it it
just makes it much less likely that it's
going to harm you very badly so you can
have the vaccine and you can still
spread it and to imply otherwise is just
wrong
can I just say to The Honorable
gentleman who has who has called
repeatedly from a sedentary position
that I don't I know the science that I
has I said nothing of any sort to
contradict the points he has just made
and with respect to members opposite and
particularly people who oppose these
measures I think the thing that they're
missing is that what is indisputable is
that the booster does provide greater
protection than the first and second jab
that vaccination full stop provides
better protection and that if we're
talking about NHS pressures and
Workforce pressures the biggest danger
is that the virus sweeps through the
Health and Social care Workforce knocks
a load of people out in the middle of
the busiest period for the NHS and then
the system topples over I don't know why
it has to be explained again and again
and again to members opposite that the
objective here is to protect the NHS and
to stop it from toppling over at a
critical time so these points about the
severity of the virus or the efficacy of
the vaccine and preventing transmission
or serious illness are largely secondary
questions because we know the virus is
spreading we know it is spreading
rapidly and we know that if it rips
through the Health and Social care
Workforce that is the biggest risk to
the NHS that is what is going to topple
it over and their constituents will not
thank them one bit if they allow that to
happen
it's grateful tomorrow friend who is
making an excellent speech and uh and
putting his case very forcefully it's
this issue versus coercion versus a a a
persuasion
and involving trade unions and the rural
colleges in in taking staff with NHS
managers what wasn't respected it by the
Secretary of State when he was asked
about redundancies earlier on is that
this is a retrospective change in
people's terms and conditions and even
people who are vaccinated will be
resistant to the to the change being
imposed upon them so we have to go
forwards carefully and take staff with
us so would he urge upon the government
that they should work with their own
colleges and trade unions to take this
form but my honorable friend made such
such an important point and I think
that's why going back to the staff
surveys it's not that staff particularly
given that the overwhelmed majority of
staff are vaccinated it's not that they
don't want their colleagues not to be
vaccinated is that they do have concerns
about the way in which the government's
going about this now we accepted from
the government and from NHS England a
very clear view that Omicron has raised
the stakes in this regard and that has
had a big bearing on our position and it
is very difficult for for me very
difficult for my colleagues on these
benches to put ourselves in a position
where on the other side of the argument
from the NHS and from the public but
that doesn't mean that this point about
engagement isn't really important and
the government has got to work with the
workforce to take them with them because
they really are you know we have it's
not good enough for us to just clap for
the NHS or clap for carers we have to
work in partnership with them and
respect that these are people who have
given their lives to public service and
caring for others they do care they will
instinctively be on the right side but
they just need some persuasion some
patience and genuine engagement and
that's why I think the government's gone
slightly wrong
I'm very grateful to my honorable friend
who started off his speech in a an
excellent way and has got better
as she's gone
as he's gone through it I say that and I
will certainly not be in the same lobby
as soon on some of the votes uh this
this evening but there is a general
point to the specific point she is
making on vaccines and that is I think
that the government should be as clear
and explicit and transparent on every
issue that they make if they're not just
want people who are worried about
vaccines but worried about this affair
if they want to take them with us but
repeatedly the government has refused to
do a cost-benefit analysis on the impact
of their policies and we've got before
us now a number of sis without impact
assessments does he agree with me that
that information should be available
say to my honorable friend that in his
intervention he started off well dipped
in the middle and then got better at the
end and I think he made some absolutely
Fair points
um about about about impact assessments
and transparency in fact I can see the
vaccines Minister waiving impact
assessments so I'm sure she'll make them
available to my honorable friend and it
does come back to
um this point and and it's come up at
various points today and and previously
when we've discussed these
um these sorts of restrictions and
measures and it's how I began uh my
contribution and it's how I'll begin to
to close we we really can't be
complacent when it comes to public
support public compliance public consent
for the measures that we are considering
because we know that we've asked so much
of the British people and they have done
their part we also know that recent
events have dented their trust and
confidence and their and their
willingness to comply because they've
seen number 10 doing one thing and doing
another which makes it even more
important that when we discuss measures
that impact on people's lives
livelihoods and Liberties but we are
having these sorts of exchanges we are
rigorously rigorously looking over the
evidence we are testing each other's
assumptions and we are coming a conclu
coming to a conclusion and I think with
some of the exchanges we've already
heard today uh that that people across
the country on both sides of these
arguments can at least take some
reassurance from the fact that when
these matters are under consideration we
do take them seriously and I think the
government could do a little better
sometimes on bringing measures forward
in advance of of their implementation
and setting out the rationale and
argument and not just assuming that
because measures have been supported by
the public before they're supported
today I think we have got public support
for the measures under consideration
this afternoon but I don't think we
should be complacent about it and that's
why I think it's right we're spending so
much time exploring these issues I'll
take one or two more interventions and
I'll conclude
I found one of a friend for giving away
and he's making a very important point
that we need to make every decisions on
the evidence that is available does he
agree with me that having a debate today
and passing these measures tonight is
urgent we've heard as well that the
doubling rate of Omicron is actually
shortening and if we are to protect the
public our families and our communities
in the run-up to Christmas and Beyond
and our NHS these measures need to pass
today
agree with my honorable friend and
particularly in this city and the the
the the
reproduction rate of this virus is is is
shortening for every day and the numbers
the Secretary of State set out and his
opening remarks I think should
concentrate Minds before people walk
through the division lobbies this
afternoon
um fun though it might be to see the
government in hot water and struggling
in votes it's not in the National
interest and that should be the thing at
the Forefront of our minds
things that will reassure members across
the house is seeing that commitment at
the dispatch box from the government
that if further restrictions were to
come into play that a vote would be had
in this house
I agree with the honorable member look
we can't have spent so much time and I
appreciate she's a newer member of the
house but I dare say she was watching
proceedings before she arrived and we
can't have spent so much time in this
house talking about parliamentary
sovereignty and then throw it out the
window uh in the next Parliament so I
think that is a point well made myself
and the shadow Public Health Minister
we've already agreed
um he's bringing the dinner I'm bringing
the pudding and we'll see if the common
shop is doing crackers on discount uh
before we if we're meeting over
Christmas
um but look finally and seriously uh
Madam Deputy speaker we think there are
areas where the government can and
should go further without impacting on
people's lives livelihoods and Liberties
on ventilation in schools we know that
young people have borne the brunt of
this pandemic and we owe it to them to
their education and to the staff who
support them to make sure that their
school are properly ventilated they
can't wait until October next year for a
review to be published we need action
now I wonder if the Secretary of State
or or the minister for cabinet office in
Winding up could say something about
that
and on Jabs for young people the
Christmas holidays seem to ask to be an
ideal time to get young people
vaccinated so when does the government
think we can see action on this front
and finally on statutory sick players
we've already heard very powerfully from
my honorable friends we know we know
that there are people out there who are
forced to choose between doing the right
thing by their families and doing the
right thing by public health because
they simply cannot afford to isolate at
home so we implore the government to
again to act by making sure that higher
statutory sick pay is available to
people immediately so that they can
afford to do the right thing
Madam Deputy speaker we have not played
games with these votes we are not
exploiting the divisions in the
conservative party to inflict defeat on
the government for the sake of scoring
political points the threat facing the
country is too serious and labor takes
our duty to the country seriously the
Tories may be in disarray but the public
can rely on labor to keep the country
safe to do the right thing to support
these measures today and we trust the
British people to do the same
father of the house sir Peter bottomley
Deputy speaker
I hustle want to acknowledge the power
of the speech that the obsession
spokesman has just given we wish his
predecessor well and the one thing we
can say about the gentleman is his voice
carries very well around this chamber
the government
is right to ask for support for these
regulations
I'm glad the opposition will in general
be supporting them and I will as well if
the public health risk increases we have
to ask what kind of changes the
regulations a proportionate and
appropriate and it may have missed gone
past some of those who've written to me
about it that some of the regulations
are actually relaxations
others are not
they are trying to make sure that some
places can stay open if people abide by
sensible uh
precautions
one of my constituents has written with
me today
says that he and his family and many of
his friends will not go to places of
public congregation because too many
people are not vaccinated or showing
that they are not infected by the virus
that may be a minority of you expressed
but I think actually it's one that was
held in the hearts and the minds of very
many of our constituents
for those who've said the impact
assessments not being made it has it's
been published those who invigilate
assessments don't think it's adequate
but that's a side point in Annex B on
pages 54 and 55 it shows the proportion
of people by age in the National Health
Service who have been vaccinated I think
we have to recognize that one of the
reasons why half of them are under the
age of 40
is that the opportunity of vaccination
came later for them than it did for
those who are older blood systems they
don't think it matters to them it does
for the reasons of our honorable friend
the perhapsing doctor gave that if you
are caring for people who are vulnerable
and obviously people in needing Medical
Care are vulnerable the same way in
Social care they are
most that we can do to protect ourselves
is also having the impact of protecting
them so if in doubt get the protection
of the vaccine and the booster gives I
was going to make a rather longer speech
but I'm actually going to stop now
because I think many people want to
contribute many of whom will disagree
with me I'll respect what they have to
say but I'll say very clearly I back the
government in these regulations
Graham Stringer
thank you madam Deputy speaker as you
know is trying to help you with the
intervention by withdrawing from the
list because I'm grateful to be the uh
top of it on this side the
I agree with the my right honorable
friend the leader of the opposition when
he says that the prime minister is a
threat to Public Health I think that's
absolutely right I draw a different
conclusion
from my friends on on the front bench to
this as how we should respond to this
not by being irresponsible but by taking
a look at the way the government has
dealt uh with the whole of the kovid
crisis from the very beginning and are
still continuing to do as a member of
the Science and Technology committee
together with the health committee we
produced 150 Page Long report
which I hope honorable and right
honorable members have the time to read
because you may not agree with the
conclusions but it has very uh valuable
information in it I think the key point
in it which a lot of the press missed
was that not that the government
followed
uh the Scions on on this issue
but that they got into a group think
with the scientific advisors and
actually didn't challenge them they
assumed that science was something that
handed down tablets of stone whereas it
is not it is a process and it needs
challenging both by those of us who have
responsibility in this house for making
laws and policies as well as being
challenged by other scientists and we
seem to be repeating that process again
along with a northern honorable members
we
interviewed had as a witness Susan
Hopkins uh this this morning and
as an advisor
let me say are the best if I can use a
word that somebody else used the advice
we were getting was opaque
the information we were getting was
opaque when it should be transparent
one of the this time last week
the Deputy Prime Minister
stood up and said there is no no plan to
go to Columbia we're not going to plan B
36 hours later
we were starting Plan B why was that
what was the scientific advice given we
were told fairly definitively that there
was no such advice given that changed
the view what changed the viewers that
the Prime Minister was in a state of
Crisis and under pressure from his own
backbenches and everybody everybody else
that is not sensible way to make
decisions it is not a sensible way to
make decisions to put forward statutory
instruments that stay on them and the
minister was waving a sheet about which
may or may not be the impact of
assessment but it the satishary
instruments themselves say there is no
uh impact assessment that is being done
one of the other issues that has
happened during this process is that the
code
I give way to The Honorable Men Tim I
just have got in my hand the impact
assessment for vaccination as a
condition of deployment in Health and
Care Providers I wasn't able to get in
earlier but I feel confident that the
front benches will know that the
estimate is that 88 000 people will
leave the health sector sector 73 000
from the NHS 15 000 for the Independent
Health sector and 35 000 workers in
domiciliary care does he agree with me
that that enough is a reason to vote
against imposing this on the nation
it's very interesting that is it also
interesting that the papers that were
circulating that I got from the post
office said there was not a an impact
for assessment and that doesn't impress
me the point I was just about to make
and I don't know if other honorable and
right honorable members have noticed but
there was a 350 page Act passed at the
start of this epidemic uh the covid ACT
uh it's barely been used
the government could have used the Civil
contingencies act to bring in some of
the items that they they've brought in
uh to restrict people's freedoms maybe
necessarily maybe unnecessarily the
difference between the Civil
contingencies acts in the 1984 Health
Act
it's quite simply that there is less
scrutiny in the 84 Health act much less
scruffin is available once the acts are
passive is not a sunset Clause they lust
and I think the government should not be
rewarded for unnecessarily using tough
authoritarian legislation when other
legislation was available which would
have allowed more scrutiny they've
refused to give information and let me
say this and I come back to my honorable
friend on the front bench starting off
his speech by saying different people
have different views way different
factors civil liberties Health in in
different ways that's absolutely
absolutely
right on this point but the government
will not tell us
uh how many they will not tell us the
costs and benefits of these policies we
now know three-quarters of a million uh
people have failed to be tested for
cancer some of those not a win-win
situation here cancer patients get to be
tested will eventually die because of
the decisions taken here because
Services aren't available some people
will die of coveted in order to come to
the right decisions this house needs to
have all the information available that
isn't coming from the NHS and it isn't
coming from government ministers that is
well I will not give the Prime Minister
the benefit of my support for the way he
has arranged uh to respond to a covid
crisis
said Desmond Swain Mr Speaker
in a typical Winter's day
between 200 people and 350 people will
die of flu do we hide behind our masks
do we look at home working from home do
we demand that people provide their Bona
fides before going to a venue do we
require people to be vaccinated as a
condition of keeping their jobs the
question is whether the the measures
before us today are proportionate
actually comes down to a matter of
opinion do you take seriously some of
the extraordinary extrapolations that
we've been given particularly given the
record of before the fact that these are
things that might take place and we have
to balance that against the known costs
and damage to enterprise economy and
society and in the end it comes down to
a matter of opinion a matter of our
prejudice
and we are typically capable of
organizing our lives
and making those decisions for ourselves
we decide what our risk appetite is and
what we're prepared to encounter and
what we're prepared to not
notwithstanding the Carnage on our roads
certainly killing more people than
covert at the moment some of us still
decide to drive
it's a matter of opinion
so it comes down to letting loose the
dogs of war get the Fear Factor into it
get the members of the officials the
members of sage the members of
Independence age of spy m
all those of course speaking in their
own private capacity get them out there
twisting the fear lever what about the
um in the the uh Health Protection
Agency what what stalinist Minds thought
up that nomenclature get them out there
twisting Their Fear button and by and
large you will get the reaction that you
want people will crave more enforcement
and what theater measures to protect
them from this great danger that is out
there and let Hospitality be just
collateral damage let them endure the
Deluge of cancellations now affecting
that industry and what should be its
most productive time
that's the situation that we have
delivered the government having
administered this ministry of Affair
Affair is absolutely complicit with its
officials and its organizations that
have designed it and delivered it
they have abandoned in doing that any
principle of social democracy of liberal
democracy
absolute Beyond it but beyond anything
that we've endured in recent living
memory in the history of this uh
pandemic
and as a consequence having abandoned
What Might Have Been their ideology they
are rudderless and as a consequence of
that so much more at risk of the
opinions and predictions of the advisors
to which they are in Hook
Caroline Lucas
thank you very much Mr Deputy speaker I
have just come from a meeting of the all
party group on coronavirus and we were
given a shocking set of presentations I
know my honorable member the the member
for West Oxfordshire and Abingdon will
say some more about this shortly but I
wanted to bring three key messages from
that meeting of scientists and NHS
professionals the first is that the NHS
is beyond full stretch already right now
some said it was at breaking point and
they pointed out that we are not in
South Africa where they started their
Omicron wave at a very very low level we
are starting it on top of a rising
number of Delta cases and that means we
have to get transmission levels down now
the focus on vaccination alone while
vaccination is vital will not be enough
it means that we have to focus on a
range of other measures like
ventilations in schools as others have
referenced but also the big issue of
limiting social contact we need to be
honest and we need to have consistent
and clear messaging about the need to
reduce that social contact there is a
direct relationship between the number
of contacts that we have and the spread
of infection so guidance to work from
home yet still giving the green light to
Christmas parties is as the professor of
primary care in Oxford suggests akin to
advice to wash your hands after a meal
but not after you're going to the toilet
all of us are dreading the prospect of
not seeing lived ones I will in a minute
loved ones again at Christmas but that
is exactly the direction in which we are
headed unless the government shows some
leadership and tells us the unwelcome
truth we might not like to hear I give
away the honored lady because she and I
share a hospital trust but she will know
that that hospital is not being
overwhelmed at the moment by covered
cases and the pressures of kovid that
hospital is being overwhelmed by cases
of non-covered illnesses which have been
neglected during lockdown and by the
failure to be able to release people or
medically fit for discharge those are
the real pressures on the health service
at the moment not a torrent of covert
cases coming into them as it stands
isn't that correct
that may well be
the case right now but I don't see why
that is an argument about saying that we
need to get coronavirus cases down if
transmission rates go on the trajectory
that we are being told that they will
then we can be absolutely sure that the
pressure on our hospitals and on our NHS
trust is going to be massive so I don't
disagree with the point that he's made
but I don't see that it's a a criticism
of the argument that I'm advancing it is
precisely because of the multiple
pressures on our hospital system that we
need to get the transmission rates of
Omicron down and indeed Delta down that
is why I want to see the government get
rid of the disincentives that are
currently built into the system that
stop people from being able to
self-isolate when they need to why do we
still not have that better sick pay for
self-isolation why do we not have the
better support for our businesses
because we know that if there's going to
be reduced social contact as there needs
to be that has an impact particularly on
the hospitality sector so what we need
to see is for example the vat reductions
being extended Beyond April where it's
due to end we need businesses to be
offered grants to help them through
these next difficult weeks as well as
the flexibility on paying back covered
loans my constituency in Brighton
Pavilion is already feeling the impacts
of Omicron on the hospitality sector
there is extremely worried so why can't
we not tell them for example that there
will be extended and expanded business
relief with the government ensuring that
local councils don't lose even more
funding indeed as well as a proper
scheme of support for the self-employed
who as we know play such a key part in
our economy and yet have been utterly
left out from previous support
mechanisms now turning to the statutory
instruments before us today I very much
regret that the government has given MPS
less than 24 hours to analyze these sis
and frankly they have not Advanced the
scientific case a public administration
committee inquiry early in the year that
the government hasn't made a robust case
for vaccine passports and I haven't
heard anything today that has persuaded
me otherwise and whilst I recognize the
civil liberty arguments on these
measures and I have sympathy for them my
bigger concern is through the strong
body of evidence about the impact of
vaccination passports on vaccination
rates because this makes clear that
whilst amongst those inclined towards
vaccination vaccine passes can
accelerate the take-up rates they also
entrench opposition amongst those who
are hesitant as Professor Stephen
Reicher has said people not getting
vaccinated isn't some kind of cognitive
problem it isn't that they don't
understand the issues it's a social
problem people aren't getting vaccinated
because of a lack of trust and trying to
force them into it either with vaccine
passports or mandatory vaccination in
some settings compounds that mistrust as
does berating them or other in them if
we want more people to be vaccinated and
believe me I absolutely want more people
to be vaccinated that is the bottom line
of course we do but we have to build the
sense that vaccination is being done for
the community not done to it it is for
the common good Behavioral Science
clearly indicates that coercion
undermines the relationships that we
need to build and the respect that we
must show one another in order to
increase vaccination rates and we do
everyone a massive disservice By
ignoring that science
finally Mr Deputy speaker I just want to
say a word about the wider Global
situation we face it is supremely
reckless to have so catastrophic
catastrophically neglected vaccination
in poorer countries and as it extremely
representative of our government to be
refusing to support the trips waiver at
the World Trade Organization as we need
by Amino the executive director of un
AIDS has said Omicron is with us because
we have failed to vaccinate the world
the government should be absolutely
changing its position when it comes to
that trips waiver it should not be
blocking it this virus is one that we're
with us for years and years to come and
it will mutate into other viruses and
variants unless we treat this as a
global crisis not just a crisis that
here at home so I beg them to look at
the evidence look at what works and move
forward on that basis Dr Liam Fox
uh thank you Mr Deputy speaker may I
begin just by seeing a word about the
vaccine program and make a plea to
ministers
it's very important that with the
emergence of Omicron we don't
accidentally underplay the success of
the vaccine program to date we know that
the vaccines will produce a number of
immune responses the the production of
neutralizing antibodies the production
of marker antibodies and a T Cell
response and although with Omicron a
booster dose is required to get to the
level of neutralizing antibodies that we
saw with our response with two doses to
the Delta variant
the whole program gives both individual
and Community protection and we're
starting from a very different place
when we were with the Delta uh variant
and can I say that it's very important
we encourage people especially young
people to get their second dose so can I
make a plea that we stop hearing from
ministers this phrase two doses don't
work three doses do I think it is
actually undermining the government's
own uh program and can I also make a
plea that we drop this constant
reference to the doubling time of the
current variant because the measured
doubling has been two days in the very
early stages is no measure whatsoever
that that would be something that we
will see again in the future if it
doubled every day then the whole
population would be affected in nine
days this is not modeling this is simple
extrapolation which actually doesn't
contribute to a sensible debate uh or on
the subject now when it comes to the the
proposals we have in front of us today
lawmakers I believe need to look at the
elements of necessity are these measures
proportionate are they enforceable and
will they be effective so let me begin
very briefly with the 10-day quarantine
this was a bad measure to begin with
it was disproportionate and it was
likely to see a recurrence of the
pandemic all over again so I'm glad that
it's being dropped but I have to say
that the point made by The Honorable
member for Exeter is an absolutely key
one which must be answered by the
government if having the red list is
pointless if having enforced 10-day
quarantine is pointless why do we still
have some people in enforced 10-day
quarantine uh it's it's absolutely
incumbent upon the government having
abandoned the policy to let those people
go free otherwise I fear they may face
legal action
he's making a very important point there
are some Welsh rugby players who had
covered in South Africa they did 10 days
quarantine in South Africa they're now
halfway through quarantine in England
and they're being told that they've got
to complete the whole of the quarantine
when when things are that illogical it
brings the whole thing into distribute
they agree with the honorable gentleman
and what we do not require is more
advice for ministers on this subject we
require decisions from ministers uh on
this subject on the second issue Mr
Deputy speaker that of masks now I get
letters as I imagine all members do from
from people who say there's no point in
wearing masks masks don't actually stop
transmission I imagine that those people
therefore wouldn't like their surgeons
to wear masks during a surgical
procedure this is a nonsense it's a
common sense thing for us to do if it
reduces transmission to some level it's
a minor inconvenience to the vast
majority of people and it's a sensible
measure for the government to bring
forward and therefore I support it I
cannot say the same for the government's
covered passports I don't believe it
passes the necessity test I think the
good working of the insurance industry
and the ability of civil remedy in the
courts is enough to drive behavior of
venues towards sensible Public Health
policy I think that we as a government
should not be creating criminal offenses
unnecessarily I worry about enforcement
I worry about penalties on a system
that's already overloaded there's no
evidence from Scotland or elsewhere that
the covered passports actually worked
France was mentioned earlier there are
more than twice as many people in in
France in hospital with covert than
there are in in the United Kingdom I
I've given them away once I'm very
conscious that colleagues uh want to
speak so I won't give away again and I
also come back to this point of lateral
flow test I presume that you can't do
your own test and it has to be
externally validated which will add a
cost to anybody who wants to go to any
of these venues and which I suggest
therefore is not the help to the
hospitality industry that has been uh
suggested by either the government front
bench or the opposition front Banks
today and then I briefly will touch on
the issue of of compulsory vaccines
many people in this house
took the view took the view that when we
had the introduction for care workers it
was the thin end of the waves but we
were assured it will be care workers and
no one else now it's all NHS workers
with a few exemptions and the grounds
for the compulsory vaccine is that they
will be dealing with vulnerable members
of the public well so will the police
soil elements of retail so will post
offices where does it stop once you
begin this the point was made by The
Honorable gentleman I think very very
validly that this is a retrospective
change in the terms and conditions of
people who already work in the NHS and
it is likely that we will lose staff as
a consequence completely in my view
unnecessarily when we've seen that over
91 of NHS staff have volunteered already
to have the vaccine I think it's
disproportionate and I don't believe it
will be effective for those reasons I
also believe it's illogical because if
the logic of the government's position
on the covered passports is that you
must be given a choice between being
vaccinated and getting a daily lateral
flow test why does that not operate in
the Health Service as well for those who
actually want to have a choice between
vaccination and having a lateral flow
test it's the lack of logic in many of
these which I think is actually
diminishing support for the government's
case and can I just finally end on a
positive note these many of these
measures are relatively small beer
compared to what we can achieve from the
booster campaign and I think that it's
essential that the one message that we
leave this house with tonight is that
every one of us has a duty to say to
every one of our constituents go out get
immunized get a booster because it's the
best way that you can help you your
family your communities and The Wider
Public Health if there is to be
unanimity at this time of year Mr Deputy
speaker in this house that is surely the
message that must resonate
Justin matters
having had the GPS pleasure of spending
an inordinate amount of time in various
committee rooms during the past 18
months scrutin scrutinizing regulations
put forward by the government as part of
their response to the pandemic I was
confessed I've had withdrawal since
installing the reshuffle so I'm pleased
to have the opportunity to speak on the
regulations today I'm sorry to say on
too many of those previous occasions
regulations have been debated well after
they've come into Force so it's a
positive we do seem to be getting into
the habit of the last alone debates and
votes before regulations become become
Lord I wouldn't want that to be seen as
a ringing endorsement of the
government's approach to parliamentary
scrutiny because two of the regulations
before us today were only published at 3
P.M yesterday afternoon less than 24
hours before this debate began and I
know things move on quickly but some of
these regulations have been the subject
of consultations for many months there
is no excuse for them to have been
dropped in at the last minute like that
and I have to say the decision to reveal
the precise detail of these regulations
at the very last minute has probably
generated more oppositions to some of
the regulations and is actually
warranted I've had many representations
from constituents about the entry to
venue regulations on the basis that they
represent a compulsory vaccine passport
let's be clear they do not a negative
test taken in the 48 hours before the
entry can be used as an alternative and
that deals with a lot of the concerns
that have been raised with me legitimate
concerns I sent about civil liberties
and discrimination so I'm pleased that
my party's persistence in pushing for a
negative test as an alternative has been
accepted because that does give me
enough Comfort to support these
regulations today
I thank my honorable friend for giving
away and I'm sure across the house that
is what so many of us have been calling
for is greater transparency from the
government the more we hear from the
chief medical officer the more
concerning it is if there had been more
transparent up front I'm sure it'd be
greater support from across the house
indeed if we look at what's happened in
Wales we've had a similar system for
some time which seems to be working
reasonably well people have been
required to produce tests when traveling
abroad and a number of venues in England
have actually been doing this on a
voluntary basis so this is not the slide
into dystopia that some people fear but
I think it's not been aided by the fact
the government has not been as upfront
as they should have been about what
these regulations actually mean and I
know a lot of people are already taking
lateral flow tests routinely before they
go out there are however some
outstanding questions and concerns
raised and there's no doubt that some
some constituents still feel this is the
start of a slippery slope and we will
soon have to show vaccination papers to
get in anywhere I'll be clear I don't
support such a move and give them the
government can't even bring itself to
mandate to wearing the face coverings
and pubs I'd be surprised if they would
move in that direction but I do want
confirmation when the minister winds up
that they aren't planning on any
extensions to where this regulation were
operating I do think we also need a
clearer explanations to where the line
is drawn as to which venues applying
whether it actually places such as this
where which falls into the definition of
a public hall indoors of with 500 or
more people who stand up and move about
actually falls within the um the
regulations as well because my reading
of it suggests that it does and if we're
going to be gaining the confidence of
the public we've got to show that the
rules apply to us equally as well and
another concern that I think has rightly
been rage is about whether there will be
some charge introduced to obtain lateral
flow tests at some point in the future
which would obviously undermine that as
an alternative to showing a vaccine
status I have no doubt charging people
to obtain tests would be an absolute
disaster from a public health
perspective and that goes Way Beyond the
remix of these regulations but I do hope
we can get confirmation from the
minister there are no plans to charge
for tests either and we do need the
government to be doing rather better
than it has been in setting out what it
considers the cost to be to businesses
of these regulations again I know
there's been no impact assessment for
the entry regulations who is going to be
picking up the cost of enforcing them
there's nothing I can see about
supporting businesses to check people
let alone providing resources to local
authorities who are meant to be
enforcing all of this I can Minister set
out what the position will be if there
is a national shortage of tests we're
told there are tens of millions of them
but as we know the challenge is getting
them out to the places and people who
need them in those circumstances will
the regulations be suspended or will be
people pushed down the vaccination route
that said the evidential burden for a
negative test does seem to be
particularly broader I think that will
assist in reducing the burden on
businesses but I do think it also means
there is an increased risk of fraudulent
tests during the rounds which I think
would undermine the whole point of the
regulations we do not want the worst of
all worlds an expensive bureaucratic
system that doesn't actually help reduce
transmission because it isn't enforced
properly I'll talk briefly now about
vaccination of NHS stuff because there
is plenty of evidence to suggest the
small but significant proportion of
covert emissions are a result of people
acquiring the infection in hospital so
I've seen figures suggestion that has
been as high as 15 to 20 of all covered
emissions although one once the staff
started to receive the vaccination that
did drop them up dramatically so I think
there is evidence to suggest that this
will have an impact on Covert emissions
and The Wider pressure on the NHS and I
know it's difficult but I think on
balance it does need to be supported but
it shouldn't be the end of the story
we've had a Workforce crisis for years
covered accelerated cases of burnout and
only a few weeks ago the government
passed up the opportunity the grass the
nettle by refusing to implement a
long-term Workforce strategy that is why
we need an awful lot more work on the
regulations but in conclusion I think
the government have got a real uphill
struggle to earn people's trust to
explain why they consider these
proposals necessary to convince the
public that what is before us will be
the limit of the restrictions and that
we won't be talking about extensions or
changes at some point in the future
because judging by the comments of many
members opposite it seems the government
have failed to persuade a number of
their own back benches in this regard so
it's a little Wonder we're all being
bombarded with emails from our
constituents expressing concern but that
exposes a wider truth the government
have vacated the space where leadership
should be compromised by their own
failure to follow the rules ridden with
internal disagreements about the route
ahead and unable to provide the
authority needed to persuade a skeptical
public that these measures are needed
Steve
for that to speaker here we are again
and uh this time two weeks on I think
the concept of learned to live with
kovid is As Dead As anything I know we
were told in July in this house from
that box many many times and from the
podium in number 10 that we are on an
irreversible road map to Freedom do we
all remember that
I have to say I thought it was an unwise
Hostage to Fortune when it was said and
so it has proved
now when I vote here tonight I'm going
to consider the legislation before us
and I completely agree with the previous
speaker it should have been published
long before less than 24 hours before
the debate and that's why I certainly
didn't tell anybody in the media how I
was going to vote today because I'm
rather old-fashioned and like to
actually read the legislation that's
before me before I decide how I'm going
to vote I wish the official opposition
front bench had done the same but I look
at the legislation I also look at the
intention behind it so what's the
intention here is it to stop Omicron you
know is it to slow the spread well
that's clearly not happening now so I
guess the question that we've got to ask
then is are these foursis before us
going to do that now working from home
is not an SI it is guidance
we're told that our that people need to
to work from home where they can but
they can then meet those very same
people in the pub that evening every
evening
is that going to slow the spread I don't
think so now when it comes to masks I I
didn't I I abstained on the mask uh SI
two weeks ago and I would do so again
this evening I I have no issue with
wearing a mask it doesn't impact on my
life it doesn't impact on my freedoms
many of my constituents have been
wearing masks in plenty of situations
indoors and out for a long time
throughout the pandemic I think it's a
bit of of a crutch but if people believe
that it makes them safer then then that
is fine and I guess in many ways it is
an instrument of people feeling their
say but looking at the SI that's before
us aren't before us on Mars wearing Mr
Deputy speaker you know we have to wear
a mask covering it in certain shots but
not in pubs not in restaurants and and
some of the exemptions in there I think
make a mockery of it but I won't stand
in its way and then on the on the on the
covid passport I mean if you were to put
aside the practicalities and the moral
arguments which I do not and many of my
constituents writing to me certainly do
not then a vaccine doesn't stop you
getting this it doesn't stop you passing
it on Professor Whitty said to MPS on a
call this lunchtime that there is a
minimal impact on transmission of all of
our all of our vaccines so last
Wednesday when the sector states that
therea made his late night statement I
expected it to be because that statement
came earlier than we expected I expected
him to bring forward a devastating piece
of science which basically said the
drugs don't work that isn't what he said
he said we're moving Plan B based on on
the basis of some some modeling yet we
have Sage's gloomy predictions and a
confirmation that vaccines do work with
two Jabs even better with a booster
completely agree today we have a study
that says the fisa vaccine has 70
efficacy against the onocron variant
last Wednesday's statement of the house
Mr Deputy speaker in my opinion should
have been about the national booster
effort
that was announced on the live TV
broadcast on Sunday night I can't say
how many of my constituents have
contacted me furious at the frightening
nature of that broadcast and sent their
children off to bed terrified if we
truly mean this learn to live with covid
Mantra that we hear and continue to hear
the booster campaign is 100 where our
Focus would be and an ongoing plan to
keep immunity high is what we should be
focusing on and this is where I just
wanted to focus my remarks is that a new
Primary Care infrastructure is probably
what we need because Panic stations and
cancel all else is not a plan Mr Deputy
speaker I spoke to three of the four
primary care networks that cover my
constituency yesterday they're going to
do their absolute everything to offer it
to all eligible over 18s by the end of
this month but it's going to be really
difficult they're scrambling around for
venues in the week of Christmas I just
don't think that's the long-term
thinking that we need
on on the actual regulations so 1400 on
face coverings I'm ambivalent to that I
I won't stand in its way on isolation
moving to test I I will support that if
there's a Division I don't suspect there
will be but if you can't get the lateral
flow test as you haven't been able to
today and yesterday as I raised in my
intervention with the Secretary of State
then then we get the pandemic anyway so
we need to sort that Supply out on on
the vaccine passport I will not support
that I think it crosses a Rubicon I
think Italy began in exactly this way
saying it was all about providing
lateral flow test and I think it will
move and move quite quickly on the
mandation of health staff I will support
that to be consistent with the mandation
of vaccines in the care sector I just
think if you work in the Health Service
working with vulnerable people you have
to be leave in science surely Above All
Else and there is of course precedent
because of hepatitis B so it's a mixed
egg for me mixed batch for mail supports
some of the measures before us today I
won't support others thank you
Daisy Cooper
thank you Mr Deputy speaker we all know
that the NHS is facing one of the
toughest Winters in living memory not
only is covered a very real threat but
we are also facing a potentially uh very
tough flu season as well liberal
Democrats will be supporting the sis on
face coverings and self-isolation but
let's be clear when it comes to masks
the government should never have
scrapped the use of masks on the 19th of
July earlier this year the government's
Obsession for removing all precautions
in one go had far more to do with party
management than it did with Public
Health
we have all made tough sacrifices
throughout this pandemic and asking
people to wear masks on public transport
would have been a very small ask with a
very large payoff
we also support the working from home
guidance and have been calling for that
for some time
now today we are discussing the plan B
protections to reduce the spread of this
disease
but there have been rumors overnight
that the government is also working on a
possible plan C
it's also been reported that the UK
health and security agency has privately
advised the government that and I quote
stringent National measures will need to
be imposed by the 18th of December
that's in just four days time
this drip drip of information is causing
huge uncertainty and anxiety
we need clarity
and we need it now
the British public are haunted by
Christmas Past
we know that that last minute u-turnment
that many people ended up spending
Christmas on their own and with just
days to go we need the government to
come clean and tell us what Omicron
means for Christmas this year
we in the liberal Democrats welcome the
ambition of a million Jabs per day
and we sincerely hope that it makes up
for the complacency around the booster
scheme over the last few months
but the way in which that Target was
announced no scrutiny
no details it was a real insult to all
those who were left to scramble on
Monday morning to pull a plan together
the idea that NHS staff
GPS and their staff local authorities
the military the idea that none of them
had been given any prior warning of that
announcement is extraordinary it
highlights the government's complete
lack of planning
and those people who are we are now
asking to vaccinate Millions the idea
that they were an afterthought is
shocking
but here we are
and as always our NHS the GPS their
staff local authorities military and
volunteers are stepping up and as a
country we are grateful
now the government still hasn't made a
commitment this afternoon that if it
brings in more protections of any kind
that this house will have the
opportunity to scrutinize those so
there's a few points I want to get on
the record right now
if the government is considering any
further protections we must support
small businesses and our high streets
Hospitality businesses are experiencing
unprecedented rates of cancellation for
this festive period
and they would they were experiencing
that even before the latest protections
were announced
hospitality is technically allowed to
stay open
but all of the mood music is telling
people not to go and that is causing a
huge problem and that is why we have
called on the government several times
to call and convene an urgent
Hospitality Summit to see what support
businesses need right now
if there are further restrictions we
must also look after people's Mental
Health we need supported isolation not
loan self-isolation there must be
financial support and practical support
for those with caring duties and for
those that live alone
and our schools our children have
suffered
so so much it was months ago when
liberal Democrats called on the
government to make sure that there was
an air purifier in every single
classroom in England and we are still
nowhere near that
and finally for all of these measures to
work there must be Trust
there has to be trust in the government
and with that in mind what we need now
from the Prime Minister and his cabinet
is the truth
will the government come clean about
Christmas or will we see another last
minute U-turn that ruins the Christmas
holiday and which is too late to
alleviate pressure on the NHS I
sincerely hope that it's the first
thank you Mr Deputy speaker over the
last year I've supported some covered
measures and voted against some as well
so with that in mind that my
constituents may be struggling with the
logic of my voting record but I believe
it is indeed straightforward and I hope
to exemplify why that's the case where
these measures have felt
disproportionate to The Wider harm I
voted against their introduction in the
last year an example of this was putting
the constituency in differing tiers when
Hospital admissions were low whether
hospitals could not cope I did support
lockdowns as proportionate in those
dramatic circumstances where the wording
of measures felt contrary to the aims
they sought to deliver I voted against
their introduction the 10 pm curfew was
a good example of this everyone piled
out of the pub and on to public
transport and the government eventually
conceded and reversed and that was the
same concept that led me to vote against
the self-isolation regulations of last
week I couldn't understand why when
Omicron was going to become the dominant
barrier and we're requiring people to
self-isolate it would have led to a
pandemic and I'm glad that the
government is reversing that today and I
will gladly support that regulation as
for the other three my thoughts are as
follows for face coverings I voted for
the same outcome for retail and public
transport last week I don't want to see
face coverings become a permanent
feature and I do not want to see them
reintroduced in the classroom but for a
limited period of time in the settings
referenced it feels right for me to
extend the scope for NHS workers being
vaccinated I voted for the same outcome
for the social care Workforce and will
do so again we know that getting
vaccinated reduced the Delta
transmission rate by 60 we also know
that patients who get vaccinated are not
completely protected from serious
illness or death surely if Co if care is
in the DNA it is not unreasonable to
expect vaccination to be an entry point
if an HS workers believe that their own
choices come from come before the safety
of their patients or if they don't
believe that the NH chest is about
working for Kobe and working for
vaccines and the evidence on those is
true I question if they are in the right
profession for vaccine certification at
larger venues I am genuinely perplexed
about the outrage at worst at showing
paperwork last month I got asked my
passport when I came back into the
country I have to show evidence of
purchase while I watch a football match
I was also delighted to be asked for ID
showing my age when I wanted to buy a
beer only a month back what's the issue
in temporarily asking someone to
evidence vaccination or a negative
lateral flow test for certain venues if
it keeps people safe and in jobs because
we don't have to put more Draconian
restrictions on events and Hospitality
that I'm happy to oblige the impact of
the Omicron bearing is not known what we
do know is that the doubling rate is two
to three days for Delta it was seven
days in South Africa where the variant
emerged the hospitalization rate is now
Rising yes the vaccination rate is lower
in South Africa however it's also their
summer
they have a higher level of antibodies
for natural infection and the average
age is 13 years lower than in the UK
these restrictions are limited in time
and scope I ask myself this what is it I
will not be able to do tomorrow which I
could do last week the answer is
absolutely nothing a little more face
mask wearing a little more admin to go
to the football if you're an NHS worker
and are not going to vaccinate then
there are record number of jobs
available for you to work somewhere else
there is a larger issue at play which I
find infuriating over 80 of my
constituents have got themselves
vaccinated they are keeping themselves
safe and their communities safe they are
minimizing their own impact on the NHS
they're a small minority who are not
playing by the same rules and have the
temerity to lecture me on freedom let me
tell them this their freedom to remain
unvaccinated and then do as they choose
is reducing the freedoms of those who
have done the right thing for themselves
and The Wider community as a
conservative I believe that rights are
not absolute they have to come with
responsibilities
being a Cavalier for freedoms is what we
were sent to this place to be being
Cavalier about the health of the public
is contrary to that principle with that
in mind I will be supporting these
proportionate and limited measures this
evening
Mr Deputy speaker and given time I will
concentrate my comments on mandatory
vaccinations for NHS staff I find myself
really torn on this emulsive subject and
I also find myself trying to apply logic
to what is quickly becoming an illogical
argument from the government benches
if it's really about patient safety the
government should have already
identified workers in the NHS who are
still unvaccinated and have been working
with them to alleviate fears concerns
and removing barriers
Dave's should explain to this house why
it's acceptable for those in the NHS Who
currently remain unvaccinated to work on
the front line to assist with the
Omicron crisis become the first of April
to be dismissed quite frankly it makes
no sense
today comparisons have been drawn in
this house about the requirement of NHS
staff to be vaccinated against hepatitis
B
the reality is that chapter 12 of the
public health England green book that
provides the latest information on
vaccines and vaccination States
hepatitis B
is recommended for healthcare workers
who may have a direct contact with
patients blood or blood stain body
fluids it is not law
the government proposal will see these
workers who work around the clock during
the next few weeks and months only to be
dismissed on the 1st of April if they
don't succumb to mandatory vaccinations
I will give one I'm very grateful to my
old friend from uh for giving away does
she agree with me that if it is the case
that these measures will come in to
force at the beginning of April there is
an ideal opportunity if the party's
concerned are to be participate in a
framework agreement for the rollout of
these Provisions to work through how
they may be implemented and by rushing
those today we're being we've been
robbed of that opportunity despite those
noises from the BMA and from the unions
I'm from the Royal colleges
I thank my honorable friends for the
excellent points he makes which I agree
with wholeheartedly
the workers that I'm talking about
are the workers who at the start of the
pandemic went around the clock
despite inadequate PPE because they were
putting the nation first
these are the workers who will continue
to work around the clock over Christmas
and New Year periods and in in an
institution that is built upon consent
between patient and clinician the
government are ripping up that rule book
to Seuss its own ends whilst at the same
time we are seeing the 17-3 organization
of the NHS since 1993.
yeah we clap for our care workers and NH
staff on a Thursday
they will now get us through the latest
crisis over Christmas and the new year
but then a government who ripped up the
rule book last Christmas whilst the rest
of us obeyed the rules sacrificing loved
ones some in their final moments are now
going to dismiss workers in April and
all this while number 10 and the DFE had
Christmas parties not only did they have
Christmas parties but they told this
house and the nation that they didn't
this message is inconsistent and makes
no sense
Mr Deputy speaker we are told to trust
the government
but what is increasingly concerning is
we are seeing this from a government who
is currently reviewing the Human Rights
Act and wants to replace it
and I think we should be very afraid
because this could be a sign of things
to come from a government and prime
minister who believe they are above the
law and even worse if they don't like
the law and it doesn't serve their
purpose anymore they will rip it up and
start again until they get the policy
they want or the outcome they want
irrespective of civil liberties or
economic damage
the right to choose particularly when it
comes to our own bodies is something we
should all take very seriously
I personally implore everyone to get
vaccinated and boosted to protect
themselves and others but we have seen a
precedent set by this government which
should worry every citizen for the first
time ever we have seen the profession of
care workers singled out and have
conditions attach their their employment
status which was never there to begin
with
there is so much that could be done by
this government in the weeks and months
ahead from constructive negotiations
with the trade unions Who Remain opposed
to mandatory vaccinations to ensuring
Global authorities and Health Services
have the resources and capacity required
to deliver the ambitious daily targets
around boosters to ensuring that
statutory sick pay is set at the rate of
the foundation living wage and most
importantly the government could also
follow the rules themselves to give the
public confidence that any measures
introduced are proportionist and
necessary
as someone who before entering this
place represented care workers NHS staff
and public servants many of whom are now
my constituents I take the
responsibility very seriously to ensure
their voices are still heard whilst
trying to balance that with the
unprecedented situation before us and
the importance of Public Health
I personally think we can do just that
by consensus rather than compulsion and
today I implore the government to OLS on
the issue of mandatory vaccinations to
remove that particular statutory
instrument and work with the trade
unions and the labor party and all the
trust Party Support in this house on
that very issue the secretary of state
has said himself we have seen an
increase in vaccination rates since the
start of the consultation please remove
this site let's work together let's get
the country vaccinated thank you Dr
Andrew Morrison Deputy speaker and I I
draw your attention to my interest in
the register I'm a doctor and vaccinator
um SI is 1400 14 15 and 1416 are without
question relatively modest certainly by
comparison with the restrictions that
currently apply in other similar
jurisdictions and they fall on the 26th
of January which is a very good thing
but I would like to urge ministers to
think about the rapidity at which the
evidence is changing at the moment the
evidence from South Africa is relatively
positive and particularly impressed by
the fact that mean hospitalization with
this particular wave is 2.8 days it was
previously eight days and of course that
was with the predominant beta variant in
South Africa when we have had Delta here
which is worse we can deduce from that
because it's the same population with
the same demographic issues that this is
relatively mine that has to be our
working hypothesis but we really don't
know we're struggling for evidence and
that evidence appears to be evolving by
the day and it seems to me
um unreasonable for the public to see
their representatives leaving this place
for two weeks when really they would
expect us to be here
calling the government to account
on a real-time basis and that means this
house sitting next week and the
following week inconvenient that may be
for a lot of college and I would urge
ministers to give that some thought so
that we can for example consider advice
on working from home which currently is
having a significant impact on sectors
of the economy Century instrument 1415
is permissive I congratulate the
government for that I welcome it that it
should avoid another ping uh endemic the
advice about taking a lateral flow test
every seven days is sensible but only of
course if lateral flow tests are
available I've heard from my own
constituency today that they are not I
hope ministers will attend to that as
best they can statues of 1400 on face
coverings I can't get too excited about
it the best evidence published in last
month's British medical journal
meta-analysis suggested that there was
some effect by wearing mask on
transmission and therefore I think it's
the least we can do to wear The Wretched
things
um
now the measure extends a list of venues
that require a mask
um but the prevalence of mask wearing in
any event of course as we've all seen
are those of us use public transport and
and shops has increased in any event
thanks to the good sense and a Goodwill
of the British people which needs to be
encouraged at all times statues at 1416
access to venues starting starts getting
a little bit more sticky the Secretary
of State's workmen like recasting of
vaccine certificates as an alternative
to a negative lateral flow test
yesterday I think was very helpful not
terribly much help though by the remarks
of the chief medical officer attributive
the chief metabolic earlier today we
seem to suggest that transmission for
vaccinated people is rather less than
many of us have previously hoped that
did nothing to advance the case the
government is now trying to make but I
will be more relaxed upon that
particular SI The Siam regulated
activities I'm slightly concerned about
if a recent negative natural test is
okay under si-1416 to extend 1415 why
not for healthcare workers the
difference between with respect to my
colleagues
um BCG and hepatitis B for those with
exposure Pro and procedures with our
National Health Service and this is
there is an alternative to demonstrating
that you pose no threat to your patients
and that is a lateral flow test
conducted very recently and it seems to
me given the regulatory policy
committee's dummy assessment of this and
the likelihood that we will lose quite a
few people in a Health and Care system
that can scarce afford to loose people
as a result of this so we need to be
looking at alternatives to keep them in
not least because even the even the
vaccinated will feel the pressure of
some of their colleagues who are
unvaccinated leaving this could be
something of a perfect storm in the
winter months and I hope ministers will
look again at whether we can have
lateral flow testing if you like on a
daily basis as I've had when I've been
jabbing as an old alternative to
insisting upon vaccination and please
ministers will you look at the
quarantine hotels and the requirement to
bang people up that is completely
untenable given the change in advice I'm
very surprised that treasury lawyers
already haven't been advising ministers
that is just not appropriate and I
suspect there will be a whole wall of
cases if those people are kept locked up
when in fact they should be released in
accordance with ministers very very
welcome announcement today on the red
list
Dame Meg Hillier thank you Mr Deputy
speaker and I rise today in the short
time I've got available to particularly
focus on the statutory instrument 1416
on Entry to venues and the issue of
compulsory vaccines
and it feels like I've been around this
block before because I just over a
decade ago I was the identity cards
Minister the responsible for identity
cards and passports in the last Labor
government uh and yet I share concerns
about Health Data being routinely
required to access services but when we
dealt with identity cards we were
absolutely clear they were about
verifying in that case identity with no
health information included despite
lobbying from some groups to have health
information on those cards no
immigration status on those cards though
of course many of my constituents and
people up and down the country do have
cards with their immigration status on
which they are happy to have to prove
their rights and there were other
lobbying to include things like veteran
status on cards but we pushed back hard
on those as a labor government and there
was absolutely in law no requirement to
have an identity card to access any
public service and the latter is very
important because this proposal tonight
does not require you to show your
vaccine status to access a public
service it's about accessing optional
large events where you could be a
spreader an ID cards of course all
had a really clear basis for doing this
and they were long-term they were
debated at length twice in this house
indeed because the general election of
2005 interrupted the process
let's be clear that a vax a covid
vaccine taste test document or on your
app it's a temporary measure
it expires I've just had my booster had
I not done it would be a moot point as
well how long that second vaccine would
still give me the status that I would
require and of course the secretary of
state has said that the booster will be
required once it's rolled out on that
passport for it to be valid on that path
for it to be valid and it's not required
to access any public service which I
think is an important step because if we
were to go down that route we would then
need to get it onto a statutory footing
and I hope we never get to that point
but we do not know what is going to
happen with coronavirus as it stands we
haven't had a version of this that will
kill our children
um that I thank good God for that but we
know that this is a not yet over but at
this stage there is no proposal for a
permanent covid pass and there is no
need therefore for a statutory footing
because we hope this will be something
that will run into the sand
um and it's also a health treatment so
when I prevent my past it tells me
enough tells the person nothing other
than my name I think my date of birth's
on there but sadly I think people
probably have worked out I'm no longer
21 and I don't really mind about that
that's information that you need
um in order to get into a venue I'm
prepared to take that choice and it's a
compromise because if we do not do this
the date will show although even
vaccinated people can catch it and
spread it it reduces that and the
booster reduces it further and for
Skeptics a hundred percent safety let's
be clear would mean a lockdown or
closing down these Hospitality venues
closing down events and closing down
workplaces in schools and no one wants
that so it's not a perfect solution to
stop spreading Omicron or any any
variant of the of the virus but it
protects our hospitality industries and
events even though they are still hit it
protects them from complete closure so
this approach a temporary and near
Universal coverage limited information
required to be presented and no
requirement for venues to hold copies of
our data I think is a proportionate
response and it's a responsible thing to
support each other individual Freedom as
outlined by The Honorable member for
bexon battle and is that it cannot be at
the expense of wider freedoms we do have
that responsibility with that freedom I
want to just touch on compulsory
vaccines for health workers and I
congratulations me my honorable friend
from the front bench for his tour de
force on this because I am concerned
about pushing people forcibly to have a
vaccine but we should never have got to
this point and we should rely now on
reliable information and education to
make sure that we do not get to the
point where people have to be forced to
do it we can't actually Force someone to
cause to have the vaccine so the
consequences for a health worker is
immense But ultimately for those people
who are health workers working at the
front line to support their patients
this is going to now have to be a
requirement for the job because the risk
of spreading it or the risk of being
sick so much across the Health Service
if we don't have staff who are protected
we'll also [ __ ] our health service so
reluctantly I've moved to the point
where having voted against it in the
past I will support that measure tonight
because spreading a virus that makes us
ill kills us and put pressure on the NHS
is not something that NHS workers can be
a part of but we must work hard and the
NHS England must work hard to convince
and support people and and get rid of
this disinfect information about
dangerous the dangerousness of vaccines
Mark Harper
Mr Deputy speaker let me just start with
a few words about well I think the big
picture is here and I think my honorable
friend the member for Winchester put it
very well we know covert is going to be
with us forever and we know we're going
to have variants forever the chief
Scientific Advisor has told us that and
I agree with him so there are many
people who think somehow we just have to
wait a bit and then it'll all be over
that's not happening so we've just got
to be realistic about what we face now
we face in this country we face this
Challenge in a situation where we're
probably according to Jeremy Farah
probably the best protected country in
the world from vaccination and this was
effectively the first big test for the
government about how you deal with a
variant of concern with a very well
vaccinated population and I'm very
disappointed that we very quickly gone
into panic and emergency mode with late
nights Sunday night broadcasts not in
the House of Commons where questions can
be asked frankly scaring people witness
and telling them for example that two
doses don't give you any protection
which is of course not true two doses
have weakened protection with Omicron
against infection but actually still
very good protection against serious
disease and I'm concerned there are many
people out there who will have had two
doses who are perhaps vulnerable who now
feel they have no protection which is
simply not correct and so I think
actually if this was the first test I
don't think we're doing very well
against it of course
the data we heard this morning in
science and technology committee from
South Africa is that you do still have
good protection from five two doses of
Pfizer against severity but it's gone
from 93 to 70 in terms of
hospitalization that's four times the
risk of hospitalization
yes I've seen that and I look forward to
the information from the UK and one of
the points I've been making and my
um constant repetitions which one will
run on my friend from Southwest Works
repeated about the house uh sitting next
week or the week after being recalled is
that we're learning new information
every day and when we get that
information we may need to make
different decisions and the house needs
to be involved in those decisions not
just decisions taken by ministers by
decree and I repeat that point and I
don't understand why ministers won't
give that Assurance it would build a lot
of trust and Good Will with colleagues
and I don't understand why they won't
give that commitment these decisions
have significant economic social impacts
as well as impacts on the NHS delivering
non-covered treatments my honorable
friend already pointed out the NHS now
is going to scrap a whole load of
elective surgeries and consultations
with GPS in order to get boosters
delivered now that may be the right
position and I don't think a proper
balancing has taken place and goodness
knows how long it's going to take us to
recover from that new creation of a
backlog over the coming months now if
the government's fears that the
Secretary of State set out are confirmed
in any way the question I have for
ministers is what is the exit strategy
what is the approach that they're going
to take that means that we don't face on
and off seasonal restrictions forever a
point made by other colleagues it's a
very serious question if we're going to
have an economy that functions people
able to build lives that function and an
NHS that can function and deliver all of
the other health care we require let me
just turn up briefly Mr Deputy speaker
to plan B very happy to support the
measures on self-isolation I just note
that two weeks ago when we were asked to
vote for restricting them I voted
against them and two weeks later the
government's basically agreed that I was
right two weeks ago to vote against them
because it's effectively revoking them
and I just leave that fault with
colleagues when they decide whether they
wish to listen to the advice of
ministers or others on vaccine passports
the points I would make would be these
in the government's own plan B it's very
clear Minister's preference is for is
for vaccine only passports it's very
clear to me that the only reason why
tests have been Incorporated is to buy
or secure the support of the Opera
position that's the only reason
Minister's preference in writing is for
vaccine only certificates and so we know
what ministers would like to do if they
could get away with it the Secretary of
State also made some commitments about
not being in support of mandatory
vaccination for the entire population
and all I would say is the only reason
why that
needed to be said was affected it was
the Prime Minister two weeks ago who put
on the table
the whole concept of mandatory
vaccination when he talked about having
a national conversation about it so all
I would say is ministers need to be very
careful again if they wish to build
trust and Good Will and to be careful
about what they say and don't fling
these very troubling Concepts around
without thinking about them words have
consequences both in terms of what
happens in the real world but about the
trust that you build both with members
of parliament and with members of the
public the final thing I tell vaccine
passports is they're very limited at the
moment about what's proposed but that
was true everywhere they were introduced
around the world everywhere they've been
introduced they've been extended in
terms of the venues they apply to and
we've seen that in Wales where labor are
in power so anyone who thinks that
they're going to stick to what's
currently on the order paper I'm afraid
of kidding themselves the final thing I
would say to colleagues is this the vote
on vaccine passports isn't just about
the the regulations on the order paper
it's a signal about how we wish to treat
this house
how we wish to be treated on behalf of
our constituents and about the direction
of travel and the approach so I'd say to
my colleagues if you wish to send the
government a clear signal then it needs
to rethink its approach and certainly on
vaccine passports vote against them send
the government a clear message we can do
better there's a better way to do this
send that message today
Lola Moran
Mr Deputy speaker
um
the last week has been tumultuous and we
are about to go off on our Christmas
break and the only positive I can see a
party gate is it took Boris Johnson
being on the front excuse me I do
apologize the Prime Minister potentially
being on the front pages of all the
newspapers on Monday morning
to then come out in favor of more
a different approach to plan B and I can
only say that thank goodness for
partygate because had that not happened
I do wonder how much longer we would
have waited for the government to act
and do something
and the reason why this matters is
because every single step of the way
through this pandemic we know that the
longer we have waited the worse it gets
the sooner we act the less we have to
act and the better the benefits are
this morning the all party parliamentary
group heard from the same experts many
of whom advise the government and also
people who are representing Frontline
NHS workers and we were wanting to
answer a simple question
what's going on tell us about umicron
but also is it enough
on Omicron itself
it is startling
two-day doubling
is quite scary
and between the time if all of us got
our boosters today if all the rest of
the population were to have it today
the numbers would increase such that it
was 60 times more in the time it takes
to develop the immunity
because it takes 12 days more or less to
develop the immunity after you've had
your booster for you to then become
protected and that's why the two-day
doubling matters and it's true that when
you start to put these things in place
when you get that booster immunity in
place then the two-day doubling will
increase which is a good thing because
we want the time to increase which then
reduces that Peak and my concern is that
we haven't gone fast enough soon enough
you then look at evidence from places
like Denmark now much has been made of
South Africa and it is true to say that
the populations aren't directly
comparable comparable there are some
things we need to take heeds so for
example just this morning there has been
new evidence to suggest that Omicron
seems to affect children young children
more than Delta
now it takes tiny tiny amounts
of percentages of children getting sick
for us to start seeing them following
through into Hospital admissions and
remember it's children who are as yet
unvaccinated they have no protection at
all so the first plea I make to the
front bench is where is the plan for
children
it needs to go beyond hoping that
they're going to be okay because it
would seem this variant is potentially a
threat and I will send the front bench
the evidence that I've seen and it's
sincerely alarming and I hope they take
it seriously
but the other thing that we see from
Denmark is just the shape of the curves
and Mr Speaker I know this is hard to
show when we talk and I will say it for
the benefit of Han solid but the blue
line here is Delta the red line here is
Omicron this is coming this is data from
Denmark I will post it on Twitter if
people want to look at it
but there is a blue line that looks like
it's a gentle slope for the benefit of
Hansard and there is a red line that
looks like a hockey stick and that is
deeply deeply alarming so what does this
government needs to do well it's gone
from plan a to plan B
and it's considering once we get Plan B
through B to C now if I was the teacher
before if that was happening to a
student of mine I would get the parents
in and get them to have a chat because
what we need to do is to go from B to B
plus and what does B plus mean well it's
booster absolutely it's booster
but we have to recognize between now and
then it's not enough we need to
ventilate our public spaces we need to
provide support for social care because
unblocking those beds in the NHS
requires extra support in Social care
we need to ensure that test trace and
isolate works that means allowing people
to get tested and we've seen the issues
already but we also need to help them
isolate we need to limit mixing and if
people if people won't do it themselves
the government needs to act and we also
need to bear in mind the effect of long
covered in all of this if there are huge
numbers of people that already have it
many many more are going to so I urge
the government don't hesitate act
quickly please don't curb Christmas go
from B to B plus now so we can enjoy the
holiday ahead
Andrew Bridger thank you Mr Deputy
speaker whenever this house passes
legislation it is essential that is it
is effective
evidence-based logical and it needs to
have broad public support and what I see
in front of us today in regard to plan B
delivers on virtually none of these
items indeed if I look around social
media look in my constituency email
inbox or just going General conversation
with others it's clear that these
measures before us today are being
treated with strong suspicion of a wider
agenda
partly because they simply will not
deliver on their supposed intentions
sadly today the party opposite will be
supporting the government as legislation
passes to introduce vaccine passports
for the first time in this country
so it will fall to back benches on this
side of the house the only people who
will be subjecting these proposals to
any sort of scrutiny
no doubt Her Majesty's loyal opposition
would also like to partake in the
proposals to discuss mandatory
vaccination as well given the fact that
they have supported every one of the
government's lockdown proposals indeed
they've demanded longer and stronger
lockdowns than we've had
it would be remiss of me not to
highlight the risks to the NHS that both
vaccine passports and mandatory
vaccination would bring
vaccine passports tell those unconvinced
of the science or those who for health
reasons cannot take the vaccine that
their second-class citizens they must
show their papers all be banished
mandatory vaccination would take these
things a step further effectively
imprisoning anyone who doesn't agree
with the status quo all these measures
are being considered or may be taken to
protect our NHS
and all this fixation on the uh on the
vaccine status of Health and Care
workers yet we know from the science
that vaccination does not prevent
transmission of the virus
so why are we going to put tens of
thousands of people out of a job at a
point when the NHS itself is going to be
stretched to the Limit
and may add when their vaccination
status makes them little more or less
dangerous to the people they work with
or work for if they're tested daily
indeed the best protection of all is
actually having had the the virus and
then you recovered the scientific
evidence shows that that is often 10 to
20 times less likely to be reinfected if
you've already had them recovered from
the virus they feel double vaccinated
and yet
many thousands of individuals in those
key worker roles who've had and
recovered from the from the virus but
refuse to have the vaccine will actually
lose their jobs at a key time it's uh it
is an inconsistency
turning to the necessity of these
restrictions
there have been no doubt far fewer
deaths due to Omicron variant in South
Africa despite the fact that it's been
prevalent for four months and has
replaced other variants there that were
more deadly in various ways all the
evidence we're hearing is that Omicron
is a milder form of covid with fewer
cases of serious disease fewer
hospitalizations and thankfully far
fewer deaths
Mr Deputy speaker in my view the most
dangerous epidemic sweeping the world
and sweeping our country is an epidemic
of fear yeah yeah it has seriously
damaged mental health and in
particularly damaged the mental health
of our young people
it must end
Rachel maskell yeah yeah thank you Mr
Deputy speaker I Rise to express my
serious concerns about the principle of
mandatory vaccination not for any
ideological reason because it has the
country effect for which it is intended
and therefore is wrong
first of all Mrs Deputy speaker I want
to say that my concerns are first and
foremost for Public Safety and also
patient safety that is the analysis I
bring having worked in the NHS for 20
years myself as a clinician that has
drilled into you from day one
and I think the lack of a strategy the
government brings to managing this
pandemic is quite astounding and they
really need to understand that you need
to get ahead of a virus in order to lock
it down as opposed to locking people
down and their Futures down but also the
lack of consistency which continually
comes through their policies you can't
have it both ways it has got to be one
approach which carries that thread of
containing this virus you can't say in
one venue you're going to lock it down
and then another venue you've got all
the freedoms you need because that
simply doesn't work in fact it's
dangerous and therefore the government
needs to get a grip
but at the very people that we revered
just a year ago we were clapping and
calling our heroes are the very people
who are now exhausted traumatized and
frightened
and this legislation before us will
stack them
for two decades I was their colleague
and I know the dedication the compassion
and care they give to their patients I
was their Trade union leader and I know
the professionalism and sacrifice they
gave for the people they care
I will not undermine that trusted
relationship which is absolutely
essential as to how we deliver Health
Care in our country
and I will not run Russia over Labor's
NHS Constitution which pledges to assist
people to participate fully in their own
health care decisions and to support you
in decision making I will not turn my
back on working people
and I will never forget my roots and
those I served alongside and while the
Prime Minister partied NHS workers put
layers of PPE on and fought for lives
it's what you do in the NHS you make
sacrifices and while traumatize you just
keep going I'm happy to give away I
thank my friend for giving way and her
excellent work at Trade union leader in
the NHS is well understood
she's speaking on behalf of NHS workers
has she any idea how many will be
affected by this uh in my view totally
wrong attempt to force vaccinations and
passports on people
well I'm grateful to my honorable
Friends making that intervention a point
I wanted to make myself in government's
estimates 123
000 uh in their impact assessment and
even the best case scenario is 62 000
people will lose their jobs something
the NHS just simply cannot afford I will
give way briefly I thank my honorable
friend for giving way
yo I know my honorable knows the health
fair work the health workers and the
care workers
it's the house please and I know I'm to
apologize for that I know my friend
knows co-workers and health workers very
very clearly she knows him and she knows
how to Dedicated their lives it's a
vocation that they have would my
honorable friend agree with me the
government should and can stop going too
far that is not great the trust between
patient and worker and between
government
let us go down the route which has been
proven to work at persuasion and
education and to ask them and to work
with them to distill the fear
I I thank my honorable friend who also
represents her constituents so well and
there is an alternative path we can go
and we can go that way today
we know that the prime minister is
allowing people to go to pubs and clubs
unmasked while sucking NHS staff wearing
full PPE and testing 93 of NHS staff are
vaccinated the ons figures show that
four percent
uh of people a vaccine hesitant and that
rises to 21 among minoritized
communities and we have 22.1 percent of
NHS staff from minoritized communities
these regulations will Target black
workers in fact 26.8 of black workers
are not vaccinated 20 sorry are of mixed
race and and 26.8 black workers too this
is in the government's impact assessment
and therefore it indirectly
discriminates against black workers
unvaccinated staff
they're frightened on Friday I spoke to
an NHS worker in my constituency worked
for the NHS for 16 years her father had
a vaccine his heart stopped miraculously
NHS workers brought him back to life he
is now in a critical condition she is
frightened she tests she wears PPE she
has sacrificed everything she will be
sacked
I want all NHS and Care staff to have
vaccine counseling and education with a
qualified practitioner holding the right
competencies so that concerns can be
explored not a line manager they just
don't have the competencies I want
everyone to be vaccinated and I can't
stress that enough I want to win the
trust of staff not push them further
away which this approach will do now in
York where we have had a focus on those
trusted conversations we have seen 99 of
our social Care staff vaccinated it just
shows what works what makes the
difference we don't want to push people
further away we want to bring them in
and win their trust and win their
confidence because we're going to have
to ask more of our Health and Care staff
as things get harder and certainly if
there's less people in the service to
deliver that so let's do what works
enforcement never does and therefore
these regulations are illiterate vaccine
illiterate
so if around 123 000 lose their jobs it
will be catastrophic in the midst of a
Health and Care crisis not least as
people are starting to hand in their
notices now why go through another tough
winter of trauma when you don't have to
and these regulations are making it
worse we know that two vaccines or even
three will reduce someone's transmitting
the virus so get your Jabs but it won't
stop transmission so let's move to
better PPE ffp3 Mass daily testing and
better biosecurity and I urge the
government rather than pushing these
regulations today go back bring a plan
forward to this house and let's vote on
that plan in January that is good
governance and the way forward but as a
trade unionist I'm not prepared to be
complicit with the sacking of NHS and
Care staff trade Juniors fight for
working people never complicit in
writing their people 45 and as a trade
unionist I came to this place to fight
for working people and therefore I urge
that we change course and put the staff
first and the care that they have for
their patients Sarah brickliffe
to agree with
look at bringing in mandatory mass in
the hospitality sector the damage that
will cause for the small pubs in
heinburn would be
are huge so we have to try and mitigate
that as well
um I first want to start by saying I am
against mandatory vaccine passports and
the government would have had to present
me with significant evidence to change
my mind so the fact that the secretary
of state has been very clear at the
dispatch box to say that he is against
us as well has eased my mind and I want
to also be clear this vote was never
about mandatory vaccine passports it
basically states that if you don't want
to show up that you've had the job just
show proof of a negative test which is a
key caveat for me and I think
members should really be careful with
how they were this because it's
irresponsible to push that to the public
and make out that it's something that it
isn't
um I would like reassurance from the
government that if anything above this
was to be proposed that there would be a
vault in this house so that this house
decides because I think again what we're
looking at is as many people many
members across the house looking at this
plan C
Etc and the same but where does this end
well actually if we have a vault on any
further restrictions we're all looking
at the measures that are in place today
and voting on what is in front of us and
I think that's really important
um I I am in a position where we can't
keep locking down there has to be an
exit strategy
um it's just financially unviable and so
these limitations for hospitality and
things like that that's that's key for
me
um and these measures are just temporary
so we can see what actually is going on
with Omicron because if we put ourselves
12 months ago where we were in the
position where we could see our family
for one day over Christmas look at these
restrictions now compared to what we
have had where we were only allowed out
of the house for an hour a day to
exercise for me just to see what is
going to happen when we know it's really
transmissible
putting certain measures in place that
we're seeing today is not as Draconian
as what we've had and I think I think we
need to really make that clear to the
public but the key thing is for me if
there are further restrictions if there
is this plan to see bring it to the
house make sure that we all have the
opportunity to have us here and have our
vote on this these measures are being
put in place to make sure that we keep
our freedoms to make sure that we can
keep going to the pubs keep going to the
clubs with our friends and actually it's
just a little measure to make sure that
we can spend Christmas with our family
and I think it's better to be safe than
sorry
Flora Anderson's removed
Mr Deputy speaker and a thank you to
everyone across the country who has had
their booster and everyone who's been
lining up across centers throughout the
country to make to take the time to make
sure they've done the right thing and
get their booster and a thank you to all
of those NHS staff who enabling this to
happen who have putting on a mighty
mighty push to change all of their ways
of working and to get the booster into
as many people as possible and a thank
you to all those who've written to me
about the issues under debate today
those who have said we should have more
measures
um they will only feel safe to go out to
go and take up NHS appointments if they
know to go out into into public spaces
if they know there are more measures put
in place and to all those who written to
me about the concerns they've got the
concerns about more measures being put
into place more restrictions on our
lives and it's quite clear that Omicron
is quite is a clear threat highly
contagious doubling every two days most
cases in London are now Omicron cases
and um they are increasing all the time
two vaccines don't now reduce the rate
of transmission as much as they did for
Delta and it's clear that action must be
taken
so we know it's more contagious but we
don't know yet the severity but we
cannot wait the government waited too
much
last year at the beginning of
coronavirus They delayed for sometimes
weeks and we saw the effects of that so
we cannot wait we have to act now and
these are a measured and proportionate
set of actions
on masks I don't think we should have
dropped that from the first place we
should never have stopped wearing masks
on public transport for sure
um and and in shops to keep shop workers
safe so I welcome that
on the vaccine passes they are not a
vaccine passport and I'm very glad that
the government has listened to labor
saying that there need to be options
either showing the double vaccination or
showing a negative lateral flow test is
absolutely proportionate to enable big
venues and our Hospitality venues to
stay open really so important after last
year and so much loss of income they
need to be able to stay open and so when
this is a freedom freedom to be able to
go out enjoy those events enjoy being
out with people whilst also staying as
safe as possible
we know that there will be a peak in a
couple of weeks of the number of cases
and then it will only be a couple of
weeks after that that there will be a
peak or not in hospitalizations in the
new year when we return to this place so
it's absolutely right that we're taking
these measures now to stop those
hospitalizations later
I welcome the change on the red list
list of countries that the minister
announced earlier um if it's not having
any effect there's absolutely no reason
to make people
unable to go and visit their family in
South Africa for many of my constituents
but also to pay huge amounts of money to
be quarantined here as well and I also
welcome the minister saying that he will
look into those quarantine costs of
those who were unfairly were stuck in
the middle of a couple of weeks when it
was needed to pay some of them you've
written to me some of my constituents
are NHS workers who've had to pay
thousands of pounds that they cannot
afford
and for all those who are now so worried
about civil liberties on the other side
of the house I welcome there in also
engagement with the elections bill which
certainly will be a papers please
society when we're asked to show our ID
to even vote that is far more of an
infringement on our civil liberties such
a fundamental thing as voting than this
is to go to a club's or to large events
we absolutely need the schools program
to ramp up
schools transmission rates are very high
in my constituency in primary schools
but also for all those they do not those
facing exams this year they must
continue them this is not a slippery
slope to vaccine passports and I'm
grateful for the Assurance on that we do
need to ramp up communication and
engagement with health staff who face
face
measures later on in the year if they
don't get the vaccine and we must see an
increase in statutory sick pay it's only
fair I'll conclude Mr Deputy speaker the
chief medical officer gave a chilling
briefing to MPS earlier today saying
that when it comes to the Omicron
variant the breaks are off we have to
put the brakes on too many people have
died and we mourn every single one now
is the time to take action and I
encourage everyone to get their booster
jab thank you very much Dr Ben Spencer
Mr Deputy speaker and I'm going to speak
briefly to make sure that our fellow
colleagues can get in on this important
debate
um I'm going to go through the the four
measures and then come up with some big
questions I think that I we need to ask
about what we're doing and how things go
forwards um the first measure I want to
talk about is a self-isolation SI I'm
that makes quite a lot of sense and I
welcome the government for bringing in
this change and bringing in the daily
testing
um now on the vaccination of health
staff I will declare an interest I used
to work as a doctor my wife currently
still works as a doctor
um I really do have no issue uh with
this measure going forwards when I had
to go through medical school I had to be
vaccinated and I was flipping on its
head which is uh if my relative went
into hospital and caught covered or was
being treated by someone who was
unvaccinated and got covered and became
very poorly from that I would be very
concerned about that happening so I do
think this is uh fundamentally a basic
duty of care issue but I recognize there
are you know different views on that
um on face masks on the mandatory face
mask Provisions brought in I do struggle
with these measures a bit because this
along with the working from home
guidance is going to cause harms and
given the secretary's estate uh
Secretary of State's update today on the
Omicron wave that's going forward I do
wonder what actual impact uh this is
going to have and what the harm benefit
ratio accordingly looks like on this but
you know there we are but my real issue
is with the covert status certificates
now there's many reasons to be concerned
about covert status certificates but I'm
going to focus on one
as a doctor I've spent my career looking
after people who are marginalized people
will see their mental illness people
have learned disability they're
digitally excluded and looking at these
measures and explaining units today I
cannot see how one can show evidence of
a negative test without having access to
the internet without having a phone
without going through that or how any
validation process can go through and
it's very clear to me that this is going
to exclude people and I can't support
excluding anyone but especially those
people who are marginalized most
marginalized in our society yeah but my
big three questions are really what
comes next so I had a chat with uh the
the leaders of Ashford and Saint Peter's
Hospital trust the trust of my
constituency in terms of what's
happening and what's their plans are for
the next few weeks and they're telling
me that already because of the pivoting
towards vaccination by primary care
they're going to have to look at shuring
up a e because it's not going to be the
GP capacity and people are going to go
through a e and that may have a knock-on
effect in terms of them having to cancel
elective care so that Ania can be short
of now they don't want to cancel
elective care they're a great hospital
to us and they think they can get
through and they can still do some some
elective measures and one of the things
asked me to ask Minister today is can
they have flexibility in terms of what
they do around elective care and try and
keep that going as much as possible
but there will be a cost to this in
terms of misdupy appointments in terms
of miscreening
um we've already seen what the cost was
in this past year in terms of waiting
list Etc and I'd like to hear from the
minister what the plan is to recover NHS
as usual after we have got through this
wave because trust me a protected NHS is
not an NHS where GPS are going off to an
abandoning rooting care and focusing on
vaccination a protected NHS is where you
can get your blood pressure screening is
where you can have that conversation uh
about your your mood where Health
visitors see young families and can have
those very incorporent conversations
about does a woman feel safe with her
husband at home
my second question is what happens when
the next vaccine Escape variant comes
because I think we all feel that that's
inevitable after this wave we'll get
another one coming through so what's
going to be the plan to stop us having
to re-pivot like this again honesty the
long term living with covert strategy
and my third question which is really
more of a plea
is that the cost of this pandemic
have largely fallen on the shoulders of
our children yeah please please please
can the minister confirm that there are
no plans for mandatory restrictions on
schools and we will never close our
schools again
so the last speaker at five minutes is
Vera Paul person then goes to four
minutes era
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and maybe I
will even stick to the four minute limit
no doubt we are at the at a pivot pill
point in the fight against
like many across the country are doing
their best to keep covet levels lows low
in their communities and I really thank
everybody for their efforts getting
vaccinated is the most important thing
and I'm glad for the consensus that we
have in this place that that is the most
important thing what we are debating
here is how what is the most effective
way of getting the most people
vaccinated and I hope that this debate
is not distracting from the fact that we
all believe that vaccine is the best way
to reaching covert and we will beat
um all these sort of uh uh consider
conspiracy theories around vaccines and
indeed going as far that covet is an
invention it is important we are all
getting vaccinated there is a consensus
and I'm glad that consensus is here and
then of course mask wearing we on this
side of the house have always supported
that it is a way of reducing the risk of
course not entirely eliminating it but
wearing masks is very important and
indeed we have been deployed that it
that requirement which isn't difficult
has been dropped uh including in this
house
it is not about just keeping ourselves
safe it is not just even about keeping
our loved ones safe it is about keeping
everybody safe yes we have and enjoy our
civil liberties we should protect them
but Liberty doesn't mean the harm the
Liberty to harm others and that is a
very important principle and that is why
we are protecting and public safety
measures
now many of my constituencies have been
in touch with me to share their concerns
about the logistical difficulties of
following government advice I want to do
the right thing but often they find it
difficult one of my constituents who I
met last week had recently returned from
Zambia where he where his work is based
as a red list country my constituent was
required to quarantine in a hotel for 10
days my constituent tried continually to
book a quarantine hotel but was not able
to do so because it was fully booked
when he was finally able to book a hotel
he received an email from ctm saying
that this booking had been canceled due
to an error on their part but upon
speaking to their call centers the
members have told them there was no
problem I know that the rest Red List
system has now been dropped but the
stress and cost to people who tried to
do things has been considerable and
needs to be addressed urgently is there
going to be compensation for those who
have actually
faced considerable costs and also um as
has been asked before those who are
still in quarantine will that be
released immediately
another of my constituents is housebound
her son lives in Southampton and has
multiple health conditions make it
impossible for her to get a vaccination
Center to a vaccination Center on her
own meaning she has not yet had a
booster her story is All Too common the
local ccg has said that they are in the
process of contacting people who are
housebound but many are still waiting to
be contacted and con and obviously they
are very worried and I hope the minister
will be able to outline the steps that
are being taken to ensure those who are
housebound are able to receive their
boosters as a priority
lastly another constituents was
vaccinated abroad yet is still unable to
receive confirmation of his double
vaccinated status because his vaccines
are not recognized on the NHS NHS up a
problem that has been recognized since
the summer to make matters worse my
constituent and many others like him is
not able to get his booster because the
system will not recognize him as having
been doubly vaccinated so the government
must address these issues as a matter of
urgency it should not be this difficult
for those who are trying to do the right
thing to follow government's own
guideline my constituents and many
across the country want to do the right
thing but the government must do its bid
or people will lose further confidence
on uh already at this time which is very
highly volatile and where we need as
many people as possible to have
confidence in the system and the
government thank you thank you very much
four minute limit Jane Stevenson thank
you Mr Deputy speaker I'm very grateful
for the chance to speak in this debate
and I want to start by saying I
absolutely support the government's aim
of buying us a bit more time to increase
the booster take up and give us all more
protection and nothing I'm about to say
makes light of covered in any way at all
but I the issue I have with these
regulations is in terms of language and
how we bring people together to get the
most compliance
and I think Omicron it certainly isn't
the last variant we have to deal with
and in my constituency there are
significant number of people who have
grave concerns about civil liberties
about data harvesting about all of these
things while I think their fears are
unfounded I have to listen to them and I
think we in this place have to take
their concerns seriously as The
Honorable lady for Brighton Pavilion
said we don't allay those fears of
over-regulation by passing more
regulation and we need these people to
come on board in a national effort to
keep each other safe
so I believe we need a change of
language from telling people mandating
measures to asking people to comply
we already do trust our constituents we
trust them to take the tests correctly
we trust them to give us a correct
um reading of their test there is
nothing stopping them from declaring a
negative test when they've tested
positive there's nothing to stop them
not take the test at all but just to
scan the code and I think compliance
could be increased if they can trust
that they're not facing these
restrictions for no reason they're not
having their data harvested it is a very
major concern in my constituency and I
do respect it the vast majority of my
constituents and the vast majority of
the British people will do everything
asked of them by government without it
needing to be mandated they have been
incredible throughout this pandemic they
have acted in the interests of
themselves their families their
communities their cities and towns and I
would humbly ask the government to get
back to our conservative principles of
trusting the British people they are the
people who sent us to this place they
have common sense they know their risk
they can you know act with Supreme
intelligence we must never underestimate
their community-mindedness so I in our
last plea to the government that is my
only comment on this evening's votes
I won't be supporting all of them but I
will support some of them but it is a
plea in order to go forward together as
a nation we have to stop passing
never-ending regulations and move
forward in a voluntary Community public
Spirited Away yeah like shellbrook
yeah thank you um Mr Deputy speaker
pledge to follow him from my honorable
friend
um Mr Deputy speaker as
um my honorable friend from Bexley and
battle said earlier on
our hospitals are our Intensive Care
Unit beds are being filled up by people
who are unvaccinated this is a real
problem in um Leeds and the hospitals in
Leeds and this actually is having a huge
impact
um on people who want to get vaccinated
they want their lives to move forward
they want to be able to continue to do
the things that we'll want to do and the
reality is my honorable friend the
health secretary said at the time is
that there could come the point where
there just may not be the ability to
have that operation you may be it may
not be a bit available I've spoken to
surgeons who are in the theater and
trained highly skilled searching they've
got the theater available they've got
the theater nurses available the
operation was canceled they haven't got
a beg to put them in and they cannot do
that operation what we've got before us
today
set of really unfortunate measures I
don't sit comfortably with me I don't
like what things we're doing but they
are balanced for this moment in time I
don't believe that they are vaccine
passports as have been described in the
countless round robin emails I've had
it's been made clear from the dispatch
box that they're not vaccine possible
they are at a moment in time in a very
specific area
what I do think we need to look at and
moving forward if this is the way that
perhaps we have to say you've got to
everybody have a lateral flow test
before going into an area where there
may be the chance of spreading the virus
because that is how we've got to try and
protect Society it is people's right to
not get vaccinated and I am totally
opposed to monetary vaccines it's their
right not to get vaccinated but it is my
right and the right of a great many of
my constituents to be able to expect to
be able to receive the services that
they have paid him for and they have
used when where they may need them and
that is what is overwhelming things at
the moment and this Mr Speaker Deputy
speaker is going to lead to a simple
choice and a debate is going to be had
some point we are going to have to work
out
how are we going to make our
Intensive Care Unit beds free up again
how are we going to do that are we going
to say that you're going to have to take
the actual flow tests to make sure when
you mix the environment everybody's got
it if we don't want to do vaccine
passports and I don't believe that
actually a vaccine pass will overall
would work
because it may be you've got a partner
who doesn't want to get vaccinated and
they can't go to the event and you can
but because you've got a vaccine
certificate you don't have to test and
you get it and you go home you give it
to them and they end up intensive care
so that's not really going to work
lateral flow tests work
um
I don't believe what's on the table
today is a vaccine passport I've got to
say and that's why I I don't like it but
I will be supporting the package of
measures today but there is a
fundamental question which is going to
stir up a really hard debate in this
country
do we demand everybody has electoral
flow test before they go in everywhere
do we find strains which may not cause a
lot of disease and let them spread to
try and defeat the virus
or do we have to take the Singapore
model and say on your head be it if you
need the hospital treatment and there
will be Financial consequences to that
one of those three things is what's
going to have to happen in the long run
as we stand here today we've got a
really unfortunate set of measures but
I'm backing them today because the most
sacrosanct thing to me at the moment Mr
Speaker Deputy speaker especially after
last year we have got to protect this
Christmas season people have got to be
able to have it and that makes a few
sacrifices now I think that's a prize
worth paying yeah Dr Luke Evans thank
you Mr Deputy speaker and can I applaud
the government on the massive scale up
and huge ambition when it comes to the
booster program this truly is the way
forward for our nation and I commend the
government for taking forward this
approach now critics will argue the
target's set by the end of the month uh
will it be reached will it not
um don't listen to them they're myopic
political Point scoring will be
forgotten in the light of the fact
government is doing everything it can to
get Jabs into our bombs because that's
the way out but I accept there need to
be some measures and I want to talk to
them now so mandating of face coverings
and change in isolation Mr Speaker the
government will have my support on these
measures while masks are of course
inconvenient it's a relatively easy way
to reduce the risk of covid but also
other viruses such as flu let's not
forget this causes a huge amount of
pressure on the NHS with admission so a
reduction in both
as evidenced makes sense to me
now those who argue the Nuance of
settings for face masks often miss the
point I've heard a number of times both
in this chamber and in the public well
how does the virus know if it's in a
restaurant or if it's in a shop of
course it doesn't know that but that's
not the point the point is what is the
easiest measures that when applied to
the population as a whole will reduce
the risk as best as possible and the
government has to balance this at Mass
levels so what can be implemented to
reduce the risk of covid while
mitigating the instant economic and
non-coveted damage that could occur in
vulnerable sectors like hospitality
so a change in self-isolation speaks to
this I think it's difficult but a fair
balance
now turning to mandatory vaccination for
the NHS Mr speaker I spoke on the 13th
of July
um this year to the house when we
debated this and I'm not going to rehash
the entire argument I urge someone to
people to look at my contribution if
they want to see
but the argument still stands to me as
it did then it was put forward on the
duty of care for those in positions of
responsibility to the most vulnerable
that stands even more starkly today
one knowingly undertakes this commitment
in their decision to pursue this career
and the precedent already exists
but while I am speaking on this topic
this must not be used for a slippery
slope argument for mandatory covert
vaccination for the general population
and I was glad to hear the health
secretary confirm that won't be the case
because I do not believe that this house
or indeed most of the UK population
would accept this
but on the topic of slippery slopes this
leads me on to the final regulation that
a lateral flow test and the covert part
exemptions to certain venues I'm against
vaccine passports I don't believe they
are practical moral ethical or indeed
evidence-based in a scientific rationale
the closest comparison we have is
Scotland and there's 70 page report does
not provide the evidence for passes to
introduce such a huge change in our
Health Management of our nation requires
a full and thorough debate and I don't
believe it'll be done Justice tonight I
am so pleased the government has
listened and added lateral flow testing
as an alternative because at least this
provides a choice
but I can't support covid passes I worry
about the slippery slope what businesses
what Society interactions or what
infections may become in scope in future
months or future years
in closing
looking to the future I said in the
house on the 6th of June 2021 what is
most needed is a full debate on the risk
we as Society are prepared to tolerate
when it comes to covid for those
vaccinated those unvaccinated who will
never get vaccinated and the trade-off
between covert and non-covered health
implications Health protection measures
and the trade against our economy
society and Liberty I hope the house
will bring a debate next month yeah
and some
Mr Deputy speaker
our covid measures have and continue to
hurt our citizens from a man with late
stage dementia who is terrified of face
masks to an 80 year old constituent who
got stuck in South Africa not because of
Omicron but because flights were
suspended
and now the news that non-urgent Primary
Care will be diverted once again with
the huge risk of harm to babies and
young children if face-to-face support
is unavailable for long periods of time
once again
and the creeping regulation is so hard
to keep up with resulting in teachers
canceling school plays businesses
stopping events and families staying
away from Happy occasions because
they're afraid of breaking a rule they
didn't know about
surely the campaign against kovid should
now focus on two key fronts more
boosters and more education
the action by government on boosters is
fantastic but instead of criminalizing
people why don't we start a hard-hitting
public health campaign if you're going
out this Christmas don't forget to take
a test or if you're seeing your granny
make sure you get a jab let's persuade
people rather than criminalize them
and let's go much further to reassure
those who have a fear of vaccines
whether because of a needle phobia
because of cultural sensitivities or
just because of fake news
and my specific concern about testing
requirements for big events is the sheer
challenge of enforceability in a
commercial setting
far better in my view would be to use
this approach of a daily test or a
vaccine exemption for NHS staff and
carers instead that would be a practical
and fair solution for both carers and
the cared for and it would be
enforceable
it would also avoid the risk of losing
NHS and care workers who are unwilling
to accept compulsory vaccinations
Mr Deputy speaker I have supported the
government throughout the pandemic when
I could see the present danger we faced
but this time around the measures
proposed are precautionary just in case
and I cannot see where this will end
covid will be with us for many years to
come and it's Unthinkable that every
Autumn from now on we will be limiting
the quality of life for all citizens
just to be on the safe side and
justifying our new illiberal rules on
the basis that they're less
authoritarian than those of other
countries is truly appalling that is not
our culture that is not our history
so Mr Deputy speaker this is a slippery
slope down which I do not want to slip
so I'm afraid I'm not going to be
supporting these measures
Greg Clark
Deputy speaker it's a pleasure to follow
my right honorable friend and I think
everyone acknowledges that the
government have a difficult uh task here
in some ways the the regulations that we
have before us whilst it's important
that we debate are not the most damaging
ones in fact the advice that the
government has given to work from home
has consequences that are much more
significant than any of the relatively
minor measures and unlike these
regulations they don't have an expiry
date they don't have an impact
assessment even though we know that the
impact on firms across the country and
for example the experience of young
people at work once again for those
firms who perhaps are conscious of what
their insurers and what their Regulators
might require are confining people to
their homes that is very significant and
it is a shame that the house doesn't
have chance to vote on those measures
but on the measures that we
uh it's it seems to me that there is a a
lack of clarity as to what the the
purpose of the access certificate so I
can call him uh call them that uh is is
it to prompt people to get a vaccine uh
is it to uh to give them a nudge and
have those people who haven't surveilled
themselves of a vaccine uh a further
incentive to do so
if so what is the evidence for that
working we know that 90 of the
population are vaccinated what motivates
that remaining 10 is it the case that
the desire to attend a football match uh
or a nightclub is going to cause them to
take the vaccine up if it is then this
might be a good measure but to
inconvenience that 90 of people who are
vaccinated
when we have no evidence of that we
don't know and what are the Alternatives
it could be that if we really do want to
have these remaining people take up the
vaccine or some of them rather than
requiring a pass at the entrance to a
nightclub or a football ground to have a
vaccine Center at the uh the turnstile
or at the Gate of a nightclub the door
of a nightclub uh may be for those that
have been too disorganized to arrange
their vaccine that might be better we
don't know this we have reached for uh
compulsion and as other colleagues have
said
um it can't be the case that it is just
about obtaining a vaccine because
otherwise having a negative lateral flow
test would not be available if it were
just to to nudge people and there's a
certain logic to requiring 100 of people
entering a venue to have a negative test
but as we know and as has been reported
especially if you've just got two that
jazz then it is perfectly possible for
you to transmit covet so I think there
is an ambiguity as to the purpose of
these measures that we are bringing in
and given that the consequences for
business owners and venue operators if
they fail to get right some very complex
regulations is a fine of ten thousand
pounds a huge amount of money for for
small business operators we shouldn't
tread lightly with this I wonder whether
the the minister might be able to say
possibly an intervention uh answer a
question that came up in this debate
which is whether the the lateral flow
test is to be self-administered or
whether they will be at some cost be
sent somewhere else to a a third party
to uh to administer I wonder whether the
minister might be able to clarify that
point
perhaps later perhaps he'll uh he'll do
it in his Wonder Mr Deputy speaker it is
clear that whatever the difficulty is I
think there are flaws in this approach
that I hope the minister will be able to
provide some reassurance on uh when he
wants it
protect our communities
I support like most of us evidence-based
policy making and in the absence of data
precautions not restrictions now I'll be
voting in the government today on
precautions face masks it's about
personal responsibility in a small step
we can take to protect our communities
the NHS mandate we need to keep our
health Force safe and not put those who
are most vulnerable who they care for at
risk testing over 10 day isolation
absolutely testing is the most important
thing we can do I support that boosters
absolutely need to get everyone boosted
but vaccine passports is where I find
difficulty and they come in three main
areas
the first there is no evidence that
passports reduce transmission
France Scotland yes we've seen some
increase in the uptake of the vaccine
but we see no reduction in transmission
as a result
secondly we're saying at the moment that
two Jabs are not enough
well then if you need a booster and
that's so important why is the vaccine
passport based on two Jabs there is a
contradiction there
and I do not believe that these covert
passports will prevent lockdown and I
question the mechanics of them like my
colleague who just spoke a negative test
you are self-declaring you've had a
negative test you are self asking for
someone to give you that declaration
with no evidence that you've had a
negative test and then somehow there's
meant to be some kind of uploaded
capacity the bureaucratic mechanics
required for passports to work are not
there
um sorry the bureaucratic mechanisms
required for negative tests are not
there they will come at Great cost to us
and I do not believe that we have the
capacity to deliver the negative test
aspect of the passport regime
secondly modeling of the severity of
Omicron dstl has not even reported yet
so how can we be asked to decide on
these measures today without the data in
South Africa we're not seeing the
experienced death spikes the expected
death spikes hospitalization sits around
38 for every 1000 compared to 101 per
1000 for Delta modeling on Delta cannot
be right because we know this variant is
not the same
there are currently 10 people in
hospital with Omicron but are they in
hospital because they have Omicron or
with Omicron these are answers we just
don't know and frankly vomicron is that
severe we need more than the plan B
measures being proposed today
my third reason for voting against Kobe
passports today is the fundamental
unease they give me we do not
discriminate on a medical basis in this
country and we cannot secondly we are
encouraging people to work from home but
Pub tricks or parties are permitted when
we know from the previous uh lockdowns
that it was home mixing where the
problem was we have very high
vaccination rates we do not need these
passports 96 of people in Rutland and
Melton have both their jobs 93 sorry 96
have had their first 93 of Rotten
Tomatoes about their second 47 people
percent of people have had their
boosters they deserve to be thanked and
recognized and my constituents do not
deserve to have to have passports put
upon them when they are taking up the
vaccine like this and on this part I'd
just like to thank those amazing
vaccinators across rotten to Melton
particularly the Melton lines and the
Rutland lions
finally my final two concerns are that
we constantly changing the rules
businesses cannot keep up this is not
the certainty they ask for and school
closures since we announced the measures
and plan B there are schools across the
country talking about closing that is
not acceptable our children must be in
school to learn our children must be in
school to be protected and our children
deserve more we cannot have people going
out to parties and pubs but children not
in school and the government must
mandate for schools to remain open not
just say that that is guidance
my final plea is for help because in
Melton we do not have enough clinics for
vaccinations and this has been an issue
for months and so I plead for the
minister to please make sure we get more
booster clinics in Melton and finally my
pleas get vaccinated get it and you need
to get other people in Aaron Bell
thank you very much Deputy speaker it's
a pleasure to follow my honorable friend
it's been a good debate I think it's a
necessary debate that we've had the
debate there's strong views expressed on
all sides and I think those reflect the
views that a lot of us have heard from
the country and in our inboxes for me I
believe in a proportionate response to a
Perpetual threat of the public health
emergency and the precautionary
principle applies here so I will be
supporting the government today I think
given what I've heard about the
transmissibility of Omicron this is only
going to be for a limited period of time
one way or the other because this is
very transmissible and we don't quite
know yet how severe it is
that that the response of the government
has taken has to be balanced by the
needs of the economy as many as others
have said and we must be particularly
mindful of the effect on the hospitality
industry particularly at this time of
year but it's not these measures that
are affecting the hospitality industry
um in fact some of these measures will
support the hospitality industry by
giving people confidence it's the virus
that's affecting the hospitality
industry and sometimes I get the sense
here that some colleagues and certainly
some people who write to me are arguing
with the virus they're not arguing with
the government they're arguing with the
virus well I think it's common cause
across the house that we all don't like
the virus but the unfortunately the
virus doesn't care about that and it
will keep on doubling Madam Deputy
speaker and that brings us to the data
I'm grateful to all the witnesses we
heard this morning at the Science and
Technology committee ably chaired by my
honorable friend but clearly we don't
have enough data yet particularly UK
data as my colleague from my right
honorable friend from The Forest of Dean
said earlier on case fatality rates we
heard that it's perhaps 29 milder than
the original strain that's from the
South African data and in terms of
length of I have hospitals my honorable
friend I mentioned earlier on Omicron
stays or maybe half the length the
regular stays but both of those
unfortunately are linear variables and
they are not rate the thing where
Omicron truly is out competing the other
variants is an exponential variable and
that means until it runs out of targets
it's going to keep doubling we've had
200 000 infections uh yesterday and that
will be four hundred thousand two or
three days and possibly eight hundred
thousand in a week's time and we must
fool ourselves that we know how we can
balance that exponential growth with the
other two linear measures we've told
we've found out about we have to take a
precautionary but balanced approach in
the meantime in terms of the slippery
slope arguments made by my honorable
friends here and those who say it's the
thin end of the wedge I do have sympathy
with that argument I really do and I
share a view of many colleagues that the
house must have their say over the next
two weeks if we are to take further
steps along that slope or to the thicker
part of the wedge but I would not vote
for the thickest part of the wedge I
would never vote for mandatory
vaccinations of the general public and I
welcome the assurance as we've heard
from dispatch box today but that's not
the question before us today Madam
Deputy speaker we should all vote for or
against these measures based on the
content of those measures and our own
personal beliefs in those measures and
on the so-called vaccine passports I
don't believe they're anything of the
salt with lateral flow tests and recent
vaccinate recent experience of covert as
Alternatives I don't think they they
should be described as vaccine passports
they should be described as a covid
party and I welcome the Assurance again
from the dispatch box that lateral flow
test will remain part of that in the
future and I will be holding the
government to that to finally come to
the point about rights and
responsibilities as Citizens that might
or honorable friend from Bexley and
battle mates so eloquently earlier
um the four million people who've chosen
not to be vaccinated so far some of them
may be disorganized but there are
undoubtedly many out there who have
chosen not to do so and I say to all of
them that I will stand up for your
freedom and for your right not to be
vaccinated but you cannot imagine that
there can be no consequences to that
choice one once that starts impacting on
the freedoms and rights of others and
therefore I I think some of the measures
that my honorable friend from helmet and
Robin made may have to be considered in
the future if we genuinely get the
severe exponential growth of Omicron and
finally in my last 10 seconds Madam
Deputy speaker I commend the government
for what they've done on boosters and
I'd urge everyone to go out and get
their booster as soon as possible that's
the way out of this Rick Smith
thank you uh Madam Deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to follow my honorable friend
for Newcastle underline and he's
absolutely right in the way he concluded
that speech that boosters are the answer
to this boosters and the vaccine program
at large give us hope
and give us a path out of covid and back
to normal life
I very much congratulate the government
on stepping up that booster program and
aiming to get those Jabs into people's
arms by the end of the year
very much needs a lot of focus and
attention and planning on the detail and
on the logistics to make that happen to
my own experience yesterday of trying to
bring my own booster which is booked for
the 31st of December forward where I
jump from Seventh house in the queue to
three thousand then curiously to ten
thousand before eventually uh coming
down and being offered a date in
mid-January there is clearly a lot of
work to be done to ensure that we can
get those boosters into people's arms
can I also welcome the government's move
to get rid of the 10-day isolation
period for anyone that happens to have
come near someone that has tested
positive for Omicron and replace that
with daily testing that is a sensible uh
measure and like my right humble friend
for The Forest of Dean I feel Vindicated
in my vote against that measure two
weeks ago
but can I
set out why I won't be voting uh for the
extended mask mandate I won't be voting
for the covid passes and I won't be
voting for mandatory vaccination within
the National Health Service I very much
agree with my writable friend and
constituency neighbor from South
northamptonshire who made the point that
this is a slippery slope this is going
to change the way we operate as a
country not just in December 2021 but
going forward whenever another variant
emerges maybe not of covid but a another
virus it is a fundamental change in the
relationship between Citizen and state
and one to be resisted
I have argued throughout this pandemic
at times when I then reluctantly voted
with the government as last Christmas
and other times such as a couple of
weeks ago when I voted against extending
measures
that all restrictions are not without
harm in themselves even on masks it
might be an easy thing for many of us to
do to put one on but as others have
mentioned to the dementia patient
petrified at the Mast figure approaching
them to the child with autism
to the person who is hard of hearing or
deaf you cannot read our lips actually
does have consequences it does bring
harm and likewise to mental health I've
been scared at reports in my
constituency
of the rise in mental health challenges
particularly amongst our young people
the rise in self-harm in our secondary
schools that is not something we can
stand idly by and just ignore and of
course the damage to our economy
we may not have shut Hospitality down or
proposing to shut Hospitality down but
I'm already hearing from pubs right
across my constituency losing 20 30 40
some cases 50 percent of their Christmas
bookings
people are too scared to go out now and
that is a direct correlation to what I'm
afraid to say the government is saying
and betraying this virus to be and I
took a lot of heart
from the news coming out of South Africa
this morning
that showed that in fact they are
finding it to be a more mild variant and
that the vaccines do work and so I come
back to where I started let's focus on
the boosters and otherwise give people
their freedom back to choose
Derek Thomas
I want to know I want to believe that
these new restrictions are motivated by
the care and compassion that scientists
and Senior government ministers have for
British public and support the NHS I
heard this Secretary of State say these
measures keep people safe and protect
our liberties however I'm worried
because the same care and compassion and
support of the NHS does not seem to
extend to other severe difficulties our
constituents face largely because of the
actions of government to impose
restrictions to fight covid I'd like to
say how these are not how these
individuals are not safe and how their
lives have been curtailed for example
for cancer diagnosis and care we are
throwing away everything we are throwing
everything we have at covert and the
booster program how many more cancer
patients will miss their diagnosis and
treatment and lose their lives because
we told them to protect the NHS surely
now is the time to reopen our
Nightingale hospitals to do with Omicron
and protect the NHS to care for our
constituents who've had severe
life-changing or life-limiting illnesses
for learning disabilities who's checking
on the impact of these measures and The
Wider context of covid on people who
have learning disabilities when will we
wake up to realize that these people are
effectively locked up safe from covid
but living a miserable existence without
their usual social network and normal
activity
scared witness is the word the
expression the member for The Forest of
Dean used and he's absolutely right and
what about mental health and anxieties
has just been said why do we feel that
our robust response to covid justifies
yet again plunging or maintaining
massive numbers of people in anxiety and
mental health and school disruption how
is it that for years we have made
missing school an offense but we have
quite literally deprived children from a
structured learning environment already
with this new renewed enthusiasm by
government and the opposition we see
schools closing early and our children
and families lives disrupted I accept
that the measures we have we are asked
to vote on today do not in themselves
trigger these problems however the
briefings and the fear that is
encouraged to justify these measures
does not acknowledge a very real and
horrible lived experience for people in
each of our constituencies
constituencies
we seem to have a Whole Health
Department that is consumed with covid
and has seemingly abandoned abandoned
all other responsibilities such as
mental health cancer diabetes social
care loneliness and isolation a health
department that is prepared to sack
staff in the NHS who care for these very
patients I doubt that this new variant
is a lost are we to expect this level of
reaction with every covert threat
indefinitely if not maybe now is the
time to change our approach and have a
fresh conversation about how we want to
combat pandemics such as covid across
across the British Isles in 22 and
Beyond and on that note Madame Dex
speaker I'll be voting in support of the
booster jobs and in support of the
testing but against the other measures
proposed today
in order to accommodate everybody I'm
going to reduce the time limit to three
minutes and I have been able to warn the
next speaker of that Gareth bacon
thank you madam Deputy speaker it has
been a good debate but it is a
profoundly frustrating and depressing
experience to be having to have this
debate at all just a few short weeks ago
of course we thought that we were almost
out of the woods and now we are
threatened with a return of a terrible
uncertainty now given the the time
restriction I'm going to have to go
through this at PACE in terms of the
proposals before us the extension of
face coverings we've been there before I
don't like face coverings but as a
precautionary measure while we find out
more about this new strain of the virus
I can see the argument for them so I
will not oppose them
on mandatory vaccination for care
workers for NHS workers rather this has
been debated before and it's about a
duty of care owed to the vulnerable
people in the care of the NHS
it's an extension of an existing
principle practicing doctors have told
me they are already required to be
inoculated against chickenpox rubella
measles and hepatitis B
there are also exemptions in this
particular statutory instrument for
people who work in the NHS but have no
face-to-face contact with patients so
again I will be supporting this measure
on self-isolation I think it's
self-explanatory why that is a
proportionate response and I will again
support it now on the case of Entry to
venues and events for me this is the the
real elephant in the room this is the
one that gave me the most pause for
thought
now we already have to show our vaccine
status when we travel overseas but that
is our choice and it is marginally
inconvenient but with uh appropriate
prior preparation it's not any more than
that however the application of that
approach to moving around domestically
is in all together different thing
as originally conceived when Plan B was
drafted it would seem to be a
requirement that you would have to show
your vaccine status to get into anything
whether it be a bar a restaurant a cafe
or whatever very much indeed as what
exists in Mainland Europe at the moment
that for me would been a step too far
and I would not have supported it but
the government have made I think a major
concession not only have they changed
the venues and and limited the number of
venues you would have to use it to
access they've also allowed the
provision of a lateral flow test instead
that avoids the deeply divisive nature
of having to show your vaccine status
and on that basis I feel that I will be
able to support that now the government
measures will not be allowed to be
simply rolled over uh interminably if
the government wants to extend them
they'll have to bring it back to this
house in January for approval and that
is something else that I do approve of
Madam Deputy speaker we don't yet know
the severity of the Omicron variant but
we do know that it is spreading rapidly
these measures won't stop Omicron from
spreading spreading but they're not
designed to they are designed to slow
that spread
the government need to use this time
Madame Dr speaker to obtain solid data
deepen our understanding on the risks
posed by Omicron and in the meantime
Madam Deputy speaker I will support
these measures and encourage everybody
to get their booster
and it's all about slowing transmission
and about reducing Demand on our limited
NHS capacity so there are two ends to
this telescope it is firstly about
prevention making sure people don't get
covered and secondly to make sure the
capacity is there if they do get covered
to cure not just them but people other
patients who have non-covered related
illnesses
now these regulations Madam Deputy
speaker are very focused on the
prevention end of this telescope clearly
vaccination uptake is crucial and the
government is to be commended but this
has to be a matter of choice given time
others contributions the point has been
well explained already
mask wearing and covered passports I
believe have not been subject to the
rigor of proper assessment there hasn't
been a proper analysis here and I have a
real fear that they will do more harm
than good to society taken as a whole
they generate fear in those that least
need to be fearful that increase mental
health problems they reduce non-covered
Admissions and treatments but Madam
Deputy speaker my real concern is the
government does not focused sufficiently
on the other end of the telescope we
have not looked adequately at what we do
about the adequacy of our resource
despite promises and numbers of new
doctors and nurses coming forward even
the government has admitted that will
not be enough to fill the huge vacancies
that we have
if we can reduce vaccine development
from 10 years to 100 days surely the
goodness we must be able to find a way
of laser-like reviewing of a patient
journey to make a better and more
efficient use of the limited resources
we have and indeed to increase them I
call on the government Before Christmas
to put in place an emergency resilience
task force this needs to focus
laser-like on the capacity issue which
has not been fully addressed indeed
frankly hardly at all we can work smart
there are very good brains within our
Health Service look at what Sarah doesi
has done in the accelerated access
collaborative new drugs Foster patients
in a way never seen before and what
about our own Kate Bingham the vaccines
are look what she's done to do what was
supposedly impossible and when this task
force is created and it must be before
Christmas and it should be asked to
report by the end of January it must
look up better use of Emergency Services
you use firearm police better it must
look proper triaging of any arrivals
better use of medical professionals we
are using the wrong people to do the
wrong jobs expedite training look at
whether or not some of our training is
too long and use The Nightingales and
other resources to deal with non-coded
backlogs and convalescing dealing with
the healthcare problem a Madam Deputy
speaker testing if we can't have uh
covered passports must be the right way
forward in Social care and health
uh we will get everybody in as long as
there aren't people don't take
interventions or if they do they still
stick to three minutes Nick Fletcher
speaker I want to speak directly to all
the points raised very quickly
being able to take a test and sort of
self-isolation I think that's a positive
move forward and mass nobody likes
wearing them most people can see the
benefits of them so I'm okay with that
NHS Frontline staff after careful
consideration in my opinion should have
the vaccine they have a duty to do no
harm and while we know the virus can
still spread the chances are reduced
again having spoken with local health
professionals there is some
understandable concern from NHS
employees who are pregnant so I would
ask that these members of staff are
given the Assurance they need from the
Secretary of State and the chief medical
officer that this vaccine is safe at
whatever stage there are at their
pregnancy
with regards to the concern over many
health professionals leaving the
profession and have been assured that
this would not be the case at least in
Doncaster as most of the Frontline
workers have seen the devastating effect
of covid and have gotten the vaccination
I know many colleagues on these benches
are struggling with vaccine passports
and I do understand their concerns but
this is not a vaccine passport it is
covered status certification it allows
negative lateral flow tests or proof of
vaccination it is only for venules that
carry high-risk and I personally think
it will be selfish for anyone not to
take a test before going to a large
event anyway
I know many people complain about long
cures when boarding a plane but who
would want to get on a plane where there
was no security I feel this is the same
and it's not as though people have not
had the vaccine are just putting
themselves at risk the people are not
vaccinated and require
hospitalization when they become ill
with covet are blocking beds and causing
huge backlogs on elective care
two-thirds of patients in the ri with
covid are unvaccinated and that's just
not fair on the person who's been
waiting for that hip operation for 18
months or any other elective procedure
preparing oneself a major surgery only
for it to be canceled because another
bed has been taken by someone who is
unvaccinated it's hugely frustrating so
I will be voting with the government
today but I ask that they don't take my
vote for granted and that if we see no
real increase in hospitalization then
this legislation does expire on the 26th
of January and that the government does
not seek to extend it
they're working from home although not
being voted on today is only guidance
but it will cause much disruption to
small retail and so I hope the
government will keep a close eye on that
and finally I asked my constituents to
understand that I'm voting on these
measures today not because I have been
with to do so but after careful
consideration and speaking to many local
professionals I believe this is the
right thing to do
Anthony Magnolia thank you madam Deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to follow
follow the honorable gentleman I thank
him for his reassurance that the whips
haven't pushed him in that direction
listen I think the government has done
an extraordinary job over the course of
the last two years I think it has been
an extraordinary achievement to roll out
the vaccinations as quickly as we have
and I think it is an extraordinary
achievement that we have also been able
to produce a booster program in the way
that we have there is a remarkable book
if I may suggest Madam deputies speaker
by Adam grant called think again and I
think that title is perhaps quite
opposite for the government right now in
which it talks about how we persuade
people to take vaccinations and uptakes
and the two case studies it gives are
Canada and Germany in which we don't
mandatory require people to get
vaccinated or push them in that
direction but we find ways in which we
can persuade them we would do well to
follow the guidance that can be found in
that book I'm going to be voting against
the masks in 1400 and I'm going to be
supporting the self-isolation point on
1415. in relation to the masks I'm
afraid the legislation is shoddy it's
been ill thought through as I said the
other day if we can sing with a
colleague eat with a colleague drink
with a colleague but not have to go to
work with them and yet master reduced in
those settings it seems somewhat ill
thought through government and
legislation has a responsibility to be
good and comprehensive this is not what
it's doing when it comes to vaccine
passports I will not support them as has
already been said by countless
colleagues in this house there is little
evidence to show that they work and I'm
sorry the SMP aren't here because the
70-page report produced by Nicholas
sturgeon also adds to that point and as
was made earlier the very important
point about the lack of enforceability
on it now that we have the lateral flow
test because of this slightly dodgy deal
that has been done with the opposition
to get their support the course for
abuse and observocation on that is far
too great and when it comes to mandatory
vaccinations I cannot and will not
support the problem I have with this is
that the government has yet to release
the data of how many people have left
Care Homes since we introduced that
policy we need to have a data to be able
to review that because if sixty thousand
if twenty thousand if thirty thousand
people in the NHS decide to walk out how
on Earth are we going to be able to have
that have the capacity to help support
those um who get infected we need more
information before we make those
decisions
um the last two weeks the Ghost of
Christmas Past has appeared and he
brings with him fear and uncertainty we
cannot continue to flip and flop and
change attack nor should we be cherry
picking information from South Africa to
support the government's agenda I
appreciate the evidence coming out this
morning shows that actually two fisa
vaccinations do well and that actually
it's a milder milder virus but we cannot
continue to terrify people I am
staggered by the government's approach
after over the last two weeks in which
we have used fear to persuade people I
believe that no government should ever
use fear as a tool to try and persuade
its citizens and that is what's happened
build up our resilience Madam Deputy
speaker and reduce our restrictions
let's move quickly on Richard Graham
Deputy speaker's patient follow the
member for totnes although I won't allow
us agree with every word that he has
said let me start by celebrating some of
the things that I think we can all agree
on the end of the red list for all 11
countries the extension of the travel
passes for all teenagers and I think
many of us can agree that we need to
release from quarantine immediately
those who are still in quarantine in our
country having come from those red
countries now today we vote on four
specific measures which amount to
firstly a modest increase in mask
wearing which really can only be opposed
by those who strongly oppose it on
principle we also have an end to the
pandemic self-isolation in favor of a
lateral flow test which surely everybody
can agree is a step forward
thirdly we then vote on having mandatory
vaccination for NHS workers which the
NHS itself supports and lastly comes the
issue for debate which is I would say a
modest requirement for a lateral flow
test to go to venues with more than 500
indoors and 4 000 outdoors in my
constituency in Gloucester that amounts
to Gloucester rugby Gloucester Cathedral
and the attic nightclub and I believe
that all of those will be quite capable
of administrating things effectively so
what is it that the Libertarians led by
the Eternal Cavalier the right honorable
member for New Forest West most object
to and I believe Madame Deputy speaker
that they object in principle to new
rules being introduced and struggle
slightly with the specifics of what is
wrong with the proposals brought forward
this evening for there is no vaccine
passport let us be clear nor is this
Nazi Germany an only conceivable Shake
nor is there scaremongering for
everybody except that the Omicron
variant rate of infection is moving fast
and we cannot be sure how many with
Omicron will need to be hospitalized and
therefore we cannot wait to do something
until the Gloucester oil and other
hospitals are overflowing with people
with covid and therefore critical cancer
operations are canceled I do not believe
that any member would want to face the
family of someone lost because a cancer
operation had to be canceled as a result
of the hospital being clogged up with
Omicron variant covid sufferers so is
everything perfect no I have three
suggestions to the minister and the
Departments involved this evening
firstly they need to reassure us on the
provision of lateral flow tests we must
have them otherwise people will not be
able to get them and fulfill the
requirements of these rules secondly we
need to look again at the wording on the
advisory recommendation that people
should work from home if you can I
believe this should be work from home if
you wish thirdly and most importantly
the impact assessment makes it clear
that the central estimate is of 73 000
NHS workers out of 1.8 million not
wanting to be vaccinated Madame Deputy
speaker we need to do more about that
Richard Drex
speaker let me start by sympathizing
with the Prime Minister and the front
bench these are not easy matters and
decisions to restrict our freedoms I
appreciate are not taken lightly however
I am an independent magic back bencher
and I would not be doing my job if I did
not question government policy and vote
against it where I think it's wrong
I shall oppose to wearing a mask vote
for self-isolation vote against vaccine
passports and all but name
and against mandating inoculation for
NHS workers where natural flow testing
would retain much needed stuff
speakers before me have asked whether
these further laws will be effective
whether they are or not is not as much
an issue for me than how we as a nation
want to live our lives
do we want to fear more restrictions
every time a new variant appears and
they will no is my answer
do we want to damage our economy and all
within every time a new variant appears
no is my answer is working from home
when I can enter a peck part the right
approach no is my answer
do we want to shut down schools and
universities and ruin further young
people's lives knows is the answer
do we want to restrict people's movement
and what they can or cannot do when
there's no evidence to suggest it would
work no is the answer
do we want to see hundreds of thousands
of NHS patients some waiting in agony
for operations because they've been
delayed again no is the answer
do we want to see the hospitality and
Retail sector collapse because we keep
instilling the fear of God into their
customers no is the answer
and do we want to go on spending
taxpayers money on the eye watering
scale that is unaffordable no is the
answer finally a Marvel fan below me can
relax
[Laughter]
do we want the state to give back our
lives and freedom uh Monumental yes is
the cry from many
I had hoped to hear the secretary States
say the respect this afternoon something
along the lines of keep calm and carry
on
and the government will stop bringing in
all these laws
criminalizing the people of England for
breaking rules that many it seems cannot
follow is not the way to win trust and
confidence
advise suggest and courage and take into
the government's confidence is the way
forward I would observe
it's time Madam Deputy speaker to put
fear to one side
put our shoulders back and get on with
our lives
you've got to follow buttons but I will
try yesterday I was asked on a in an
interview am I plotting to revolt and
indeed I see my name on birth lists of
rebels today well let me make it clear I
haven't been plotting I'm not rebelling
and I'm certainly not revolting what I
am doing is in three minutes trying to
scrutinize a really important piece of
legislation affecting all of our
constituents a duty which the labor
party seems to completely have abrogated
in giving a blank check to the
government here today which is why
there's only been single figures of them
here for most of this debate now what
have we learned during this pandemic
we've learned that vaccines work they
are our best defense we also learned
that disproportionate measures have
consequences closing schools has led to
a tsunami of mental health implications
for many of our children we've also
learned that when it's evidence light
and there's a shortage of data some of
the actual outcomes predicted don't
happen we've learned how brilliant the
NHS is but there have been consequences
for non-covered death as well Kobe isn't
the only killer but we've also learned
the difference between modeling and
forecasts too often we've heard that
models predict over a hundred thousand
annual in Daily infections who are going
to be back in September in the turnout
it was nothing like it let's not confuse
modeling for accurate forecasts and
predictions but we've also learned of
mission creep and perhaps we saw that on
Monday we were learning on Sunday we
were learning to manage risk and realize
that you cannot eliminate risk soon
we're going to have Pi row Sigma and Tau
we cannot head for the hills with
knee-jerk emergency measures every time
a new measure comes uh variant comes
along so to scrutinize these regulations
and be prepared to vote against certain
measures they're not ideological it is
to do our job now I'm pragmatic on Mars
I'm quite relaxed I've been wearing a
mask in shops on public transport I
think it's a respectful thing to do I
think it gives Assurance to people who
are scared to come out so I'm not going
to oppose that the measures on
self-isolation are of course Progressive
but on covid passports it's a key part
of Plan B I will vote against I
appreciate they're not vaccine passports
but that is government's plan C and that
is what I fear it's passport Crete we've
already heard about passports for pubs
and others however much we want to get
people vaccinated we do not want a
society where we ask for papers and
deprive people of their Liberty and on
mandatory vaccinations for the NHS I
will certainly vote against it it was
crazy to do it for care workers which we
probably lost forty thousand they're 1.5
million people working in the national
uh Health Service I think it is wrong to
mandate medical procedures but it's
pragmatically stupid when you're going
to lose so many people that you need to
help fight this infection at the sharp
end I know afraid we're going to lose
many more of this we need to base our
decisions on science a holistic impact
and what's proportionate and fair and
these aren't yeah hates hey uh Madam
Deputy speaker I think most people
understood that vaccination was the
route back to normality and despite the
fact that 95 of adults in the UK now
have antibodies and I accept that there
may be some reduction in protection in
antibodies but there's certainly no
evidence that there's any reduction in T
cell production protection despite that
enormous antibody coverage we're being
asked to impose more restrictions on
lives and livelihoods now I've looked in
detail at the London School of hygiene
and tropical medicines modeling and I
think we need to be clear these are
models as my honorable friend has just
said not to forecast our predictions and
they're based on some pretty major
assumptions such as Omicron has the same
severity of disease as Delta the length
of Hospital stay Etc is the same and
these assumptions are becoming more and
more out of date by the day there's no
known benefit to the measures that we're
trying to implement Implement today but
there will be inevitable harms working
from home we've seen last week research
that suggests that those working from
home are 11 times more likely to
experience domestic abuse mask sounds
innocuous in their own right the signal
it has sent and is sending across all of
society including schools is to panic is
to fit and we're seeing schools closing
already today and and saying that they
may not return in the new year and the
hundred thousand ghosts children that
have not returned to school since
lockdown should be a warning to us and
the unintended consequences of
potentially small measures on vaccine
passports I can't support that I think
as my honorable friend said I think it's
discriminatory I think it segregates
people and we have a proud tradition in
this country of standing up for minority
views even when we don't believe them
ourselves and I think in the rush to get
Jabs in arms we shouldn't throw that
tolerance and that respect to the to the
wind
and on the mandatory vaccination of NHS
staff I completely agree with my
honorable friend from East Worthing I
don't think this is about the ideology
of whether or people should or not be
vaccinated it's about the pragmatic
reality that we will lose tens of
thousands of staff at a time when we can
least afford it
but I think this is no longer really a
debate about whether masks work and and
who should have a vaccine and not it's
really about who are we what kind of
society are we creating for our children
do we really care about the the freedoms
that we all took for granted before
2020. now I know people roll their eyes
when conservatives and liberate and
Libertarians start talking about civil
liberties and freedoms but freedom is
not an abstract ideology freedom is what
enables my constituents to see their
family to comfort the dying to go to
school
there has been a permanent change to the
understanding understanding of what
Liberty is in this country that's why I
can't support these measures and I urge
the government return to a society of
freedom and responsibility our
constituents deserve it and they will
rise to the challenge
[Music]
thank you
oh thank you very much Madam speaker
sorry I couldn't hear you over the
um appreciation of my honorable friend's
speech I strongly spot getting back to
Native I've had my job two weeks ago and
my booster jab and I thank all Islanders
are engaged in the vaccination process
in my constituency and I congratulate
the government on a very ambitious
booster program when it comes to the
vote tonight I will accept and Trust
what the government has to say on face
mask and I will do the same for the
daily test which seems infinitely more
sensible than locking people down in um
in hotels I'm not supporting the
passports and I'm not supporting the
mandatory Jabs and threatening the jobs
of 73 000 NHS staff seems to be a very
odd way of trying to support the NHS
there is a wider issue that I do want to
raise uh with the front bench and which
has somewhat colored my judgment and
I've heard nothing to reassure me on the
following points I'm fed up with dubious
forecast and ridiculous extrapolations
the kind of which many of us have talked
about academics and not calling myself
academics have talked about Imperials
forecasts as being hysterical inflated
consistently overconfident lured flawed
spectacularly wrong what has the
government got to say about the
incredibly questionable extrapolations
that it's used I'm tired of all the
leaks Omicron we've Suddenly It's been
leak could kill 75 000. well it could
not and all these doomsday forecasts
leaked at critical moments erode public
Trust
thirdly we're told we have to follow the
signs of course we have to follow the
signs but at the same time that is a
misleading statement because science is
shaped by a your inputs and B your
potential desired outcomes for example
we've had 70 pages of evidence from
Scotland on vaccine passports no
evidence to support their valued uptake
so why are we doing so we're doing so
because of the precautionary principle
that is not science next there has been
an absolute one of the most disturbing
things has been the absolute lack of
context for the statistics used was this
to increase knowledge or to increase
fear our The Honorable friend from New
Forest West said that between 500 and a
thousand people die every day in the
country people dive flu all the time
but it's actually about putting this
information in context and I fear that
too much of this the result has been to
scare people especially the old and
especially now the young as well who are
petrified of covid uh without um and not
taking account of other more genuine and
potentially more damaging threats like
the appalling impact that it's had on
education and so I am going to vote
against the government on two of these
issues tonight but my decision to do so
has somewhat been colored by the last 18
months of policy and I think we need to
improve on that thank you Maria Miller
Madame Deputy speaker the help of the
nation has United this house over the
last 22 months but what we know now
about the impact of covid on the health
of the nation has changed and I think
that's created the debate that we've had
to dot tonight we know that the physical
impact of covid is only part of the
story that mental health is a
significant consideration and that the
impact of covid on our hospitals has to
be considered alongside the impact of
canceling non-covered treatments too and
many members have referred to the impact
on children being schooled at home and
actually the impact on many people about
working at home is not without its risks
as well
but the my right honorable friend the
Secretary of State for health has set
out I think very clearly his case for
the measures before the house today the
new omnicrom variant
um is more transmissible than the Delta
variant and even it if it has the same
impact on our health as the Delta
variant its high transmissibility means
that this new variant has a more
significant it could have a more
significant impact on the number of
people who need urgent Hospital
treatment and stopping the NHS being
overwhelmed has been our objective from
the start I commend the government's
focus on ramping up the booster rollout
which is a vital part of solving the
problems we face now but these
regulations are designed to take the
actions that we can take through the
rollout that step further and to help
keep transmission levels down and that's
why I'll support them today the nature
of human active means that we won't have
a perfect set of neat decisions these
regulations do what's possible not
what's perfect I've got a couple of
questions for the minister if he's able
to deal with them in his summing up and
particularly around the importance of
making sure that we protect the
education of our children as we move
forward and can he provide an update to
members next week even if the house
isn't sitting on the number of
hospitalizations
can't eliminate the risk of covid-19 but
there are a set of these are a set of
time limited measures to help reduce the
risks that our communities face if our
NHS is overwhelmed it not only risks
covert patients but anyone who needs
emergency care through the winter months
we have to act with caution and that's
why I will support these measures today
in totality and I commend the government
for putting the safety of the people we
represent first and I commend them for
the taking that approach Shadow Minister
Andrew Gwynn thank you madam Deputy
speaker this has been a passionate
debate and one that I think reflects the
gravity of the situation before us I
want to sincerely thank members on both
sides of the house for their heartfelt
contributions
since the start of the pandemic labor
have been Crystal Clear we will not play
Party politics with people's lives
especially when it comes to something as
Grave as kovid 19. these precautionary
measures have been recommended by the
chief medical officer the chief
scientific advisors and are based on
scientific evidence they are
proportionate they are necessary and
they will give us time to get people
boosted and better understand the
Omicron variant we have always said that
the government should not have scrapped
guidance on mask wearing and we have
repeatedly stressed the importance of
allowing people the flexibility to work
at home these measures will help us have
a safer Christmas as well as to protect
our NHS from being totally overwhelmed
by this new variant we are also pleased
that the government have taken on our
advice and suggestion of including an
option to present a negative lateral
flow test as an alternative to
vaccination status I'm grateful to the
government for that and for providing
the necessary assurances that these
restrictions will not impede any access
to essential Services we have always
supported measures that have been
necessary to keep people safe and we
will not alter that approach nor will we
pretend that we are in any way satisfied
with the conduct of those on the
opposite benches and of the Prime
Minister in particular over the last few
weeks the Prime Minister has done
irreparable damage to public trust and
thereby undermined vital Public Health
messaging we know that when the country
was most in need and ordinary people
were doing the decent thing and sticking
to the rules the prime minister and his
tinsel clad advisors were making a
mockery of the British public
that being said neither myself nor those
sitting behind me will allow the prime
minister's failure to undermine
necessary Public Health measures because
we know that the Omicron variant is much
more transmissible and that the two
doses of vaccines seem less effective in
tackling it
booster jab does provide an increase in
protection and that is why it is
essential that the boosters are rolled
out and that all those who have yet to
have their primary course come forward
as soon as possible throughout the
pandemic vaccine vaccination has proven
to be the effective tool against the
virus and this Remains the case now we
have repeatedly called on the vaccines
minister to put a rocket under the
booster rollout but we are concerned
about mixed messaging coming from
government over the past few days in his
televised address on Sunday night the
Prime Minister said that people will
have the chance to get the booster
before the new year but in a statement
yesterday the Secretary of State
indicated that the aim instead is to
offer the booster to every adult by the
end of the month meaning the delivery
will wait until January or even February
so when is it can and the minister
clarify for once and for all is the
government rowing back on the target set
just two days ago now we are concerned
about the shambolic lack of tests
available for people across the country
how do we expect fully vaccinated
contacts of cases to take daily tests if
they can't get hold of any and what's
more the regulations requiring
vaccination status or a negative lateral
flow test for entry to certain venues
come into Force tomorrow if people are
unable to get a lateral flow test then
we have a big problem and I hope the
minister will address this on
vaccinations for NHS staff it is our
position that we want everyone working
in the NHS to take up the vaccine the
vaccine is safe and effective and we
should focus on driving up vaccination
rates through persuasion education and
support vaccination not only protects
vulnerable patients but it will protect
staff from severe disease the government
must urgently meet with the Royal
colleges the NHS providers and the
unions to agree a framework of how any
changes agreed tonight will be rolled
out finally Madam Deputy speaker I
wanted to just highlight where the
government are still falling short in
the hope that the minister will take
these points on board before it's too
late
firstly can the government confirm that
we will not waste the Christmas holidays
and ensure that all children who are
eligible to be offered a vaccination
before the end of this month will have
one furthermore can the minister advise
why it is more than 19 months in Sage
first highlighted The crucial role of
good ventilation the government is still
failing to act on their advice and
secondly on sick pay with these measures
being laid before this house the
government should reconsider its
position on sick pay a provision nobody
should have to choose between feeding
their family and doing the right thing
and isolating to conclude Madam Deputy
speak
I appreciate that no
ah wants to bring in measures like this
and I fully appreciate the frustration
of members across the house and from
people across our country that we are
here again being forced to change our
way of life to fight this virus but I'm
afraid that the alternative is far more
serious if we do not take the steps to
protect the NHS it will face a wave of
infections that will likely overwhelm it
labor opposes this prime minister and it
opposes this conservative government but
we will support them for these measures
because we support our NHS we support
the science and when we are faced with
us with a crisis labor will always put
people and the health of the nation
above Party politics
cabinet office Stephen Barkley
Madame Deputy speaker throughout today's
debate we've heard the sincere and
heartfelt views of honorable and writing
all members from across the house
I recognize the strength of feeling and
will turn to each of these strategy
instruments for consideration before the
house but before doing so can I
recognize the constructive approach
taken by the opposition front bench
we are learning more about the only
converiants each day
but we already know that new variants of
covid-19 has spread this quickly and it
will become the dominant variant in
London in the next 36 hours and soon
across the UK as a whole
it is right that we take a cautious
approach to the arithmetic alongside a
strong Communications campaign of the
sort called for by my writable friend
the member for southern northamptonshire
in a moment there is much we still don't
know about this virus
it's a wide range of opinions on its
severity
hospitalizations and deaths always lag
infections by around two to four weeks
we are not at the topping out point in
South Africa so we don't know what the
peak will be
but even a small percentage of
widespread transmission will be very
significant a point quite rightly made
by both the opposition front bench and
the Secretary of State in opening this
debate this is not as some suggest
solely an issue for the NHS
widespread infection and indeed staff
absences would have a wider economic
impact from our supply chains to our
factories
I will obviously give way
State said earlier that you might be
able to provide the house with an update
on this issue of people who have come
back from South Africa and are stuck in
quarantine whether they have to fulfill
the whole of their quarantine I ask
because I've got constituents from the
Rhonda rugby players who are still stuck
they've already done 10 days in South
Africa surely they can be released
tomorrow
there's an extremely important issue I
will come on to that directly and not
just because they are rugby players but
because
issue
I'll give away again don't take the
minister for giving away and The
Minister's absolutely right that we have
to do all we can to stop the spread of
the omicon virus and like me I'm sure
the minister encouraging people to take
the vaccine and the boosters
um Parliament is a really large venue
about 3 000 people work here can the
minister confirm that everybody on his
side of the house has been doubly
vaccinated and and can the minister also
confirm can the minister also confirm
that a covid pass a covered power
situation will be relevant to MPS who
are going to be huddled voting today
there'll be hundreds of us what
protections will MPS have to make sure
that we are safe
well I think my name is W speaker on one
issue I think throughout today's debate
I'm not sure she's been in for the whole
debate but throughout today's debate
there has been consensus across the
house and The Importance of Being
vaccinated and of boosters I think
that's been a point of agreement
obviously the management of the house is
a matter for the speaker Madam W speaker
and not for myself but as the member for
bexell um battle correctly highlighted
he and our constituents will continue to
be able to access all the facilities as
before and when she cites that example I
point out it is still possible to go to
nightclubs just as it is possible to
vote and these measures will not prevent
that
Madame Deputy speaker as well as
omicron's transmissibility we're also
beginning to learn more about the
effectiveness of our vaccines against
boosters were important before Omicron
but they're now absolutely critical and
we have delivered 24 million across the
United Kingdom as of this evening
boosters are without question the single
most effective thing we can do and plan
B buys us more time to get more boosters
into more arms and I pay tribute to my
honorable friend the member for Bosworth
who has a JP himself highlighted the
importance of addressing the 15-minute
wait period to increase the flow of
boosters a decision that the chief
medical officers across the UK have
supported I also concur with my writing
and friend the member for North Somerset
who quite rightly highlighted that the
second dose is important alongside the
booster
Madame Deputy speaker the early evidence
suggests that a booster dose is
extremely effective with analysis by the
UK Health Security Agency showing a
booster dose is 70 to 75 effective at
preventing symptomatic infection
and that is particularly important given
the speed at which this infection is
spreading which means the increase will
be sharper and so its impact more
concentrated over a shorter period of
time
now the The Honorable member for the
Wonder raised uh the issue which the
health secretary in opening the debate
had flagged that he intended to remove
all 11 remaining countries from
England's Red List as of 4 AM tomorrow
the health secretary has urgently
considered the issue of releasing people
from managed quarantine before they have
completed the 10-day isolation
appointments not just by him but the
member for Exeter and a number of
members from across the house
the government's decision is that we
should commit early release of those
people who went to manage quarantine
before these changes to the red list and
require them to follow the relevant
rules as if they have a ride from a
non-red list country
anyone who has tested positive will need
to continue to stay in managed
quarantine
this will require changes to regulations
and we will look to implement this as
quickly as possible and we'll set out
further specific guidance for Effective
individuals imminently Madame Deputy
speaker turning to this strategy
instruments before the house
the weight of scientific evidence shows
that face coverings can make a
difference even if as my right on a
friend the member for Southwest
Wiltshire said and he is a clinician
himself it is the least we can do to
wear these wretched things
so regulation 1400 extending the use of
face coverings is a simple step to help
slow the spread and I welcome the
support of members and indeed even those
with concerns such as the member for
Winchester said he would not oppose such
a measure
so vital
we draw on our testing capacity to keep
written moving and regulation 1415
enables close contacts of confirmed or
suspected covert cases who are fully
vaccinated to take lateral flow tests
every day for seven days and in response
to my right armor from the member for
Tunbridge Wells the lateral flow test
will be self-reported
regulation 14 16 Madam Deputy speaker
regarding entry to venues and events is
one I know honorable members have given
considerable attention
but this is very far from what has been
described as a vaccine passport at Point
my vital friend the health secretary
made in opening this debate this measure
will mean a negative lateral flow test
is required to get into nightclubs and
large events with an exemption for the
double vaccinated once all adults have
had a reasonable chance to get their
booster job we intend to change this
exemption to require a booster
I'm Adam Deputy speaker vaccination has
been and remains our best line of
defense and we have heard many
contributions from across the house on
making vaccination a condition of
deployment for staff in health and wider
social care settings and I recognize how
emotive this issue is
whether it's our Care Homes our
hospitals or other health settings
everyone working in-house on social care
is there to avoid preventable harm to
the people they care for and as the
chief medical officer has rightly said
people who are looking after other
people who are vulnerable do have a
professional responsibility to get
vaccinated a point again another
clinician the members of Central and
North Ipswich made
including Madame Deputy speaker I'm
grateful for all the contributions today
the measures before this will help us to
buy time and deliver boosters which will
provide the best protection against this
variance
vaccination which was already so
important before Omicron
is now doubly important especially in
those settings with some of our most
vulnerable people I commend these
regulations to the house
questions
order to address the point that was
raised by The Honorable lady in the
event of Divisions
um it is likely that there could be a
large number of members voting in one
lobby this evening so the speaker has
agreed that 12 minutes should be allowed
before I call for the doors to be locked
members should accordingly be aware that
they do not need to crowd into the lobby
at the beginning of the boat as there
will be more time to vote than usual
order under the order of the house today
I must now put the questions necessary
to dispose of proceedings on this motion
and the following three motions the
question is the motion relating to
statutory instrument number
1400 as on the order paper as many as
are of that opinion say aye
of the country no
[Music]
play the lobby
question is the most motion related
relating to SI number
1400 as on the order paper as many as
are of that opinion say aye of the
country no tell us for the eyes Michael
Tomlinson and Steve double tell us for
the nose Phillip Hollow bone and Jackie
Doyle price
doors
order
order
the eyes to the right
441 the nose to the left 41.
the eyes to the right
441 the nose to the left 41 so the eyes
have it the eyes have it unlocked
[Music]
minister to move the emotion relating to
statutory instrument number 1415
formally I beg to move the question is
the motion relating to statutory
instrument number one four one five as
on the order paper as many as I of that
opinion say
aye
the country no I think the eyes have it
the eyes have it
minister to move the motion relating to
SI number
1416 formerly I beg to move the question
is the motion relating to statutory
instrument number
1416 as on the order paper as many as
are of that opinion say I
of the country know
[Applause]
the question is the motion relating to
SI number 1416 as on the order paper as
many as are of that opinion say aye the
country no tell us for the eyes Michael
Tomlinson and Steve double tell us where
the nose Philip Hollow bow and Jackie
Doyle prize
the doors
order order
the eyes to the right
369 the nose to the left 126.
thank you
the eyes to the right
369 the nose to the left
126 so the eyes have it the eyes have it
unlocked
minister to move the motion relating to
the draft Health and Social Care Act
2008 regulated activities Amendment
coronavirus number two regulations 2021
formally
the question is As on the order paper as
many as of that opinion say I
the country no
[Applause]
hear the lobby
as on the order paper as many as are of
that opinion say I the country no tell
us for the eyes Michael Tomlinson and
Steve double tell us with a nose Phillip
Hollow bone and Jackie Doyle price
yours
order order
the eyes to the right
385 the nose to the left 100.
the eyes to the right
385 the nose to the left 100 so the eyes
have it the eyes have it unlock
thank you we now come to motion number
four on exiting the European Union
Electronic Communications number five on
agriculture and number six on road
traffic and with the leave of the house
I will take those together minister to
move formally I beg to move the question
is As on the order papers many of us out
opinions say aye
the country no and I think the eyes have
it the eyes have it we now come to
motions number seven on the
International Development Committee
number eight on the international trade
committee number nine on the treasury
committee number 10 on the women
inequalities uh committee
um Bill Wigan
the question is As on the order papers
many of us I've got opinion say aye
the contrary no I think the eyes have it
the eyes have it petition Alexander
Stafford thank you madam Mr Speaker
resident teachers parents and governors
of Aston fence Junior Infant School in
rothervalley are concerned about Road
Safety outside the school a busy road
that during the day is a speed limit of
40 miles per hour they and I listen to
rather Metropolitan Borough Council
calling on them to say adequate steps to
improve Road Safety but as yet no action
has been taken and signs of patrols
please do not work what is needed here
according to school is a permanent 20
mile an hour speed limit the appropriate
traffic High measures are still to
enforce it this position originally
started by the pupils of ass defense
school have been signed by over 100 325
people almost double the number of
students and the petition therefore
States the position level request the
House of Commons call on the government
to urge a rather a metropolitan Borough
Council to extend the existing 20 mile
per hour speeding restrictions around
the school so they are in in Force at
all times rather than just Peak school
hours and the petitioners remain Etc
petition Aston fence school speed limit
extension
I beg to move that this Harps do manager
the question is that this house do now
adjourn Debbie Abrahams yeah yeah thank
you so much Madam Deputy speaker Madam
Deputy speaker last Friday marked the
un's Human Rights Day and the final day
of 16 days of activism against
gender-based violence and I'm delighted
to formally mark this in the chamber
here tonight
as many will know human rights day is
observed annually on the 10th of
December
the day in 1948 United Nations generally
assembly General Assembly adopted the
universal Declaration of Human Rights
the universal declaration is a milestone
document which proclaims the inalienable
rights that every one of us as human
beings are entitled to regardless of
race color rigid religion sex language
political or other opinion National
social social origin Property birth or
other status
its Central tenant under article one
that all human beings are born free and
equal in dignity and rights is as
important today as it was when it was
originally adopted just over 73 years
ago
I have a copy of the Declaration in my
office I believe it's significa its
significance to humanity coming so
shortly after World War II cannot be
underestimated
the hope that we can be better than the
horrors that we witnessed
and yet although recognized as part of
customer international
law human rights abuses are still Rife
even by those countries who are as down
a signatures to the Declaration
the principle of equality and
non-discrimination are at the height of
him at the heart of Human Rights but we
know that across the world including
here in the UK the rights of women are
constantly ignored whether that's our
right to life in some parts of the world
girl babies are seen as less important
than boy babies our right to education
girls are still prevented from being
educated as we're seeing today in
Afghanistan
our right to marry who we wish forced
marriage female genital mutilation are
still happening in the 21st century our
right to work in whatever job we wish
only limited by abilities not by
Prejudice or discrimination and to be be
paid the same as a man doing the same
work
and our right to treat to be treated
equally under the law and have domestic
violence and rape recognized and
responded to as the serious crimes that
they are I do give way to my other
friend but I congratulations
for bringing this forward and very much
support the elderly and what to send but
those other lady not agree that the
increase of domestic violence is
referred to during lockdown has shown
that even in our great nation just here
at home there is an endemic of
gender-based violence that must be
addressed and one way to do that is the
very one that I'm really refer to
through education at Young ages and
through prosecution of domestic abuses
to a much higher degree in other words
pay harder than those who are crying
with the violence
the rise of of domestic abuse during the
pandemic is a real issue I I believe yes
we do need uh further uh and and and
strict enforcement but I also believe we
need to educate not just the victims for
the perpetrators as as well
two weeks of women uh two we oh my
goodness two women a week in the UK will
die at the hands of a partner or
ex-partner and this gender-based
violence has increased during the covert
pandemic as vulnerable friend has just
mentioned
in conflicts across the world where
violence against women including sexual
violence is used as a weapon of War we
must reaffirm and re-emphasize the
women's rights are human rights by
holding Those who commit these
atrocities because they are atrocities
to be held to account
as the UN has stated there are deep
interconnections between ending such
blatant violations of those rights
providing Freedom From Fear and the
right to security dignity quality and
justice
to Mark the International Day for the
elimination of violence against women
last month and the start of 16 days of
activism against gender-based violence I
hosted a virtual event to look at these
issues both locally and internationally
I was drawn by activists experts local
camp campaigners and people from across
Alderman saddleworth to discuss not just
the issues but what we can do to tackle
Marlins against women and girls
I promise that I will certainly who is
that sorry
lady uh for calling the support and
debate
um I personally have been overwhelmed by
the amount of supportive messages I have
received uh over the weekend since my
own story became public and every one of
them has been encouraging and many have
shared their own harrowing stories with
me I know that every campaign every
debate and every story that becomes
public is giving strength and hope to
other women and perhaps the courage that
they need to seek help does The
Honorable lady agree with me that the
belief and support from others has a
crucial role in addressing gender-based
violence
absolutely and I like to place on record
my gratitude for the intervention but
also how how amazing I am about how
strong she is and what she's doing yeah
so as I say I I promised I would raise
the issues they they raised with me in
this place and and for us to to act and
I hope that the minister will be able to
respond to some of the issues I will be
at raising tonight
naturally there remains a massive
challenge we need to change the culture
of our society which needs strong
determinant leadership driving a
multi-faceted strategy that ultimately
determines not just what are acceptable
behaviors but that shifts attitudes and
beliefs
I will do
and I congratulate
on this excellent debate and it's such a
shame that yet again we have made so
little progress would she agree with me
that it's been absolutely shocking in
recent days the revelations of even
people like the police having WhatsApp
groups with very misogynistic content
and that actually every single
institution in our country needs to
really act hard and quickly to try to
explain to people how dangerous how
Insidious this is and how so often it
can lead from attitudes to actual acts
of violence and that we absolutely must
dump it out
I I couldn't agree more with my
honorable friend
um and you know this is one of the
points about the importance of
leadership it has to be led from the the
top and it has to be visible
um that this is just totally
unacceptable Behavior
so women should be paid as I've
mentioned before the same as men if they
do the same equivalent jobs they should
also be protected under the law for
misogynistic hate speech online and
offline in the same way other groups
with protected characteristics are
and in relation to online hate because
it is online hate I hope the government
will adopt the law commissions
recommendation recommendations on this
as well as today's report from The Joint
Committee on the draft online safety
bill which I think really really
strictly strengthens these provisions
boys and girls should be brought up
believing that they are equal to each
other I go every week to particularly
primary schools
and we talk about children girls not
being abled in particular not being able
to access education and they look at me
so why and this is what we need to to
develop and and ensure it's not lost as
these children grow up
and our society and our laws should
reflect that fundamentally our children
need to understand what healthy
relationships look like and the violence
of any sort is unacceptable
this needs to build understanding of
behaviors and attitudes that are abusive
and unacceptable so that women and girls
who are disproportionately affected by
gender-based violence are empowered not
to accept this
need for a national coordinated approach
to education and behavior change on the
ESU but at the moment meadowsville
piecemeal and ad hoc it needs a whole
system public health approach
I welcome the recent introduction of The
Domestic Abuse Act however sustainable
funding is really important and
currently there's no guarantee that this
is going to
um to run on to next year
it also doesn't address the societal and
cultural issues I've mentioned
but there are other issues too the
duties under the ACT are restricted to
support accommodation-based services
rather than thinking about the support
offer as a whole including
community-based services
voluntary sector organization have
consistently said the scope of a duty is
too narrow strengthening the
accommodation support offer is really
valuable but there's also need to better
support victims and their children and
remaining safely in their own home
including for example practical
Sanctuary measures
there's also insufficient investment in
Behavior change work with individuals
who have perpetrated domestic abuse
which is outside of the access scope of
funding
better support for children is also
important the pandemic has placed
greater pressures on services and a safe
life survey of Frontline domestic abuse
Services found that 42 said that they
were not able to effectively support
childhood child victims of diverse and
domestic abuse at this time
if we think of that in the contract in
the context of little Arthur it really
is worrying
support for victims with no recourse to
public funds remains unless you and can
be a barrier for victims in escaping
abuse
the domestic violence destitution
concession allows victim to access
financial support for three months while
they make an application for indefinite
leave to remain under the domestic
domestic violence rule but this option
is only available for those who've come
to the UK on a spousal Visa not for
example on student visas
and local authorities of course bear the
cost in the interim period before the
dvdc is agreed by the home office
in addition to recurrency for services
is around victims of domestic abuse with
complex needs including mental health
issues or substance misuse issues in
some cases their vulnerabilities and
difficulties in leaving an abusive
relationship may also leave them at risk
of having their children removed
these victims often have often
experienced adverse childhood
experiences themselves which gives them
a legacy of trauma in such cases victims
May often have poor engagement with
support services but because they are
often determined as having capacity to
make their own decisions not accepting
help to leave an abusive relationship
can be treated as informed choice
rather than recognizing the impact of
traumatic experiences on their ability
to safeguard themselves
developing the support office offer for
victims with complex needs is a key Gap
and again I'd be very grateful to the
minister for her views on that the Care
Act doesn't accommodate this
in Oldham keep our girls safe at a local
charity works with children and young
people supporting them to learn about
unhealthy relationships child sexual
exploitation grooming and other risks
I've seen that inspirational work and
how they Empower these young people
giving them confidence helping to
improve their self-esteem and inspiring
them to make positive Life Choices
it's just celebrated its 10-year 10-year
anniversary and Cox has set up to
address the gaps in the statutory
services that were weren't available to
young people particularly around
prevention and early intervention
cogs works with young people in familiar
environments such as schools and and
youth centers so it makes it more
accessible
and over the pandemic they worked still
carried on work
um with young people
the chief executive of that group
attended the virtual event that I had
and I just want to pay tribute to her
because her one of her friends had died
a few weeks before and she she came to
the event
she died at the hands of her ex-partner
and I just want to repeat
um Haley's powerful words
I hope it manages
how many times will we look
the other way
how many times will people ask why she
stays
how many times will a world word become
a hand how many times will we have to
make a stand
how many times will we demand some
action
how many times will we be shocked at
their reaction
how many times will a child lose their
mother how many times will she get hurt
by hands that are supposed to love her
how many times will excuses be made
how many times will the ultimate price
be paid
[Music]
I'm very grateful to The Honorable lady
for giving way and I think this is an
excellent debate and she's making a very
powerful case for um the International
Day of Human Rights and I just wondered
whether from that very moving
um words that she just read out whether
she would pay tribute to the human
rights Defenders around the world and in
the United Kingdom including the lawyers
who defend the rights of women all
around the world and I know I chair the
old party Human Rights group and we're
very um we're very uh we're putting a
lot of effort into making sure that
human rights Defenders get the attention
they deserve and particularly women
human rights Defenders around the world
I'm very grateful to my honorable friend
but not right I don't have a friend for
a very timely uh intervention and I
couldn't agree more it's something that
I want to to raise in a moment
particularly in the context of
Afghanistan
um and congratulate her on all her work
that she does for the appg and hopefully
I'll I'll be joining that soon
it's very hard to follow this but I
would appreciate The Minister's response
on the gaps and support for victims and
also the need for a public health
approach with greater focus on
prevention
turning to Human Rights and women's
rights at a global level we know that in
far too many countries they are ignored
as chair of the appg for cashmere I've
repeatedly raised my concerns regarding
the human rights issues across cashmere
which have been documented most recently
in 2019 by the United Nations office for
human rights
the un's reports raised concerns about
women's rights and the reported use of
gender-based violence in German and
Kashmir but in the last few weeks a
prominent human rights activist Karam
pavez has been arrested by the Indian
national investigation agency after he
criticized Indian Security Forces for
killing civilians and surreptitiously
bearing their bodies
I would appreciate a response from the
government on this issue I did raise it
as soon as I became aware of it but to
date I I haven't received any formal
acknowledgment and and the result of the
foreign office's investigations and uh
requests to the Indian High Commissioner
but although the human rights abuse is
occurring in Kashmir may be the longest
running and they certainly are they are
not the only region where they're
occurring again at my virtual event we
heard harrowing testimony about how
sexual and gender-based violence is
consistently used as a weapon of war
with impunity
we heard from Christina Lam who's
written widely on this describing the
Teslas of survivors she had interviewed
from Syria to Myanmar to Nigeria
she said the first time I realized the
scale of rape as a weapon of war was
when I was speaking to the yazidi girls
who were kept to sex slaves by ISIS one
girl I spoke with was passed on 12 times
between people as if she was a goat
one of the hardest top stories I had
ever heard was a 16 year old girl who
was kept as a sex slave by an Isis judge
you told me the worst nicer of her life
was when he came back with a 10 year old
girl and he raped this girl and she
heard the girl crying for her mother all
night it should not be going on
this is a war crime and these women need
Justice
I can't hardly appreciate the minister
describing what the foreign office
is doing getting this Justice for these
women especially given the foreign
sectors a recent announcement of her
campaign
Minister will be aware that we have had
years of words but little action which
is why perpetrators think they can rape
and torture at will
given the foreign secretary describe it
described it as a red line what
consequences are there from the UK
government to those countries that are
not acting to tackle this
the minister bill will be aware of the
plight of millions of our Afghan women
many at serious risk of harm by the
Taliban are many who the UK has an
obligation to
the plight of Fatima Ahmadi a former
Afghan police officer it's just one
example the Taliban beat us so badly and
pulled clumps of hair from her scalp in
front of a nine-year-old son who was
also held at knife point she's since
fled to uh to Pakistan but knows her
time there is also Limited
foreign
and perhaps that's the reason why we
always come to support her in her
debates and Commander for our passion
for the story that she has just today I
applied to the Backpage committee for
the bid on The Afghan Reef Sultan scheme
which would enable people from from
Afghanistan who need to be re patented
to start a new knife to be able to come
the celebrity may be if she had the time
to come to that debate when the
opportunity in the new year will be
there
and yes I'm just literally going to come
on to this so I would like that I'd be
grateful if the minister could could say
what
um given that it's four months on since
the Afghan Citizen's resettlements keep
was announced and we still hasn't got
off the ground what's going to happen
there
I I share the Deep concerns expressed by
several speakers at my event rather
devastating manner in which the Taliban
have brought back the rights of women
and girls and virtually every area
education paid employment Freedom
Movement and so on
in conclusion Madame Deputy speaker
um ultimately the issue of Human Rights
and Freedoms should not be politicized
they are Universal and should be seen as
such across the globe however the wide
gap between men's and women's rights
continues to plague our society the 16
days of activism for the elimination of
violence against women or or one human
rights day is not enough to untangle the
challenges we face
it's time for strong leadership
advocating concrete action to ensure it
happens on a global level our
cooperation with countries should be
based on a common interest in our common
values
cooperation with regimes that do not
value individual rights and freedoms
that do not have the necessary internal
legitimacy or are part of extremist
terms group terrorist groups are
detrimental from our progress
as such human rights need to be the
heart of the UK trade policies and Deals
as one contributor to the event who's
recently escaped persecution said
humanitarian Aid the protection of the
rights of women and children and the
handling of the humanitarian crisis
should not be sacrificed in a game of
politics and individual interests
regimes with such discriminatory
politics and policies should be held
accountable for their actions towards
their people internally and externally
thank you madam
Mr Vicki Ford
Madam Deputy speaker I am very grateful
to The Honorable member for older Mason
saddleworth for securing this debate and
I pay tribute to her for her outstanding
work to tackle violence against women
and girls and to support survivors I'd
also like to thank the honorable member
for Burton for her bravery and her wise
words about the importance of support
for survivors of domestic abuse
I'm privileged to lead on our
International efforts to eradicate
gender-based violence in partnership
with Lord Ahmed of Wimbledon the prime
minister's special representative on
preventing sexual violent in Conflict
The Honorable member raised a specific
situation in Kashmir and I'm only sure
that she gets a written answer
as we all know violence against women
and girls is a global crisis and I will
focus my response in this given time to
the work we're doing internationally
because one in three women will
experience physical or sexual violence
in their lives and at least 200 million
girls and women that live today have
undergone female genital mutilation
child marriage affects one in five girls
we know that violence intensifies in
conflict and humanitarian crisis around
one in five year refugees will
experience sexual violence and the
uk-funded study in South Sudan found
that one in three women had experienced
conflict-related sexual violence often
many times
rates of domestic abuse were even higher
affecting up to 73 percent of women
and recent events in tigray and
Afghanistan have demonstrated yet again
an urgent need to step up and Tackle
this problem we also know that
marginalized groups are particular at
risk including those who are LGT plus
living with a disability or minority
ethnic or religious groups and
furthermore covid-19 has intensified
this Shadow pandemic of violence
the UK is recognized for our leadership
in tackling violence against women and
girls and promoting women's rights but
we have to focus on what more we can do
which is why the foreign secretary has
announced a major push to shatter the
culture of unity around sexual violence
in Conflict we will explore all options
to strengthen Global action including
the possibility of a new international
convention next year we will host a
major Global conference to unite the
world around preventing this violence
and advancing The Wider women peace and
security agenda we're also serious about
stepping up our investments the foreign
secretary has confirmed that we will
restore our spending on women and girls
to what it was before the odor
reductions last month we also announced
over 22 million pounds of new funding
including 18 million to help end child
marriage across 12 countries our work
has already helped avert 25
million child marriages over the last
decade
the UK is also recognized
internationally for our Flagship Watts
Works to prevent violence program this
has demonstrated that projects in homes
schools and communities can have